ओके। सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव।
या
ओके गाइस। सो वी आर लाइव नाउ। लेट मी सी
वंस अगेन।
मुझे एक बार कंफर्म कर दीजिए आप सभी।
ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल क्लियर है। प्लीज
कंफर्म एवरीबॉडी। इफ द ऑडियो एंड वीडियो
इज क्लियर टू यू।
एंड लेट मी चेक मायसेल्फ एज वेल।
नमस्ते नमस्ते
गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग एंड नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी
सभी क्लियर है
बढ़िया
दैट्स गुड ओके हां जी हां जी गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबडी नमस्ते
सभी को एक बार जॉइ करने देते हैं
या
गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग
अ
गुड इवनिंग ठीक है
नमस्ते नमस्ते
हाय ब्रो आई एम डूइंग योर बग बंटी इज़
अपडेटेड या यू कैन कंटिन्यू इट्स ऑल
अपडेटेड
ओके सो नाउ लेट्स बिगिन आवर जर्नी अ एंड
आज से हम आप सबको पता चल ही चुका होगा कि
अ वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट द एक्चुअल एसओसी
टॉपिक्स। अभी तक हम उसके सपोर्टिंग
टॉपिक्स को गो थ्रू कर रहे थे। हम
सपोर्टिंग टॉपिक्स को पढ़ रहे थे। जो
हमारे एसओसी करियर के लिए बीइंग एन एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एक इंपॉर्टेंट फेस था। काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स थे जो हम गो थ्रू कर
रहे थे। एंड नाउ वी हैव द टॉपिक्स दैट
एक्चुअली इज़ द प्रैक्टिकल एसओसी टॉपिक्स।
मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि ये जो प्रैक्टिकल
एसओसी टॉपिक्स हैं जैसा मैंने पहले अभी
आपको बोला हुआ है। आज मैं फिर से आपको बोल
दे रहा हूं। ये इन सारे टॉपिक्स का जो हम
अब पढ़ने वाले हैं इनका बेस वही टॉपिक्स
हैं जो अने
पढ़े हुए हैं। जो पहले हमने करे हुए थे वो
बेस बेस है इन सारे जो अपकमिंग क्लासेस अब
होने वाले हैं आपके। और आज से हमारी एसओसी
के जो ये टॉपिक्स हैं ये एंड की तरफ
बढ़ेंगे। धीरे-धीरे जैसे-जैसे हम आगे
बढ़ेंगे, यह एसओसी सीरीज एंड की तरफ
बढ़ेगी एंड काफी ज्यादा आपको एक्साइटिंग
चीजें मिलने वाली है। हम साथ ही में अ
लैब्स भी करेंगे। तो हमारा अप्रोच ये
रहेगा कि हम पहले कांसेप्ट्स को समझेंगे अ
उन एसओसी टॉपिक्स के एंड देन हम उसके
लैब्स एंड उनके प्रैक्टिकल्स जो है उस पे
जाएंगे। ठीक है? मोस्टली हम सारे जो
प्रैक्टिकल्स एंड जो चीजें हैं वो मोस्टली
हम लैब्स के थ्रू ही करेंगे क्योंकि एसओसी
के प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन और इन चीजों
के लिए लैब एनवायरमेंट होना इज़ वेरीेंट।
आपको रियल एनवायरमेंट कहीं नहीं मिल सकता
है। क्योंकि एसओसी अपने आप में एक सिंगल
मशीन नहीं है। एसओसी अपने आप में एक सिंगल
एंप्लयर एंप्लॉय एंप्लई नहीं है जो एक
बंदा काम कर रहा है और किसी चीज पे दैट इज़
अ ग्रुप ऑफ़ पीपल। राइट? दैट इज़ अ ग्रुप ऑफ़
पीपल। दैट इज वर्किंग ऑन समथिंग राइट तो
आपको वह एनवायरमेंट
जो है ना वह एनवायरमेंट आपको चाहिए वह
एनवायरमेंट अगर आपको मिलेगी तभी जाके आप अ
बेसिकली अह एक अच्छी प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हैं। यू कैन बी अ गुड एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट।
मैं ऐसा मानता हूं कि एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट
बनने के लिए आपका बेसिक बेस तो स्ट्रांग
होना ही चाहिए। साथ ही में आपका
फंडामेंटल जो फंडामेंटल जो चीजें हैं जो
आपको समझनी चाहिए जो आपको क्लियर होना
चाहिए आपके माइंड में। साथ ही में आपको यह
पता होना चाहिए कि एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट
एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल1 एग्जैक्टली
आपका काम है क्या? अब इसी क्वेश्चन के ऊपर
मेरा एक सवाल है सभी लोगों से आप सभी
लोगों से जो भी यहां पे अभी प्रेजेंट है।
बस एक बेसिक क्वेश्चन करना चाहता हूं। आप
सब ने इतने दिनों से फॉलो किया सीरीज को।
इतने टाइम से आप ये सीरीज देख रहे हो।
राइट? आप ये भी जानते हो कि दिस इज जॉब
रेडी ट्रेनिंग प्रोग्राम। तो इंटरव्यूज भी
आप दे पाओगे आगे चल के। मैं बस ये पूछना
चाहता हूं इसको आप टेक्निकली इंटरव्यू
पर्पस से इस क्वेश्चन का आंसर दीजिएगा।
बस एक सिंपल सा क्वेश्चन है। व्हाट डस
एसओसी एल1
डू? व्हाट डस द प्राइमरी रोल ऑफ एन एसओसी
ऑफ अ एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट? इसका जवाब मुझे
चाहिए आप सभी लोगों से यहीं पे चैट में।
प्लीज शॉर्टकट में मत टाइप कीजिएगा।
शॉर्टकट में नहीं लिखिएगा। टाइम लीजिए। एक
साथ पूरा आंसर टाइप कीजिए। ये ऐसे फ्री
इंस्टॉलमेंट्स में टाइप मत करके भेजिएगा
एक-एक लाइन क्योंकि वो उससे पता ही नहीं
चल पाएगा कि आपने क्या बोला है। आप एक
प्रॉपर इसका आंसर लिखिए कि व्हाट इज द
प्राइमरी रोल ऑफ एन एसओसीएल वन? इसको
इंटरव्यू पर्पस से आंसर कीजिएगा। याद
रखिएगा नॉर्मली आंसर नहीं करना है।
नॉर्मली आंसर करेंगे वो तो आपको दिमाग में
आपके होगा। बट इंटरव्यू अगर आप दे रहे हैं
कहीं पे कहीं पे यू आर सामने इंटरव्यू है
यही क्वेश्चन वो पूछता है आपसे व्हाट इज़ द
प्राइमरी रोल ऑफ़ एन एसओसीएल वन? तो आप
एग्जैक्टली किस तरीके से टेक्निकली
टेक्निकल वर्ड्स को यूज़ करते हुए क्या
आंसर करेंगे? सो आई जस्ट वांट टू नो फ्रॉम
एवरीबडी हियर दोज़ हु कैन आंसर इफ यू कैन
नॉट आंसर नो नो इशूज़ नॉट एट ऑल आप लीव कर
दीजिएगा। आप इसको आंसर को स्किप करते आप
नहीं भी बोलेंगे चलेगा। आप आंसर नहीं भी
देंगे चलेगा। बट अगर आपके अंदर है थोड़ी
भी चीज कि हां मुझे आती है वो आंसर यू कैन
स्पीक देन प्लीज डेफिनेटली स्पीक। सो जस्ट
अब यहां पे एक आंसर आया है टू एनालाइज द
लॉक्स एंड अलर्ट्स। वेरी वेरी रॉन्ग एंड
वेरी वेरी बैड आंसर। मैंने ऑलरेडी बोला
इंटरव्यू पर्पस से दीजिएगा। अगर आप ऐसे
आंसर करेंगे तो आप कभी भी इंटरव्यू को
क्लियर नहीं कर पाएंगे। यू वुड नेवर
क्लियर एन एसोसिएट वन इंटरव्यू। अगर आप
ऐसे आंसर देंगे जैसे इन्होंने दिया है टू
एनालाइज़ द लॉक्स एंड अलर्ट्स। ऐसा थोड़ी
ना होता है। वहां पे बहुत सारे कैंडिडेट्स
बैठे हैं आपके साथ। आपके जैसे टैलेंटेड
कैंडिडेट्स हैं। इंटरव्यूअर आपको क्यों
लेगा? उसको लेगा ना जो आपसे बेटर आंसर कर
पा रहा है। राइट? तो पता तो सबको है कि
लॉग एनालिसिस करता है। अलर्ट्स को देखता
है। बट उसको एक टेक्निकल फॉर्म में
रिप्रेजेंट करना अपने बातों से बोलना वो
मैटर करता है इंटरव्यूअर के लिए। ठीक है?
तो बताइए मुझे सभी लोग। लेट्स सी।
आई विल एनालाइज द आंसर्स। आई विल एनालाइज
द आंसर्स।
ओके
चलिए यहां पे कुछ आंसर्स आए हैं। मैं इसको
थोड़ा सा आपको एनालाइज़ करके बता देता हूं
क्योंकि ये काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है। आपको लगता
है कि आप चीजें सीख रहे हैं। आप क्लासेस
कर रहे हैं। दैट्स फाइन। आपको लगता है
अच्छी बात है। बट बट यहां पे आपको बोलना
भी आना चाहिए। राइट? आपको चीजों को
एक्सप्लेन करना सामने को बताना भी आना
चाहिए। अब यहां पे कुछ आंसर्स आए हैं।
यहां जो छोटे आंसर्स हैं मैं उनको बिल्कुल
ही स्किप कर रहा हूं क्योंकि वो आंसर
परफेक्ट नहीं है। सीधा-सीधा है। यहां पे
जैसे एक आंसर आया हुआ है यहां पे टू
मॉनिटर ट्रायग एस्केलेट एंड डॉक्यूमेंट
अलर्ट। दिस इज़ अ वेरी रॉन्ग अप्रोच रॉन्ग
आंसर। रॉन्ग तरीका आंसर करने का। आप
इंटरव्यूअर को ऐसे आंसर नहीं कर सकते हैं।
यहां पे एक आंसर है Suzzo का। बेसिकली
एसओसी एल1 ट्राईक डॉक्यूमेंटेशन एंड
एस्केलेशन टू L2 एंड L3 इफ रिक्वायर्ड
वेरी रॉन्ग आंसर मतलब देखो मतलब सही हो
सकता है कि हां वो ये काम करता है फाइन बट
यहां पे मैंने पूछा कि एक टेक्निकली आप एक
टेक्निकल मतलब आप इंटरव्यू देने जा रहे
हैं ना तो आप इंटरव्यूअर के सामने कैसे
बोलेंगे उस चीज को आंसर कैसे करेंगे दैट्स
द मेन पॉइंट तो यहां पे विदिशा एज अ
एसोसिस एनालिस्ट योर टास्क इज़ टू डिटेक्ट
एंड इन्वेस्टिगेट अटैक रॉन्ग आंसर यहां पे
क्वेश्चन है टू कंटीन्यूअसली मॉनिटर
सिक्योरिटी इवेंट्स एंड अलर्ट्स
आइडेंटिफाई पोटेंशियल सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंस
परफॉर्म इनिशियल एनालिसिस एंड एस्केलेट
कंफर्म थ्रेट्स टू हायर लेवल एनालिस्ट यह
आंसर
बहुत अच्छा एक आंसर कहा जा सकता है बाय
मयंक सिन्हा जिन्होंने ये आंसर करा है। द
प्राइमरी रोल ऑफ एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट इज़ टू
कंटीन्यूअसली मॉनिटर सिक्योरिटी इवेंट्स
एंड अलर्ट्स। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
आइडेंटिफाई पोटेंशियल सिक्योरिटी
इंसिडेंस। गुड। परफॉर्म इनिशियल एनालिसिस।
वेरी गुड। एंड एस्केलेट कंफर्म्ड थ्रेट्स।
कंफर्म थ्रेट्स का यहां मतलब है ट्रू
पॉजिटिव थ्रेट्स। यहां कंफर्म थ्रेट्स का
यही मतलब है इट्स अबाउट ट्रू पॉजिटिव
थ्रेट्स एंड कंफर्म्ड थ्रेट्स टू हायर
लेवल एनालिस्ट्स या टू सीनियर एनालिस्ट्स
लाइक एल2 और एल थ्री मोस्टली एल2ज़ को ही
मतलब एस्केलेट किए जाते हैं। L2 और L3 वुड
बी आल्सो फाइन। अपने हायर सीनियर
एनालिस्ट्स को वो क्या करते हैं? टू
एस्केलेट। एज एन एसोसिएल वन आपका प्राइमरी
रोल जो होता है वो
अलर्ट जो होता है उसको मॉनिटर भी करना है
और अलर्ट को जो अलर्ट से नॉइज़ है उसको
हटाना है। नॉइज़ का मतलब है
कि फालतू चीजें जो फॉल्स नेगेटिव्स हैं जो
फॉल्स नेगेटिव्स हैं उनको हटाना है। और जो
ट्रू पॉजिटिव्स हैं जो थोड़े ऐसे अलर्ट्स
हैं जो अह आपको लगता है नहीं ये तो
बिल्कुल कंफर्म है कि दिस इज़ एन दिस इज़ अ
कंफर्म्ड अटैक। दिस इज़ एन कंफर्म्ड थ्रेट।
तो वैसे चीजों को आपको एस्केलेट करना है
अपने सीनियर को। आप रेमडेशन का काम नहीं
करते। एसओसी एल1 जो है रेमेडी का काम नहीं
करता। एसओसी एल1 जो है रिज़ॉल्व नहीं करता।
एसओसी एल1 जो है उस चीज़ को काउंटर मेज़
नहीं करता। एसओसी एल1 का ये काम नहीं है
रिज़ॉल्व करना। थ्रेट्स को। थ्रेट्स को
पूरी तरीके से रिज़ॉल्व कर देना। थ्रेट्स
को पूरी तरीके से खत्म कर देना। दिस इज़ द
नॉट वर्क ऑफ़ एन एसओसी एल1। तभी तो एसओसी
एल1 जूनियर रोल कहलाता है। आपका काम है
अलर्ट्स को मॉनिटर करते रहना, देखते रहना।
कोई अलर्ट आ रहा है तो भैया उसके ऊपर अब
तुम लग जाओ। उसकी लॉगिन, उसकी
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन ये सब करो और पता लगाओ कि
इसमें से कंफर्म्ड थ्रेट्स या ट्रू
पॉजिटिव थ्रेट्स कितने हैं और उनमें से जब
ये कंफर्म हो जाए तो उनको अपने सीनियर को
पास ऑन कर दो या उनको एस्केलेट कर दो। दिस
इज़ अ एक्चुअल वो डेफिनेशन। ठीक है? अच्छी
बात है। मयंक का अच्छा यहां पे है। एसओसी
एल1 इज़ प्राइमरी डिफेंडर इन एसओसी एंड
मॉनिटर नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक एंड सिस्टम
अलर्ट्स एंड ट्रैक थ्रेट्स। ठीक है? ट्रैक
करते हैं। ठीक है? बट यहां एस्केलेशन वाली
पॉइंट डालनी बहुत जरूरी है। जब भी आप इसका
आंसर करेंगे, यू शुड बी यू मस्ट पुट द
एस्केलेशन टर्म इन योर आंसर। क्योंकि
एस्केलेशन करना यह बहुत मेजर रोल है
एसओसीएल वन का। एस्केलेशन करना ही करना है
उनको। दिस इज़ देयर मेजर प्राइमरी रोल। यू
हैव टू पुट इन आउट। ठीक है? द प्राइमरी
रोल ऑफ़ अ सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेंस सेंटर लेवल
एल1 एनालिस्ट इज़ टू एक्ट एज़ द फर्स्ट लाइन
ऑफ़ डिफेंस। गलत आंसर है। अह गलत आंसर मतलब
कि नॉट परफेक्ट आंसर।
ओके। यहां पे क्वेश्चन ये यहां पे एक आंसर
है सुदीप का। एज अ एल1 एनालिस्ट एसोसिएशन
एनालिस्ट मॉनिटर सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट 24 * 7
यूजिंग एसआईएम टूल। ठीक है? एसआईएम होता
है सोनार भी
है और बहुत सारे हैं वैसे तो आई एनालाइज
लॉग्स एंड अलर्ट्स टू आइडेंटिफाई सस्पेश
एक्टिविटी वेरीफाई वेदर दे आर रियल
थ्रेट्स और फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स एंड टू
एस्केलेट टू द सीनियर एनालिस्ट। ठीक है?
सही है। इस तरह के आंसर होने चाहिए।
बिल्कुल ठीक है।
हबीबी एज एन एसोसिएशन इन अ फर्स्ट पर्सन
टू इंटरेक्ट विद द वर्क लाइक द फर्स्ट
ऑर्डर लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस एंड मेनी मॉनिटर दे
आर द फॉल्स। ठीक है। चलिए। द प्राइमरी रोल
ऑफ़ एसएसए टू बेसिक सिक्योरिटी।
ठीक है। ठीक है। ठीक है। कुछ लोगों ने तो
बिल्कुल सही आंसर किया है। बट जैसा मैंने
बताया मयंक का जो आंसर था वो काफी अच्छा
था। उस तरह से ही आपको अगर उसके आंसर से
आपका आंसर मैच कर रहा है तो बिल्कुल सही
है। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। बाकी जो है कोई
प्रॉब्लम बाकी जो है वो डजंट मैटर। ठीक है
ना?
सर आई आंसर्ड फर्स्ट बट यू डिड नॉट नोटिस
एंड रीड माय मैसेज। ओके टेक गाइस। हो सकता
है आपका मैसेज मिस हो गया होगा। अह आई
मॉनिटर एसआईएम अलर्ट्स एनालाइज लॉग्स
फ्रॉम डिफरेंट सोर्सेस इन्वेस्टिगेट
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी एस्केलेट इंसिडेंस
व्हेन रिक्वायर्ड यस टू द सीनियर एनालिस्ट
ठीक है
ओके प्लीज डोंट रिपीट द मैसेजेस प्लीज
डोंट रिपीट सेंड रिपीटेड मोड अ वो स्पैम
होता है और आपको फिर वह यहां से बैन कर
दिया जाएगा। सो प्लीज मत कीजिएगा ऐसा। ठीक
है? चलिए तो ये तो एक छोटा सा मैंने आपको
ओवरव्यू दे दिया। कैसे आपको आंसर करना है।
बिफोर वी स्टार्ट आपको पहले ही बता देता
हूं यहां पे सिंपल सा यहां पे किसी भी
लाइव
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पे लाइव सेक्शन में
जाइएगा। और हां एक और चीज एक एक
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है आप सबों के लिए। आप सब
ने देखा होगा डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का यह जो
बैनर है YouTube बैनर वो चेंज हो चुका है।
यू मस्ट हैव सीन और अभी आप देख सकते हैं।
इट्स नाउ द बैनर वाज़ प्रीवियसली डिफरेंट।
नाउ द बैनर इज़ अह साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड
टेक्नोलॉजी यूनिवर्सिटी। क्वालिटी
ट्रेनिंग्स एंड स्किल्स आर डिलीवर्ड हियर।
यह बैनर चेंज करने के पीछे देयर आर अह
मेजर चेंजेस देयर आर मेजर थिंग्स दैट इज़
गोइंग टू हैपन विथ डिफ्रॉनिक्स एंड फॉर यू
गाइस। एंड देयर आर मेजर थिंग्स दैट इज़
गोइंग टू बी कमिंग बाय डिफ़्रोनिक्स फॉर यू
ऑल। एंड दैट्स व्हाई इट्स रिटेन हियर। एंड
यह रिफ्लेक्ट करता है उस मेजर चेंजेस को।
एंड हम कुछ ऐसा बनाएंगे आने वाले टाइम में
कि
इंडिया का सबसे एक बड़ा हब बनाएंगे साइबर
सिक्योरिटी प्लस अदर टेक लर्निंग हब जहां
पर आपको चीजें मिलेंगी बट क्वालिटी
मिलेंगी। ऐसा नहीं मिलेगा। ऐसा चीज नहीं
आपको ऐसी वीडियोस या ऐसी क्लासेस नहीं
मिलेंगी जिसके एंड में आपको हम पेड
कोर्सर्सेस सेल करने की कोशिश करें उनके
थ्रू। जैसे कि एसओसी के वीडियो चल रही हैं
तो इसमें कोई भी कॉल टू एक्शन नहीं होता
है। ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं होता है कि हां आपने
ये आज की क्लास 25th क्लास आपने कर ली तो
आप इसके बाद इस कोर्स में एनरोल कर लो।
ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं होता है। राइट? बगमाउंट
में भी नहीं था। किसी में भी नहीं होता
है। हमको तो हम उस टाइप की एक क्वालिटी
कंटेंट क्वालिटी एजुकेशन आपको प्रोवाइड
करेंगे। इस चैनल के थ्रू बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट प्रोवाइड करेंगे। कोई पैसा आपसे
नहीं लिया जाएगा। हां हम हम अपनी पेड
कोर्सेज और जो भी चीजें हैं जो ट्रेनिंग्स
है वो तो हमारी ऑब्वियसली रेगुलर चलती
रहेगी बट वो भी हम बहुत ही अफोर्डेबल
प्राइसेस में हम आपको प्रोवाइड करने वाले
हैं। इसकी शुरुआत हमने वैसे कर दी है कि
हमारी वीएपीटी की ट्रेनिंग हमारी वीएपीटी
की जो ट्रेनिंग होती है जो कि एक जॉब
ओरिएंटेड सिक्स मंथ का ट्रेनिंग इंटर्नशिप
मॉक इंटरव्यू जिसमें से 10 बच्चे प्लेस्ड
हुए थे फर्स्ट बैच से उसकी फी भी हम
नेक्स्ट टाइम से हमारी 2000 फी होती है
उसकी 20000 फी होती है उसको हम नेक्स्ट
टाइम से रिड्यूस कर रहे हैं एंड वी आर अह
रिड्यूसिंग इट टू 15000 एंड 15000 पे ही
वो ट्रेनिंग आया करेंगी। ठीक है? तो हम
उसको भी रिड्यूस कर रहे हैं 15,000 वी आर
डूइंग दैट एंड हम और भी मल्टीपल ट्रेनिंग
जो जैसे हमारे डीसीएसपी का भी फी 20,000
था। हम उसको भी रिड्यूस कर रहे हैं। एंड
वी आर रिड्यूसिंग दैट टू 15,000 अगेन। तो
हम अपनी ट्रेनिंग की मैक्सिमम फी उसी रेंज
में लेके जा रहे हैं। 20 पहले था। हम उसको
रिड्यूस करके 15 तक लेने की कोशिश कर रहे
हैं। हालांकि इससे दिक्कतें थोड़ी होंगी
क्योंकि हमें ट्रेनर को फी देनी होती है।
हमें मार्केटिंग का करना होता। बहुत कुछ
होता है। तो वी विल बी गेटिंग टू दोज़
आल्सो। हम धीरे-धीरे उसको करेंगे ब्रॉड
स्केल पे कवर करेंगे। बट स्टिल आपके
बेनिफिट के लिए होगा। और साथ ही इस चैनल
के थ्रू आपको अभी मल्टीपल चीजें आने वाली
हैं जो आपको मिलने वाली है इस चैनल के
थ्रू। बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट आपको सीखने
को मिलेगा। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है?
पता चल जाएगा। नेक्स्ट फ्री को जो भी
रहेगा आपको पता चल जाएगा। किसी भी आप लाइव
सेक्शन में आके एसओसी के किसी भी वीडियो
को उठा के इसको आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा। या
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक मिल जाएगा। दो
दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp चैनल का
मिलेगा, एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का मिलेगा। एक
लिंक WhatsApp चैनल ओपन करेगा जो कि आपको
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी चैनल ओपन होगी। एंड यह
आप WhatsApp चैनल के ऊपर जाके डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
सर्च करके भी आप इसको फॉलो जरूर कर
लीजिएगा क्योंकि हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स के
साइट से कोई भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी अपडेट्स
कुछ भी सबसे पहले आपको इसी चैनल पे मिलेगी
और कहीं भी नहीं मिलेगी। सबसे पहले आपको
इसी चैनल पे इसीलिए हमारे साथ 13,000 लोग
लगभग इससे जुड़ चुके हैं। जल्दी हम इसको
25,000 पीपल तक पहुंचाना चाहते हैं। तो
आपकी यहां पे बहुत बड़ी एक
सहयोग की जरूरत पड़ेगी क्योंकि आप फॉलो
करेंगे तभी आप यहां तक पहुंच पाएंगे
पहुंचा पाएंगे इस पूरे चैनल को। तो जाइए
इसको फॉलो कीजिएगा। फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है। कोई
पैसा नहीं लगेगा। दूसरा जो आपको लिंक
मिलेगा वो एसओसी का ग्रुप स्पेसिफिक टू
एसओसी इस सीरीज के ग्रुप है जहां पे आपको
एसओसी से रिलेटेड जितने भी नोट्स
रिसोर्सेज अपकमिंग अ जो क्लासेस हैं उसके
बारे में या सर्टिफिकेट्स जो होने वाले
हैं उसके बारे में या आपके इंटरव्यूज
राउंड जो होने वाले हैं उसके सब कुछ आपको
इसके बारे में सब कुछ आपको इसी ग्रुप में
बताया जाएगा। तो ये दोनों जरूर कर
लीजिएगा। उसके साथ ही यहां पे ये Lindin
प्रोफाइल है मेरी। आप आके यहां पे लगभग
13,000 लोग जो हैं मुझसे जुड़े हुए हैं
यहां पे फॉलो कर रहे हैं। एंड यू कैन
आल्सो कम एंड कनेक्ट विद मी। मुझसे जुड़
सकते हैं। मुझसे बातें कर सकते हैं। कोई
चीज हो कुछ हो मैसेज कर सकते हैं। क्वेरी
कर सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर एंड यू कैन
इंटरेक्ट विद मी। ठीक है?
यहीं पे आप डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च करेंगे तो
हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
Lindin पेज हमारी कंपनी का पेज आपको मिल
जाएगा। इस पेज को भी जरूर फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। इसका रीज़न यह है कि हमें हमारी
तरफ से जो भी पर्टिकुलर अपडेट्स कंपनी के
रिगार्डिंग कोई नई कोर्स हो गई, नई फ्री
कोर्स, पेड कोर्स या कोई गिव अवे या कुछ
भी होता है वो इसी पेज के थ्रू होता है।
अभी रिसेंट गिव अवे का रिजल्ट भी इसी पेज
पे आया हुआ था जिसमें कि हमने गिव अवे के
जो विनर्स थे उनको सेलेक्ट किया था। तो इस
पेज को फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा। यहां पे
एक्स का पेज है हमारा यानी कि इस हमारा
Twitter हैंडल एक्स का पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी हैंडल। इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यह
मेरा पर्सनल Instagram पेज है। यू कैन कम
एंड यू कैन फॉलो मी हियर एज वेल। एंड साथ
ही ये डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल से हमारे
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की Instagram पेज है जहां
आपको इनेशनल कंटेंट जो है रील के फॉर्म
में मिल जाती है। यह हमारी वेबसाइट है जो
अभी आपको यहां पे दिख रही है। रिवैंप होने
वाली है। पूरी न्यू होने वाली है। यहां पे
आपको नंबर मिल जाएगा जिस पे आप कांटेक्ट
करके हमसे कोई भी क्वेरी क्वेश्चंस कर
सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाएंगे तो आपको हमारे
कोर्सर्सेस यहां पे लिस्टेड मिल जाएंगे।
आप कोर्सर्सेस को भी एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। तो ये तो पूरी बात हो गई। अब यहां पे
हम चलते हैं आज की क्लास की तरफ जो कि
काफी एक्साइटिंग होने वाली है साथ ही में
क्योंकि आज प्रैक्टिकल सेशन भी होगा आपका
लैब लैब वगैरह भी इसमें इंक्लूड होगा तो
हम उसको भी कवर करेंगे। चलिए तो आज से हम
एसओसी की एक्चुअल जर्नी जो है वो स्टार्ट
कर रहे हैं। एज आई सेड यू ऑल कि एसओसी की
जो प्रैक्टिकल क्लासेस हैं जो टॉपिक्स हैं
उनको हम स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं। उसमें
सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट करेंगे एसओसी के
वर्क बुक्स के बारे में हम जानेंगे। देन
हम एक्स एसओसी के लुकअप्स के बारे में
जानेंगे। देन मैट्रिक्स के बारे में
जानेंगे। देयर आर अह सम मल्टीपल थिंग्स
दैट वी आर गोइंग टू कवर टुडेेज़। इन सबके
लैब्स भी आज कवर होंगे। तो आप लैब में
हमारे साथ-साथ एक रियल टाइम में आप लैब
में आप आंसर्स करेंगे। आप सभी आप सब मिलके
काम करेंगे। इसमें मजा आएगा आपको। तो सबसे
पहले हम समझते हैं एसआईएम वर्क बुक क्या
होते हैं? देखिए ये जो टॉपिक्स हैं। ठीक
है?
यस यू कैन कंटिन्यू कंटिन्यू
सर मेरी अमरोहा पुलिस में इंटर्नशिप लग
गई। डिफ्रॉनिक्स ने काफी हेल्प करी है।
थैंक यू सर। यू आर वेलकम सिक्योरलर 786
एंड कांग्रेचुलेशंस फॉर गेटिंग सिलेक्टेड
एस एन इंटर्न इन अमरोहा पुलिस इंटर्नशिप
राउंड। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
बलवंत सिंह वी आर विद यू सर ऑलवेज सपोर्ट
डिफ्रॉनिस एकडमी थैंक यू बलवंत
सर 100 के में क्या गिव अवे होगा 100 के 1
लाख्राइबर पुणे होने पे बहुत बड़ा गिव अवे
हम कर सकते हैं बट डिपेंड करता है कि आप
कितनी जल्दी वहां तक लेकर जाते हैं। अभी
तो हम 500 के आसपास हैं।
50000्राइबर मार्क अचीव करने में हमें 3
साल लगभग लग गए हैं। बट 50,000 से 1 लाख
पहुंचने में आपकी जो है वह रोल बहुत
ज्यादा है। हो सकता है आप लोग एक साल में
उतना करा पाए या 2 साल में आई डोंट नो बट
जितना जल्दी आप कराएंगे उतनी बड़ी गिव अवे
मैं प्रॉमिस करता हूं। ठीक है? अगर एक साल
में हमारे 1 लाख हो जाते हैं एक साल के
अंदर तो बिलीव मी देयर विल बी अ बिग गिव
अवे जो आपने कभी इमेजिन नहीं करा होगा वो
होगा हमारे साइड से।
लेट्स सी
फ्री कोर्सर्सेस कंटिन्यू रहेंगे। ठीक है?
देखो अब ये जो टॉपिक्स हैं जैसे वर्क बुक
आपका टॉपिक है। आगे और टॉपिक्स हैं। ये
टॉपिक्स आपके लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट इसलिए
हैं क्योंकि जब आप हम आगे की तरफ एसआईएम
टूल्स की तरफ बढ़ेंगे। ठीक है? ठीक है?
सोनार वगैरह ये सब थोड़ा जब पढ़ेंगे एसआईएम
वगैरह के बारे में तो उस टाइम पे इन चीजों
का ध्यान रखना बहुत जरूरी है। क्योंकि जब
आप एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड को समझेंगे एज अ एसओसी
एल1 जब उसको यूज़ करेंगे तो ये टॉपिक्स अगर
आपको नहीं पता है। आपको नहीं पता है लाइक
कि मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट क्या होता है? मीन
टाइम टू
लाइक रिसोंड या रेमेडी क्या होता है? तो
आप बेसिकली नहीं कर पाएंगे। उसको यूज़ ही
नहीं कर पाएंगे इस एम टूल को। मैं आपको
अगेन अगेन फिर से बोल रहा हूं बार-बार
इसलिए बोल रहा हूं ये टॉपिक्स अगर आपको
क्लियर नहीं होंगी तो आप एसआईएम टूल जो आप
आप में से बहुत लोग बोलते हैं ना सर
प्रैक्टिकल कराओ ना सर प्रैक्टिकल कराओ ना
एस एसओसी में सर आपने कुछ करा ही नहीं
प्रैक्टिकल तो जब हम उस चीज अभी तो
स्टार्ट ही कर रहे हैं आज से बट जब एसआईएम
डैशबोर्ड वाली चीज जब आएगी वहां जो चीजें
करने को मिलेगी तो वहां पे अगर ये टॉपिक्स
क्लियर नहीं है तो आपको एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड
का कुछ नहीं समझ में आने वाला है और आप एक
एसओसी एल1 बन ही नहीं पाएंगे क्योंकि वह
एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड को समझना और उसको
एग्जैक्टली कैसे यूज़ करना है वह समझना
टेक्निकिटी उसकी समझना इज़ वेरीेंट फॉर
एसोसिएल वन तभी आपको जॉब लगेगी क्योंकि
किसी भी एसोसिएल वन जॉब में आप एसआईएम को
देखेंगे वहां जेडी में बिना उसके तो एस
एसोसिएल वन की जॉब होती ही नहीं है। सो
वर्कब क्या होता है? पहले ये समझेंगे। द अ
वर्कबुक इज़ एन इंटरेक्टिव कैनवस बेस्ड
रिपोर्ट। इट पुल्स डाटा फ्रॉम वेरियस
लॉग्स एंड ट्रांसफॉर्म रॉ टेक्स्ट इनू
चार्ट्स, मैप्स एंड ग्रीड्स।
यह वर्क बुक होता है। ठीक है? यह कैनवस वे
रिपोर्ट होता है। एक समझ लीजिए एक रिपोर्ट
होता है। बस दैट्स इट। डाटा लॉग्स वगैरह
जो होता है अलग-अलग जगहों से यह लाता है।
ठीक है? अलग-अलग वेरियस लॉग से डाटा वोटा
निकालता है और उसको चार्ट्स, मैप्स,
ग्रिड्स इन सब में थोड़ा मतलब
विजुअलाइजेशन आपको करके दिखा देता है।
इसके कुछ की फीचर्स क्या है? रियल टाइम
मॉनिटरिंग। अनलाइक अ स्टैटिक पीडीएफ
रिपोर्ट। यह एक नॉर्मल पीडीएफ रिपोर्ट
नहीं होता। वर्कब अपडेट्स ऐज़ न्यू लॉग्स
फ्लाई इन। वर्कब जो है वह अपडेट्स होती
रहती है। अपडेट होते रहती है। जैसे-जैसे
लॉग्स आते रहते हैं, नए-नए डाटा आते रहते
हैं। वह अपने आप को अपडेट करती रहती है।
इंटरेक्टिविटी क्या है? यू कैन क्लिक अ
फेल्ड लॉग इन स्पाइक ऑन अ बार चार्ट।
फेल्ड लॉग इन स्पाइक जो है अगर कोई फेल्ड
लॉग इन का स्पाइक हो रहा है उस पे आप
क्लिक कीजिए। एंड द वर्कब कैन ऑटोमेटिकली
फ़िल्टर द रेस्ट ऑफ़ द पेज टू शो ओनली दोज़
स्पेसिफिक इवेंट्स। तो मतलब उसमें कोई एक
ऐसे स्पाइक कोई एक मतलब ऐसे है कोई चार्ट
है। ठीक है? बाहर चार्ट मान लो उसमें
फेल्ड लॉग इन का एक चार्ट है। उस पे अगर
आपने क्लिक किया जैसे फेल्ड लॉग इन वाले
ऑप्शन पे तो अब वो क्या करेगा? जितने भी
पेजेस फेल्ड लॉग इन वाले रिपोर्ट्स जो शो
करने वाले हैं उनको दिखाना शुरू कर देगा।
कंसोलिडेशन यू कैन कंबाइन डेटा फ्रॉम
मल्टीपल सोर्सेस। जैसे मल्टीपल आपके लॉग
सोर्सेस से आप डाटा कंबाइन कर सकते हैं।
फायर लॉक्स ऑफिस का जो लॉग होता है, एंड
पॉइंट का लॉग होता है या कोई सा भी लॉग इन
अ सिंगल पेन ऑफ ग्लास। ठीक है? तो एक जगह
पे आप सारे लॉग्स को क्या कर सकते हैं?
कंबाइन कर सकते हैं, कलेक्ट कर सकते हैं
मल्टीपल सोर्सेस से। अब इसका यूज़ केस क्या
है? एसओसी के लिए मैं आपको यह भी बताता
हूं। इंसिडेंट ओवरव्यू अ डैशबोर्ड शोइंग
हाउ मेनी हाई सीवियरिटी अलर्ट्स आर ओपन
एंड हु इज़ असाइन टू देम। मतलब कि यह
बेसिकली एक डैशबोर्ड है जो कि शो करेगा कि
कितने हाई सीवियरिटी के अलर्ट्स जो हैं वो
ओपन है एंड किसको असाइन है वो सारे
अलर्ट्स। ठीक है? क्योंकि एसओसी एल1 की
एल1 में मल्टीपल टीम मेंबर्स होते हैं।
ठीक है? एक ही L1 एनालिस्ट नहीं होता है।
L1 के मल्टीपल एनालिस्ट होते हैं। L2 में
फिर मल्टीपल एनालिस्ट्स होते हैं। L3 में
मल्टीपल एनालिस्ट होते हैं। शिफ्ट वाइज
काम चलती है। क्योंकि ये जो काम है ये जो
जॉब है ये 24 * 7 है। तो एक बंदे का काम
मान लो सुबह से लेके शाम तक का है। दूसरे
बंदे का शाम से रात तक का या एक सुबह से
शाम तक के शिफ्ट में ही मल्टीपल बंदे काम
कर रहे हैं। अगर कोई बड़ी कंपनी है, बड़ा
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है तो उससे तो ये
लॉग्स जो हाई सीवियरिटी के हैं वो किनको
असाइन है? हो सकता है कि तीनचार एसओसी एल1
वहां पे काम कर रहे हैं तो उसमें से एक
बंदे को वो असाइन हो। थ्रेट हंटिंग
विजुअलाइजिंग पैटर्न्स इन नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक
टू स्पॉट बेकनिंग बिहेवियर। मतलब कि आप
पैटर्न्स नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक्स में पैटर्न्स
को विजुअलाइज कर सकते हैं वर्कबुक के
थ्रू। जिससे आपको यह पता चलेगा कि बेसिकली
कोई थ्रेट एग्जैक्टली
है क्या वहां पे? इज़ देयर एनी थ्रेट इज़
देयर एनी काइंड ऑफ़ थ्रेट दैट इज़ प्रेजेंट
देयर? हेल्थ मॉनिटरिंग चेकिंग इफ ऑल योर
सर्वर्स आर सक्सेसफुली सेंडिंग लॉक्स टू
योर एसआईएम वर्कबुक से आप यह भी देखते हो
कि एग्जैक्टली सारे जो आपके सर्वर्स हैं
वो एसआईएम जो प्लेटफार्म है एसआईएम जो भी
आप टूल यूज़ कर रहे हैं एसआईएम प्लेटफार्म
के प्लेटफार्म तो क्या उसको सारे लॉग्स
सक्सेसफुली जा रहे हैं क्योंकि लॉग्स ही
अगर सही से नहीं जाएंगे लॉग्स ही नहीं मिल
पाएंगे तो फिर वहां पे क्या फायदा है आपका
एल वन का या एसआईएम जो प्लेटफार्म यूज़ हो
रहा है उसका कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है। सो,
उसको भी आप वर्कब के थ्रू मॉनिटर कर सकते
हैं। यह तो मैंने आपको अपना एक व्यू बताया
यहां पे। अब मैं इसी चीज को यहां पे
ट्राईकमी के एक वॉक थ्रू पे चलता हूं। एंड
यहां पे मैं आपको इसका इंट्रोडक्शन ओपन
करता हूं। ठीक है? यहां इंट्रोडक्शन भी
यहां पे आप देखेंगे। तो इंट्रोडक्शन में
यहां पे वक वर्क बुक्स का यहां पे थ्योरी
है। इसको मैं एक्सपेंड करता हूं। ठीक है?
अब चलिए इसको हम पढ़ेंगे। अह इसको हम
समझेंगे। इसको भी हम जानेंगे। बट उसके
पहले जो इंपॉर्टेंट चीज़ है पहले एक और मैं
वह भी आपको पहले समझा दूं। अभी हमने देखा
वर्क एग्ज़ैक्टली क्या होता है। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे हम थोड़ा सा समझते हैं LOKUps के
बारे में। वर्कब तो आपने देख लिया। अभी हम
यहां पे LOKUps के बारे में समझते हैं।
देन हम आगे की तरफ वर्कब का भी कुछ और
कांसेप्ट हम इसको समझेंगे। देखो एक तो
वर्कब होती है और एक होता है lookup।
वर्कबुक जो है उसको हम विजुअलाइज़ेशन इंजन
बोलते हैं। जो आपको विजुअलाइज़ करके चीजें
बताता है। ठीक है? एक विजुअलाइज़ेशन के
थ्रू सारी चीजें एक्सप्लेन करता है। और
लुकअप्स जो होते हैं ये इसको हम इनरचमेंट
टूल बोलते हैं। वी से देम इन इनरचमेंट
टूल। ठीक है? अ लुकअप ऑफेन कॉल्ड अ वॉच
लिस्ट इन सेंटिनेल। अ लुकअप ऑफेन कॉल्ड अ
वॉच लिस्ट। इन सेंटिनल। अब यहां पर वॉच
लिस्ट इनल का मतलब क्या है? यह यहां पर
बात Windows सेंटिनल की हो रही है।
बेसिकली जो कि एक एसआईएम प्लेटफार्म है।
ठीक है? इज़ एसेंशियली अ कस्टम टेबल ऑफ़
डेटा दैट यू अपलोड टू योर सिक्योरिटी
प्लेटफार्म टू प्रोवाइड कॉन्टेक्स्ट दैट
इज़ नॉट फाउंड इन स्टैंडर्ड लॉक्स। LOKUP
का मतलब यहां पे सिंपल है कि यह एक कस्टम
टेबल होता है डेटा का जिसे कि आप अपलोड
करते हैं अपने सिक्योरिटी प्लेटफार्म पे।
ठीक है? जैसे मान लो कोई भी आप एसआईएम
प्लेटफार्म यूज़ कर रहे हैं, कोई भी टूल
यूज़ कर रहे हैं उस पे आप अपलोड करते टू
प्रोवाइड कॉन्टेक्स्ट दैट इज़ नॉट फाउंड इन
स्टैंडर्ड लॉग्स। उस कॉन्टेक्स्ट को पता
लगाने के लिए जो स्टैंडर्ड लॉग्स में आपको
नहीं मिल रहा है। मतलब क्या हुआ? अब मैं
आपको बताता हूं इसका। व्हाई डू वी नीड
देम? देखो रॉ लॉग्स आर ऑफेन थिन। जो रॉ
लॉग्स होते हैं, वह बहुत नॉर्मल से होते
हैं। अ लॉग माइट टेल यू दैट आईपी दिस
एक्सेस अ फाइल बट इट वोंट टेल यू दैट दिस
आईपी बिलोंग्स टू द सीईओस लैपटॉप और अ हाई
वैल्यू सर्वर अ लुकअप ब्रिज दैट गैप। अब
यहां पर इसका मतलब है कि जो लुकअप होता है
उसी गैप को ब्रीज करने के लिए यूज़ में आता
है। यहां मतलब है कि एक लॉग एक नॉर्मल लॉग
जो होता है ना एक बीइंग एन एसोसिएल वन एक
नॉर्मल लॉग को जब आप एनालाइज़ करते हैं तो
आपको यह लॉग ये जरूर बता सकता है कि ये जो
आईपी है इसने एक फाइल को एक्सेस किया है।
पर्टिकुलर आईपी से एक फाइल एक्सेस हुई है।
बट आपको यह लॉग यह नहीं बताएगा कि यह जो
आईपी है यह सीईओ के लैपटॉप की आईपी है या
कोई हाई सीवियरिटी या कोई हाई वैल्यू
पर्सन की यह लैपटॉप से आ रही है या किसी
अच्छी हाई पोस्ट पर्सन के लैपटॉप से यह जो
है आ रही है या उसकी आईपी है यह नहीं पता
चलेगा तो यह हमें lookup से पता चल जाता
है। अब lookup से यह कैसे पता चलता है?
LOKUP में कुछ चीजें होती हैं जिनको हम
बोलते हैं इन्वेंटरी। LOKUP में एक चीज
होती है इन्वेंटरी। इन्वेंटरी के बारे में
अब हमें थोड़ा समझना है। सो वी आर गोइंग
फॉर द इन्वेंटरी थिंग। यहां पे मैं यहां
पे इन्वेंटरी पे आता हूं। इन्वेंटरी में
दो तरह के इन्वेंटरीज होते हैं। एक आपका
एसेट इन्वेंटरी होता है और एक आपकी
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी होती है। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे जो ट्राईहैकमी में आपको चीजें दी
गई हैं, ये तो आप खुद भी पढ़ के समझ सकते
हैं। राइट? ये आप पढ़ लेंगे। इसमें भी
दिया हुआ है। ठीक है? ईजी है। बट बहुत
डिटेल्ड आपको यहां नहीं मिलेगा कुछ भी। तो
एक एसेट आइडेंट इन्वेंटरी हो गई और एक
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी हो गई। अब ये दोनों
एग्जैक्टली क्या है? इसको हम समझते हैं।
पहले ट्राई आगमी के थ्रू मैं नहीं
समझाऊंगा आपको। यहां तो हम प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे। बट आपको पहले समझना है इन दोनों
के बीच में। एग्जैक्टली होता क्या है ये
दोनों। चलिए तो हम आते हैं वापस से स्लाइड
पे।
ओके?
अब चलते हैं आगे की तरफ। यहां अभी मैं
इसको आगे करता हूं यहां पे। अब आते हैं
एसेट्स की तरफ। ठीक है? दिस इज द एसेट्स
इन्वेंटरी।
ठीक है?
अब एसेट्स इन्वेंटरी में आते हैं। पहले
समझते हैं एन एसेट क्या होता है? एन एसेट
इज एनी फिजिकल और वर्चुअल रिसोर्स दैट
स्टोर्स प्रोसेस और ट्रांसमिट डेटा। एसेट
कुछ भी ऐसा होता है। कोई भी ऐसा फिजिकल हो
गया या वर्चुअल रिसोर्स होता है। मतलब वह
फिजिकल रिसोर्स भी हो सकता है, वर्चुअल
रिसोर्स भी हो सकता है। जो कि डेटा को
स्टोर करता है, प्रोसेस करता है,
ट्रांसमिट करता है। वो सब एसेट होते हैं।
इन अ एसओसी वी ट्रैक एसेट्स टू अंडरस्टैंड
द ब्लास्ट रेडियस ऑफ एन अटैक। हम एसओसी
में एसेट्स को ट्रैक करते हैं। बस इसलिए
ताकि हम यह समझ सके कि अटैक जो है वो
कितना वॉइड था। कितने वॉइड लेवल पे अटैक
हुआ है। कितने बड़े लेवल पे अटैक हुआ है।
इसलिए हम एसेट्स को ट्रैक करते हैं। अब
आपको एसेट्स का मतलब भी समझ में आ जाएगा।
कैटेगरीज़ ऑफ़ एसेट्स। देखो एसेट्स में
क्या-क्या होते हैं? ये सारे आपके एसेट्स
हैं। क्या? एंड पॉइंट्स एसेट्स,
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एसेट्स, नेटवर्क
डिवाइसेस, एसेट्स, आई ओटी, ओटी एसेट्स ये
सब एसेट्स हैं। अब इन एंड पॉइंट्स में
जैसे एग्जांपल में लैपटॉप, वर्क स्टेशन,
मोबाइल डिवाइसेस यूज्ड बाय एंप्लाइजज़ ये
सारे एसेट्स हैं। इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर की बात
करें तो सर्वर्स हो गया। जैसे ऑन प्रीमाइस
और क्लाउड सर्वर्स हो गए। और यह ऑन प्रेम
मतलब ऑन प्रीमाइस सर्वर्स होते हैं जो कि
आपके खुद के प्रीमाइस में रखे हुए सर्वर
मतलब एक किसी एक किसी लोकेशन पे रखे हुए
अह खुद के छोड़ो एक किसी लोकेशन पे रखे
हुए सर्वर हैं फिजिकली वो हो गए एक
क्लाउड्स जो सर्वर्स हो गए वो हो गए
वर्चुअल मशीनंस कंटेनर्स ये सारे आपके
एसेट्स ही कहलाते हैं।
प्रैक्टिकल सार्थक खन्नाल प्रैक्टिकल नहीं
है सार्थक आप लीव कर दीजिए प्लीज क्लासेस
को जिनको भी प्रैक्टिकल सिर्फ चाहिए था कि
सिर्फ प्रैक्टिकल करना है वो प्लीज क्लास
लीव कर दीजिए मैं तो यही बोलूंगा क्योंकि
मुझे नहीं लगता कि यू विल बी डूइंग गुड इन
एसओसी मुझे नहीं लगता कि आप एसओसी में
अच्छा करियर भी बना सकते हैं। एंड मुझे
नहीं लगता कि ये ट्रेनिंग आपके लिए भी है।
क्योंकि इसका रीज़न यह है कि आप में से कुछ
लोग सिर्फ प्रैक्टिकल की बातें करते हैं।
एंड सिर्फ प्रैक्टिकल की बातें जो लोग भी
करते हैं वह लोग मुझे पर्सनली पता नहीं
अच्छे नहीं लगते हैं। आई डोंट लाइक देम।
मुझे लगता है कि मैं टाइम वेस्ट कर रहा
हूं ऐसे लोगों को सिखा के पढ़ा के। तो आई
रिक्वेस्ट टू दोज़ पीपल एक पोलाइट
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा हूं आपसे कि प्लीज आप
लीव कर दीजिए क्लास को। कोई प्रैक्टिकल
नहीं होने वाला है। अगर आपको जैसा मैं
पढ़ा रहा हूं वैसा ही पढ़ना है तो आप
कंटिन्यू कर सकते हैं। मतलब यू कैन बी
स्टे यू कैन स्टे इन दिस क्लास। अदरवाइज
यू कैन लीव द क्लास। मुझे कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है। मेरे पास अगर 10 बच्चे भी होंगे और
मुझे अगर पढ़ाना है, सिखाना है तो मैं उन
10 को ही सिखाऊंगा जो एक्चुअली मेरे तरीके
से सीखना चाहते हैं और वो सीख के फिर आगे
कुछ करेंगे लाइफ में। बट बाकी अगर नहीं है
तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। कोई टेंशन इतना
इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना है। ठीक है? हां। बस
तो आप कर सकते हो। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
ठीक है?
ओके। हां। ब्लास्ट रेडियस का मतलब होता है
कि एक अटैक का कितने बड़े लेवल पर इंपैक्ट
हो रहा है। कितनी बड़ी लेवल पर एक अटैक हुई
है वो ब्लास्ट रेडियस होता है। सिंपल सा
फंडा है। ठीक है?
अब यहां पे मतलब एसेट कोई भी फिजिकल या
वर्चुअल रिसोर्स है जो कि डेटा को स्टोर
करेगा, ट्रांसमिट करेगा, प्रोसेस करेगा
सब। वह फिजिकल भी हो सकता है। जैसे कोई
फिजिकल लैपटॉप हो गया आपका, कंप्यूटर हो
गया, सर्वर हो गया या वर्चुअल क्लाउड
सर्वर्स हो गए। ठीक है? या वर्चुअल मशीनंस
हो गए हैं। ये भी आपके कंटेनर्स हो गए। ये
भी आपके हो सकते हैं। इसको हम इसलिए ट्रैक
करते हैं ताकि हम पता लगा पाए कि भाई जो
अटैक हो रहा है उसका एरिया कितना बड़ा है।
कितने बड़े लेवल पर अटैक हो रहा है उसके
लिए। तो कैटेगरीज़ में आप देख सकते हैं एंड
पॉइंट्स के बारे में बता दिया।
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर बता दिया। अब नेटवर्क
डिवाइसेस में जैसे राउटर हो गए, स्विचेस
हो गए, फायर वॉल्स हो गए, लोड बैलेंस हो
गई। ये सब एसेट्स हैं। आई ओटी या ओटी की
बात करें तो स्मार्ट कैमरास हो गए,
प्रिंटर्स हो गए, इंडस्ट्रियल कंट्रोल
सिस्टम्स हो गए। ये सब आपके एसेट्स ही आते
हैं। मतलब एक
एक कंपनी में एक नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
में जो भी चीजें हैं, डिवाइसेस वगैरह हैं,
वो सब एक तरह से एसेट्स ही कहलाते हैं।
ठीक है? अब एसेट का्टेक्स्ट मेटा डेटा के
अगर बात करें, मेटा डेटा के कॉन्टेक्स्ट
में बात करें तो नोइंग अ डिवाइस एकिस्ट इज
नॉट इनफ। एक डिवाइस एक्सिस्ट करती है। यह
जानना ही सिर्फ इनफ नहीं होता है। एसओसी
एनालिस्ट्स नीड टू नो क्या-क्या चीजें
उसको जाननी चाहिए? क्रिटिकिटी, ओनरशिप एंड
पैच स्टेटस। क्रिटिकिटी इज दिस अ टेस्ट
मशीन और द प्रोडक्शन डेटाबेस? क्या यह जो
मशीन थी जिस पे अटैक हुआ है यह टेस्ट मशीन
थी या एक्चुअली प्रोडक्शन डेटाबेस था
एक्चुअल जो प्रोडक्शन में है जो एक्चुअल
जो यूज़ हो रही है वो था ओनरशिप हु इज द
प्राइमरी यूजर और द सिस्टम एडमिन हु इज द
प्राइमरी यूजर और द सिस्टम एडमिन कौन है
इसका प्राइमरी यूजर कौन है या सिस्टम
एडमिन कौन है यह पता लगाना पैच स्टेटस इज़
इट रनिंग एन आउटडेटेड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम विथ
नॉन वलेबिलिटी क्या यह मशीन क्या यह एसेट
एक आउटडेटेड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को यूज़ कर
रहा है जो कि ऑलरेडी वलेबिलिटीज़ के साथ
नोन वलेबिलिटीज़ से इंपैक्टेड है या ऑलरेडी
जिसमें वलेबिलिटीज़ हैं ये सारी चीजें आपको
पता करना होता है बीइंग एन एसोसिएल वन ये
आपको जो भी मशीनंस या एसेट्स हैं उनके
बारे में आपको क्लेरिटी होना चाहिए ये सब
चीजों के बारे में तो सिर्फ कि कौन सा
डिवाइस एक्चुअली वहां पे एक्सिस्ट कर रहा
है जो अटैक में इनवॉल्वड है या जिसके थ्रू
अटैक हुआ है जिस पे अटैक हुआ है सिर्फ
इतना इनफ नहीं है बल्कि उसके यह चीजें भी
जाननी जरूरी है। क्रिटिकैलिटी ओनरशिप एंड
पैच स्टेटस। ठीक है? दैट्स इट।
ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
ओके? गॉट इट।
हमको एसओसी एनालिस्ट में अपना करियर बनाना
है तो क्या हमको सीएस? ना यार कोई जरूरत
नहीं है। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। ऐसी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। डोंट वरी। ऐसी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। ऐसी कंपनीज़ के तो
सर्टिफिकेशंस मत ही करो। ज्यादा अच्छा है।
अब यहां पे यह तो एसेट आइडेंट एसेट
इन्वेंटरी की बात हो गई। अब हम आते हैं
आइडेंटिटीज इन्वेंटरी। एसेट इन्वेंटरी हो
गई। अब हम आइडेंटिटीज़ इन्वेंटरी पे आते
हैं। तो एसेट्स कहता है व्हाट? मतलब क्या?
कौन सी मशीन? कौन सा प्रिंटर, कौन सा एंड
पॉइंट, कौन सा इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर का मशीन?
और आइडेंटिटी कहता है हु कौन? एग्जैक्टली
कौन? तो एन आइडेंटिटी इज अ डिजिटल
रिप्रेजेंटेशन ऑफ एन एंटिटी दैट कैन
परफॉर्म एकशंस। मतलब कि जो एक्शन परफॉर्म
कर रहा है वही आइडेंटिटी है। इट इज़ नो लगर
जस्ट अ पर्सन। इट इज़ एनीथिंग दैट हैज़ अ
सेट ऑफ़ परमिशंस। ये सिर्फ पर्सन की बात
नहीं हो रही है। ये कोई भी ऐसी चीज जिसके
पास एक सेट ऑफ़ परमिशन है जिसके पास कुछ
परमिशन है टू एग्जीक्यूट समथिंग टू डू
समथिंग। वह आइडेंटिटीज इन्वेंटरी के अंदर
आता है। अब इसमें टाइप्स ऑफ आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी में क्या-क्या आएंगे? तो यूजर
आइडेंटिटीज आता है, प्रिविलेज्ड
आइडेंटिटीज आते हैं, सर्विस प्रिंसिपल्स
या नॉन ह्यूमन आइडेंटिटीज आते हैं और
मैनेज्ड आइडेंटिटीज आते हैं। मतलब क्या
हुआ? यूजर आइडेंटिटी में ह्यूमन एंप्लाइजज़
हो गए हैं, कॉन्ट्रैक्टर्स हो गया,
गेस्ट्स हो गए। ये सारे ह्यूमन आइडेंटिटीज़
हो गए। ठीक है?
प्रिविलेज्ड आइडेंटिटीज में एडमिन
अकाउंट्स जो प्रिविलेज्ड अकाउंट्स जैसे
डोमेन एडमिनस हो गए, ग्लोबल एडमिंस हो
गया, दैट हैव द की टू द किंगडम। मतलब जो
प्रिविलेज्ड लोग हैं जो टॉप क्लास के लोग
हैं जिनके पास सबसे ज्यादा पावर है वो
पावर किसके पास है भाई? सबसे ज्यादा पावर
किसके पास है? एडमिंस के पास है। तो वो
प्रिविलेज आइडेंटिटीज में सर्विस
प्रिंसिपल्स या नॉन ह्यूमन आइडेंटिटीज।
अब यहां पे क्या है? अकाउंट्स यूज्ड बाय
एप्लीकेशनेशंस और स्क्रिप्ट्स टू टॉक टू
ईच अदर। एग्जांपल में अ बैकअप स्क्रिप्ट
दैट नीड्स एक्सेस टू अ डेटाबेस। अब ऐसे भी
आइडेंटिटीज होते हैं, है ना? जो कि
एप्लीकेशन के द्वारा यूज़ में लिए जाते
हैं। अब जैसे कोई एक बैकअप एप्लीकेशन है।
तो भैया बैकअप एप्लीकेशन आप यूज़ कर रहे हो
नेटवर्क में और वो बैकअप ले रहा है किसी
डेटा का, किसी मशीन के डेटा का तो उसको उस
डेटा का एक्सेस तो होना चाहिए। उस डेटा को
एक्सेस करने की परमिशन तो होनी चाहिए ना
नेटवर्क के अंदर में। तो अगर उसके पास वो
परमिशन है ठीक है? या उसके पास वह
ऑथराइजेशन है कि हां उस डाटा बेस को
एक्सेस कर सकता है। क्यों एक्सेस करेगा?
बैकअप लेने के लिए। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। तो
फिर वो एक सर्विस प्रिंसिपल या नॉन ह्यूमन
आइडेंटिटीज का एग्जांपल है। मैनेज्ड
आइडेंटिटीज़। आइडेंटिटीज़ ऑटोमेटिकली
मैनेज्ड बाय क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर्स। मतलब यह
मैनेज्ड होते हैं। जैसे आपने कहीं से
सर्विस ली है। आप कोई सर्विस ले रहे हैं
तो वह किसी और थर्ड पार्टी से ले रहे हैं
तो सारी चीजें उनके द्वारा मैनेज की जाती
है। तो यहां पे जो आइडेंटिटीज़ मैनेज्ड हैं
इसका मतलब है ऐसी आइडेंटिटी जो क्लाउड
प्रोवाइडर्स के द्वारा मैनेज किया जाता
है। जैसे Azure Microsoft Azure हो गया,
AWS हो गई फॉर रिसोर्स टू रिसोर्स
कम्युनिकेशन। मतलब रिसोर्स टू रिसोर्स
कम्युनिकेशन यानी कि उनके द्वारा सब कुछ
मैनेज हो रहा है जो आपको सर्विसेस
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है। यह मैनेज आइडेंटिटीज़
हो गई। अब आइडेंटिटी पैरामीटर की हम बात
करें तो यहां पे एक मॉडर्न इन मॉडर्न
सिक्योरिटी वी से आइडेंटिटी इज द न्यू
पैरामीटर।
ठीक है? मॉडर्न सिक्योरिटी में हम बोलते
हैं कि आइडेंटिटी ही नया पेरीमीटर है।
आपकी आइडेंटिटी ही पैरामीटर है। फेंस है
और वो घेराबंदी है। एग्जैक्टली। सिंस पीपल
वर्क फ्रॉम होम एंड यूज़ क्लाउड एप्स द
फिजिकल ऑफिस वॉल डज़ नॉट मैटर एनीमोर। सही
बात है। आज के टाइम में आप घर से काम कर
रहे हैं। आप घर से सारा चीज कर रहे हैं।
तो अब वह कंपनी के जो दीवाल, कंपनी के जो
चीजें हैं, फायर वाल्स और वो चीजें हैं जो
वो अभी मैटर उतना नहीं कर रही हैं। लेकिन
सिक्योरिटी नाउ डिपेंड्स ऑन वेरीाइंग द
आइडेंटिटी वाया मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड कंडीशनल एक्सेस। तो अब जो यह
सिक्योरिटी है, ठीक है? यह किस पे डिपेंड
करती है? आइडेंटिटीज को वेरीफाई करने के
ऊपर। और कैसे वह वेरीफाई होते हैं? तो
मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशंस के थ्रू होते
हैं। मल्टी आजकल मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
या कंडीशनल एक्सेस कि ये कंडीशन पे ये चीज
आप एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। कंडीशन ये है कि
इसको एक्सेस करने के लिए ये परमिशन या ये
ऑथोराइजेशन होना चाहिए। तो ये कंडीशनल
एक्सेस हो गया। एक पर्टिकुलर कंडीशन में
कोई चीज आप एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। या तो
मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन यानी एक से ज्यादा
ऑथेंटिकेशन सिस्टम आपको यूज़ करना पड़ रहा
है। जैसे कि मान लो कि आप कहीं पे जा रहे
हो कहीं पे लॉगिन आपको करना है तो आपने
लॉगिन किया। उसके बाद आपके पास एक ओटीपी
रिसीव होती है। अब मान लो ओटीपी रिसीव
होने के बाद भी आपने क्या किया? आप ओटीपी
रिसीव करने के बाद भी आपको वहां पे
पासवर्ड मान लो लेट्स सपोज डालना पड़ रहा
है। या तो आपको किसी नोन डिवाइस से अलऊ
करना पड़ रहा है उस लॉग इन को ऑथोराइज
करना पड़ रहा है उस लॉग इन को या तो आपने
उस लॉगिन को एक प्राइवेट की के थ्रू आपने
क्या हुआ एक अपना की चेन बना के रखा है
क्लाउड में उसमें सेव करके रखा हुआ है।
वहां से आपको अलऊ करना पड़ रहा है या फेस
रिकॉग्नाइजेशन के थ्रू करना पड़ रहा है।
तो देयर आर मल्टीपल ऑथराइजेशन ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड मल्टीपल ऑथेंटिकेशन को आप यूज़ कर रहे
हैं। एंड उसी को हम एमएफए बोलते हैं
मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड देन जाके आपको
कोई चीज़ का एक्सेस मिल रहा है। तो यह
आइडेंटिटी एज अ पेरामीटर आप बोल सकते हैं
कि आजकल आइडेंटिटी ही जो है वो पेरीमीटर
है। आइडेंटिटी से ही सब कुछ सिक्योर
सिक्योरिटी हो आप को मैनेज किया जा रहा
है। सिक्योरिटी को मेजर किया जा रहा है।
एवरीथिंग इज़ आइडेंटिटी। तो यही थी हमारी
एसेट्स एंड आइडेंटिटीज़। अब यहां पे आते
हैं कंपैरिजन में। दोनों के कंपैरिजन टेबल
पे आते हैं कि भैया एग्जैक्टली आइडेंटिटी
में एसेट्स और आइडेंटिटी जो हैं दोनों ये
दोनों एग्जैक्टली कैसे कंपेयर किए जा सकते
हैं? तो अगर मैं फीचर्स की बात करूं तो
यहां पे मैंने कुछ फीचर्स यहां पे लिस्ट
करे हैं जिसमें एसेट्स के और आइडेंटिटीज
के अलग-अलग हैं। जो आपको एग्जैक्ट
कंपैरिजन बताएंगे आपको समझ में आएगा। ठीक
है? ओके? सो
सुज अगर रिक्वायरमेंट होगी तो करेंगे नहीं
तो कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं होगी तो कोई नीड
नहीं है। थैंक यू सर हम आपके चैनल में वन
मंथ पहले जॉइ किए और अभी हम बग बंटी का
कोर्स कर रहे हैं आपके चैनल से तो अच्छे
से कंप्लीट करने के बाद एसओसी स्टार्ट
करूं। हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल गौरव
यू कैन डेफिनेटली स्टार्ट।
फोकस के फीचर हम फोकस की बात करें तो
हार्डवेयर सॉफ्टवेयर एंड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
फोकस्ड एरिया एसेट्स फोकस्ड एसेट्स जो हैं
यही है आपके हार्डवेयर सॉफ्टवेयर एंड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर आइडेंटिटीज में यूजर
ग्रुप्स एंड सर्विस अकाउंट्स होते हैं।
गोल की अगर बात करें तो वनेबिलिटी
मैनेजमेंट एंड पैचिंग एसेट्स में वबिलिटी
मैनेजमेंट एंड पैचिंग की बात आती है।
आइडेंटिटीज़ में एक्सेस कंट्रोल एंड
बिहेवियर मॉनिटरिंग। क्योंकि यहां पर हम
एक सिस्टम की हार्डवेयर की बात करें या
वर्चुअल सिस्टम्स की बात करें तो उसमें
वनेबिलिटी मैनेजमेंट होना चाहिए। पैचिंग
होनी चाहिए कि कोई और आउटडेटेड ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम ना यूज़ हो रहा हो या आउटडेटेड कोई
सॉफ्टवेयर ना यूज़ हो रहा हो। ये सब चीज़ और
आइडेंटिटीज़ में भाई एक्सेस कंट्रोल कि
भैया कोई कहीं कुछ एक्सेस ना कर ले।
बिहेवियर कंट्रोल कि कहीं कुछ भी कोई
सामने वाला कोई एंप्लई है वो कुछ और
बिहेवियर कर रहा है। कुछ अलग तरीके से
बिहेव कर रहा है या कुछ डिफरेंट मलशियस
बिहेवियर दिखा रहा है तो उसको मॉनिटर
करना। रिस्क की बात करें। इज द डिवाइस
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड और अनपैच्ड? क्या यह
डिवाइस कंप्रोमाइज्ड है या अनपैच्ड है? वह
देखना है। इज द अकाउंट स्टोलन और मिसयूज
आइडेंटिटीज की बात करें तो भैया क्या यह
अकाउंट
स्टोल चुरा लिया गया है या मिसयूज किया जा
रहा है। सिक्योरिटी टूल्स में ईडीआर जैसे
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स जो होते हैं वो एसेट्स
को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए होते हैं। एंड
पॉइंट डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस टूल्स। एंड
यहां पर आइडेंटिटीज में आईएएम होती है।
आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट। यह जो
टूल्स है इसको यूज किया जाता है आइडेंटिटी
के सिक्योरिटी के लिए। अब एक बात आपको मैं
बता देता हूं कि एंटरप्राइज लेवल पे
कंपनीज़ लेवल पे ईडीआर और आईएएम जो है यह
बहुत ईडीआर एक्सडीआर हो गए या आईएम जो हो
गए। यह अपने आप में एक पूरी की पूरी सीरीज
हो सकती है। आईएम के ऊपर तो हायरिंग्स
होती हैं। अगर आपका आईएम आइडेंटिटी एक्सेस
मैनेजमेंट काफी अच्छा आपने कर रखा है, सीख
रखा है तो यू कुड बी हायर्ड बाय
एंटरप्राइज मतलब कंपनीज़ एंड यू कैन गिवन द
रोल यू कैन बी गिवेन द रोल ऑफ दीज़ बेस्ड
ऑन दीज़ टॉपिक्स बेस्ड ऑन दीज़ लाइक नॉलेज
एंड तो ये चीजें जो है आपको अभी जाननी
चाहिए कि एसेट्स की सुरक्षा इडीआर करते
हैं। आइडेंटिटीज़ की सुरक्षा आईएएम्स जो
हैं वह करते हैं। आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस
मैनेजमेंट जो टूल्स जो होते हैं वो करते
हैं। ठीक है? तो इन दोनों के बीच की
कंपैरिजन भी हो चुकी है। तो आपने यहां पे
अभी आइडेंटिटीज एसेट्स के बारे में जाना।
आपने यहां पे एसोसिएट lookups के बारे में
हम यहां पे पढ़ रहे थे। अब हम lookअप्स पे
वापस से आएंगे। ठीक है? अभी तक हमारा
lookup कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ था क्योंकि
आइडेंटिटी एक्सेस इन्वेंटरी जो है जो ये
जो एसेट्स एसेट्स को कवर करना बहुत जरूरी
था। एसेट्स जो होते हैं और आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी दोनों को कवर करना बहुत जरूरी
था क्योंकि यही दोनों यहां पे अगर आप
ट्राई हैक पे भी जाएंगे तो एसेट्स एंड
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी जो है आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिल जाएगा जिसके बारे में बताया
गया है। बट अभी मैं ट्राईकमी पे बिल्कुल
नहीं जा रहा। अभी मैं अपने तरीके से आपको
थोड़ा समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं। देन हम
उस पे भी जाएंगे तो प्रैक्टिस थोड़ा
हैंड्स ऑन करेंगे। ठीक है?
अब एसोस लुकअप्स की बात हम करते हैं फिर
से।
जैसा मैंने बताया कि इसको वॉच लिस्ट कहा
जाता है। ठीक है? एंड नीड क्यों चाहिए?
क्योंकि आईपी
यह आईपी ने एक फाइल एक्सेस की थी। यह तो
आपको लॉग बताएगा। बट लॉग आपको यह नहीं
बताएगा कि यह सीईओ के लैपटॉप से आया था या
किसी एक हाई पोस्ट एंप्लई या हाई पोस्ट
मैनेजमेंट के लैपटॉप से ये लॉग जनरेट हुई
थी। ये नहीं बताएगा। ठीक है? तो अब कॉमन
टाइप्स ऑफ लुकअप्स की बात करें तो यहां पे
एसेट इन्वेंटरी होता है। आपकी आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी भी आप बोल सकते हैं। थ्रेट
Intel वीआईपी लिस्ट टर्मिनेटेड यूजर्स। अब
इसकी बात समझते हैं। एसेट इन्वेंटरी मैप्स
आईपीस टू स्पेसिफिक हार्डवेयर और ओनर्स।
ठीक है? इसका मतलब एसेट इन्वेंटरी आप समझ
चुके हैं। जितने भी एसेट्स जो भी आपके
डेटा को स्टोर प्रोसेस और वो करता है।
हार्डवेयर ये सारी चीजें जो वर्चुअल
डिवाइसेस होती है वो सब एसेट इन्वेंटरी।
तो इसका बेसिकली काम क्या है? मैप्स आईपीस
टू स्पेसिफिक हार्डवेयर और ओनर्स। ठीक है
भैया? हां। स्पेसिफिक हार्डवेयर या ओनर से
जो है वो क्या करता है? मैप कर देता है उस
मतलब आईपीस को ताकि पता चले कि भैया ये
आईपी किससे बिलोंग करती है। राइट? या किस
पर्टिकुलर बंदे के लैपटॉप से आई है। अब
किसी लैपटॉप को मैप करता है एक आईपी से।
तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है कि भैया यह आईपी इस
पर्टिकुलर लैपटॉप की है और यह लैपटॉप इस
ओनर का है। यह ओनर है। इसका ओनर सीईओ है,
सीटीओ है, सीएफओ है, सीएमओ है। कंपनी का
जो भी पोस्ट होता है वो अपना हाई
मैनेजमेंट पोस्ट की बात कर ले या टेक्निकल
पोस्ट की बात कर। एग्जांपल के तौर पे
देखें कि 10 ये आईपी है 10.0.5
= एचआर डेटाबेस सर्वर। अब ये कहां पॉइंट
कर रहा है? एचआर का डेटाबेस सर्वर है।
एचआर डेटाबेस सर्वर है जो कि इस आईपी से
मैप्ड है। उसी तरीके से थ्रेट Intel के
लिए lookअप्स का यूज़ होता है। कैसे? अ
लिस्ट ऑफ़ नोन मलिशियस आईपीस और फाइल
हैशेस। मसियस आईपीस की लिस्ट और फाइल
हैशेस। मलशियस फाइल्स की हैशेस की लिस्ट।
इसका मतलब जैसे एक IP है 8.8.8.8
नोन मैलवेयर सोर्स। अब यह तो वैसे एक्चुअल
में ऐसा नहीं है A.8.8
दिस इज़ नॉट मैलवेयर सोर्स काइंड ऑफ थिंग
बट या यहां पे एक एग्जांपल के लिए नॉन
मैलवेयर सोर्स कि मान लो ये आईपी जो है
नॉन मैलवेयर सोर्स की लिस्टिंग में
लिस्टेड है कि भैया ये एक नॉन मैलवेयर
सोर्स है तो इसको आपको मतलब ये इसमें
हेल्प करता है आपके lookups वीआईपी लिस्ट
lookup इसमें भी हेल्प करता है। ट्रैक्स
हाई प्रोफाइल यूज़र्स जैसे कोई
एग्जीक्यूटिव यूज़र्स हैं, एडमिन यूज़र्स
हैं या कोई हाई मैनेजमेंट हायर मैनेजमेंट
का कोई यूजर है। ठीक है? सीटीओ है, सीएफओ
है या आपका सीईओ है ऐसे यूज़र्स हैं तो
उनकी जो मतलब यूजर उनकी जो ट्रैकिंग करती
है उसमें भी आपकी हेल्प होती है। जैसे कि
Zee डोए या ZOAए जो भी है यहां पे नाम कुछ
भी लिख दो या डेfronic@ compनी.com या
यहां पे कुछ भी डाल दो इक्वल टू सीएफओ कि
मतलब यह जो यह जो पर्टिकुलर ईमेल है यह जो
पर्टिकुलर यूजर है जो भी है वो एक सीएफओ
है। चीफ फाइनेंसियल ऑफिसर है कंपनी का। एक
एग्जीक्यूटिव यूजर है। एक हाई एंड हाई
वैल्यू अह या फिर एक बोल सकते हैं कि एक
हायर मैनेजमेंट का यूजर है। तो, यह मैपिंग
करता है। और टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स अ लिस्ट ऑफ़
एंप्लाइजज़ हु रिसेंटली लेफ्ट जो अभी
रिसेंटली गायब हुए हैं कंपनी से। हेल्प
स्पॉट घोस्ट अकाउंट लॉगिन। घोस्ट अकाउंट
लॉग इन का मतलब है कोई यूजर है वह उस
कंपनी से लीव कर चुका। अभी रिसेंटली गायब
हो चुका है। अब यहां पे उस उसका अकाउंट
यूज़ किया जा रहा है। कोई और उस अकाउंट को
यूज़ कर रहा है। कोई और उस अकाउंट को यूज़
करके लॉगिन कर रहा है। लिस्ट शुड आल्सो बी
मॉनिटर्ड। तो LOKUP से आप यह चीजें भी
LOKUP जो है आपको पता करके देती है कि
भैया अभी जो कोई ऐसा कोई तो अकाउंट नहीं
है जो अभी जिसका एंप्लई अभी तुरंत कुछ
टाइम पहले कंपनी छोड़ के निकला है और उसका
अकाउंट कोई और यूज़ कर रहा है फॉर मलिशियस
पर्पस। राइट? दैट्स दैट्स इट।
ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट? तो अब
मुझे बताइए अभी इसका एक और पार्ट है। इसको
भी समझते हैं। अब यहां पे आते हैं हाउ
lookup वर्क्स इन अ क्वरी। एक क्वरी के
अंदर lookup एक्चुअली कैसे काम करता है?
ये भी मैं आपको समझाता हूं। ठीक है? ये सब
आपको ट्राईक के अंदर में नहीं देखने को
मिलेगा। ठीक है? इसलिए मैंने ये चीज़ आपको
बताया। आपको इधर से अलग से समझाने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं मैं। व्हेन अ एसोसिए
एनालिस्ट राइट्स अ क्वरी। ठीक है? ठीक है?
राइट केl ये क्वरी लैंग्वेज है। क्वरी
जैसे लिखी जाती है। दे यूज़ द लुकअप टू
फ़्टर और जॉइन डेटा। जब एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट
जो है क्वरी को लिखते हैं तो lookअप्स का
यूज़ किया जाता है डेटा को फ़्टर करने के
लिए और डेटा को जॉइ करने के लिए। यस
बिल्कुल सही बात है। नथिंग इज़ हिडन बाय
LOOKUPS। हां LOKUP से कुछ भी हिडन नहीं
है। Lookups हर चीज को देखता है। हर चीज़
को समझता है। हर चीज़ को जानता है। तो
लॉजिक लॉजिक देखो लॉजिक क्या है? शो मी ऑल
लॉगिंस वेयर यूजरनेम इज़ फाउंड इन द
टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स lookup टेबल। शो मी ऑल
लॉगिन्स वेयर द यूजरनेम। वो सारे लॉगिन्स
मुझे दिखाओ। जहां यूजरनेम इज़ फाउंड इन द
टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स lookuअप टेबल। जहां पर
टर्मिनेटेड यूजर्स नाम का एक lookuअप टेबल
है। उसमें वह यूजरनेम जो है वो मिल रहा
है। शो मी ऑल लॉगिस वेयर द यूजर नेम इज़
फाउंड इन द टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स। तो मतलब कि
एक यूजरनेम होगा। जैसे मान लो एक यूजरनेम
है डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। तो अब यहां पे ये है शो
मी ऑल लॉगिस वेयर द डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। यानी कि
यूजरनेम ये हो गया डिफ्रॉनिक्स इज़ फाउंड
इन द टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स लुकअप टेबल। यानी
कि डिफ्रॉनिक्स टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स का
lookupअप टेबल है। डिफ्रॉनिक्स नाम से अगर
कोई यूजर है तो उसके सारे लॉगिन्स दिखाओ
भाई कि अगर वो डिफ्रॉनिक्स नाम का यूजरनेम
टर्मिनेटेड यूज़र्स की लिस्ट में है तो
इसका मतलब वो टर्मिनेटेड हो चुका है।
टर्मिनेटेड यूजर है। हट चुका है वो कंपनी
से। तो उसके सारे लॉगिन दिखाओ कि भैया
इसका अकाउंट यूज़ कहीं-कहीं हुआ है क्या?
कहां-कहां यूज़ हुआ है? कहां-कहां वो
अकाउंट्स यूज़ हो सकते हैं या हुए हैं
रिसेंटली। तो इससे पता चलेगा ना कि यूजर
तो टर्मिनेट हो चुका है। फिर भी उसका
अकाउंट कौन यूज़ कर रहा है? हु इज़ यूजिंग
दैट अकाउंट? दैट्स द थिंग। इस तरीके से यह
क्वेरीज काम करती हैं। लुकअप्स जो होती
हैं इस तरीके से काम करती है। अब
हां जी पूछिए क्वेश्चन पूछिए। अब यहां पे
बात यह है lookअप्स जो होती हैं वो बहुत
एक इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है। एज एन एसोसिएल वन
आपको इसकी कांसेप्ट्स को समझनी चाहिए। यह
आपके काम आने वाला है। हाउ दे वर्क
टुगेदर? कैसे यह काम करते हैं? देखो
इमेजिन यू आर इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग अ सस्िशियस
लॉगिन। मान लो एक आप सस्िशियस लॉग इन हुआ
है। आप एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल वन है। आप उसको
क्या कर रहे हैं? इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे
हैं। सबसे पहले दअप टेल्स द सिस्टम दैट द
यूजर इज़ अ वीआईपी। तो LOKUP आपको सिस्टम
को क्या बताएगा? जो
सिस्टम lookup जो है lookup जो है सिस्टम
को क्या बताएगा कि भैया यह जो यूजर है यह
एक वीआईपी यूजर है यानी मान लो सीएफओ है
या सीईओ है या सीटीओ है वीआईपी है
मैनेजमेंट से कनेक्टेड बंदा है थोड़ा हायर
पोस्ट का बंदा है द एसआईएम जो एसआईएम
प्लेटफार्म आप यूज़ कर रहे हो ट्रिगरर्स एन
अलर्ट
वो एक अलर्ट ट्रिगर करेगा बिकॉज़ द सीएफओ
इज़ लॉगिंग इन फ्रॉम एन अनयूजुअल कंट्री।
अब सीएफओ जनरली दिल्ली से ऑपरेट कर रहा
था। करता है हमेशा से हमेशा से दिल्ली से
ऑपरेट करता है। कभी-कभी वह पुणे से भी
ऑपरेट करता है। तो दिल्ली पुणे इज़ गुड
चलेगा। बट अब जो यह सीएफओ है यह लॉग इन कर
रहा है लंदन से।
लंदन डायरेक्ट दिल्ली और पुणे नहीं अब
डायरेक्ट लंदन से लॉग इन कर रहा है। तो
यहां पे एक अलर्ट ट्रिगर होगा एसआईएम
प्लेटफार्म की तरफ से कि एक अनयूजुअल
कंट्री से या अनयूजुअल सिटी से लॉगिन किया
जा रहा है। द वर्कब डिस्प्लेस दिस अलर्ट
ऑन अ ग्लोबल मैप। वर्कब क्या करेगा? उस
अलर्ट को एक ग्लोबल मैप पे डिस्प्ले
करेगा। ऐसे नहीं मूवीज़ में नहीं देखते हो।
टिंग डिटिंग टिंग अरे एक रेड कलर का एक
अलर्ट आएगा। मूवीज़ में देखतेगे रेड कलर का
लैट आएगा। यहां से कोई लॉगिन हो रहा है।
एक अनयुअल लोकेशन वहां लिखा अनयूज़ुअल
लोकेशन सीएफओ डिटेक्टेड अनयूज़ुअल लोकेशन
सीएफओ डिटेक्टेड कंट्री लंदन ऐसा मतलब
व्हाटएवर मतलब सिटी सिटी सिटी कोई सा भी
सिटी अगर मान लो मान लो लेट्स सपोज़ कि
उसने न्यूयॉर्क से लॉग इन किया है। लेट्स
सपोज लॉस एंजेलिस से लॉग इन किया है।
व्हाटएवर तो भाई ये सिटी दिस कंट्री दिस
ऐसे करके वहां पे आ जाएगा। राइट? तो अब
यहां पे हां अब समझ में आ रहा है ना?
बढ़िया। तो इस तरीके से ये पिन अप होगा।
हाईलाइटेड इन रेड अलाउंग द एसओसी मैनेजर
टू सी ज्योग्राफिकल एनोमली इंस्टेंटली। अब
एसओसी जो मैनेजर होगा वो उसको देखेगा
समझेगा। ओ हो कुछ तो गड़बड़ है भाई। कहां से
आ रहे हैं ये? टुक टुक टुक टुक वाले
अलर्ट। सीएफओ भाई साहब कहां? न्यूयॉर्क
चले गए। लॉस एंजेलिस चले गए या टैक्सेस
चले गए? कहां चले गए? सो
सबको समझ में आएगा कि भाई कुछ गड़बड़ है।
तो ये इस तरीके से काम करता है। ये जो
पूरा है सिस्टम है ऐसे ही जो आपका lookup
और वर्कब है एक साथ ऐसे ही आपके काम करते
हैं। तो वर्कब के बारे में मैंने आपको
यहां पे बताया था कि एक विजुअलाइज़ेशन
इंजन है। विजुअलाइज़ करके आपको दिखाने का
काम करता है। lookअप्स में आपको बता दिया
कि lookups कैसे हर एक चीज का बेवड़ा रखती
है कि भैया मुझे यह चीज़ दिखाओ, वह दिखाओ,
वह दिखाओ। यह सारी चीजें दोनों मिलके कुछ
इस तरीके से ही काम करते हैं। आई थिंक कि
अब आपको क्लियर हो गया होगा। वर्क बुक एंड
लुकअप्स का कांसेप्ट क्लियर हो गया होगा।
एसेट्स आइडेंटिटीज का कांसेप्ट आपका
क्लियर हो गया होगा। मुझे सभी लोग बता
दीजिए तब मैं आगे बढूंगा अगर आपके
रिस्पांस आते हैं कि आर दी क्लियर टू यू?
सो दैट वी कैन प्रोसीड।
एवरीबडी रिसोंड प्लीज
आई नीड टू रिसोंड आई नीड यू ऑल टू रिसोंड
प्लीज
गाइस आई नीड यू ऑल टू रिसोंड प्लीज डोंट
डिले इन रिस्पांस सभी सभी लोग रिस्पांस
कीजिए क्योंकि आई एम वेटिंग फॉर योर
रिस्पों्ससेस राइट क्योंकि काफी लोग यहां
पे हैं बट रिस्पांस काफी कम लोग करते हैं।
देखो वर्कब के बारे में मैंने ऑलरेडी
बताया हुआ है। हो सकता है आप लेट जॉइन हुए
होंगे इसलिए आप पूछ रहे होंगे। तो मैं
रिपीट तो नहीं करूंगा क्योंकि आप उसके लिए
आपको रिकॉर्डिंग देखनी पड़ेगी। ठीक है?
सिंपल वर्कब विजुअलाइजेशन करता है। बस यह
मैंने बताया था इंटरेक्टिव कैनवस वैसे जो
डाटा निकालता है लॉग्स के अंदर से सारे और
उसको चार्ट्स, मैप्स, ग्रेड्स या किसी भी
तरह का चार्टिंग के थ्रू, बार चार्ट या
विजुअलाइज करके चार्टिंग के थ्रू मैप्स के
थ्रू आपको सारी चीजें वो डेटा को दिखाता
है। लॉक्स के थ्रू। बस दैट्स इट।
अंडरस्टुड?
साथ में नोट्स भी बनाते हैं इसलिए कमेंट
नहीं करना। अरे तो नोट्स बनाते हो। अच्छी
बात है। बहुत बढ़िया है। नोट्स भी बनाते
रहो। कमेंट्स भी करते रहो और लाइक भी लाइक
भी ठोकते रहो। सब करते रहो।
है ना?
चलिए दैट्स फाइन। ओके गुड। तो ये चीजें आप
समझ गए हैं। अब हम अब हम आते हैं हमारे
भैया जी के पास ट्राईकमी के ऊपर में।
एसओसी वर्क बुक्स एंड lookअप्स वाली जो
रूम है इसके अंदर आते हैं। एंड यहां पर
इंट्रोडक्शन पर पहले आते हैं। तो यहां पर
कुछ भी जो इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट्स हैं मैं वही
आपसे डिस्कस करूंगा इसके अंदर। क्योंकि
मैंने इसके अंदर जो जो चीजें हैं वो
ऑलमोस्ट आपको सारी चीजें बता दी है।
कुछ-कुछ चीजें एक्स्ट्रा में आपको बताना
जरूरी मैं समझता हूं। जो चीजें मैं आपको
यहां पे बताऊंगा। तो इसको देखते रहिएगा
ध्यान से और जो जो चीजें मैं बोल रहा हूं
उसको बिल्कुल ध्यान से समझते रहिएगा। यह
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट होने वाली है आपके लिए।
ठीक है? अलर्ट ट्रायग इज़ अ कॉम्प्लेक्स
प्रोसेस दैट ऑफेन रिक्वायर्स एनालिस्ट टु
गैदर एडिशनल इनेशन अबाउट अफेक्टेड
एंप्लाइजज़ और सर्वर्स। मतलब अफेक्टेड
एंप्लाइजज़ के बारे में डाटा निकालना,
सर्वर्स के बारे में डाटा कलेक्ट करना, यह
भी एक इंपॉर्टेंट काम होता है। ठीक है?
तो, यह एसओसी वर्क बुक के थ्रू LOKUPS के
थ्रू आपका होगा। चलिए,
यहां पर हम इसको चेक कर देते हैं। ठीक है?
इसको हटा देते हैं।
अब आते हैं नीचे एसेट्स एंड आइडेंटिटीज के
ऊपर।
एसेट्स एंड आइडेंटिटीज के ऊपर मैंने सब
कुछ आपको ऑलरेडी बता दिया है। वापस से
थोड़ा-थोड़ा थोड़ा बहुत यहां पे रीकैप
करता चलूंगा। थोड़ी बहुत आपको रिवीजन भी
आपकी होती जाएगी और हम आगे लैब की तरफ भी
बढ़ेंगे। ठीक है? अब यहां पे देखो इमेजिन
इमेजिन हैविंग अ नाइट शिफ्ट एंड लुकिंग
इंटू एन अलर्ट सेइंग दैट जी बेकर लॉग्ड इन
इंटू द एचक्यू फाइनेंस एफएस2 सर्वर देन द
यूजर डाउनलोडेड द फाइनेंसियल रिपोर्ट्सlsx
फाइल एक्सl फाइल फ्रॉम देयर एंड शेयरर्ड
इट विद आर
ओके
पढ़ लिया आपने आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। टू
करेक्टली ट्रैक द अलर्ट एंड अंडरस्टैंड इफ
द एक्टिविटी इज़ एक्सपेक्टेड यू विल हैव टू
फाइंड आंसर्स टू मेनी क्वेश्चंस। राइट?
समझ में आ गया? टू यू हैव टू फाइंड द
आंसर्स टू मेनी क्वेश्चंस। तो अब आपको
यहां पे एक एक यूजर से शेयर हुआ है। वो
फाइल जो डाउनलोड की गई थी। ठीक है? कौन
लॉगिन किया था? जी बेकर ने लॉग इन किया
था। ठीक है? उसने डाउनलोड किया और शेयर
किया एक और यूजर से। ओके?
अब करेक्टली
ट्रैग करने के लिए अलर्ट को एंड
अंडरस्टैंड करने के लिए आपको कुछ आंसर्स
फाइंड करने पड़ेंगे। यू हैव टू फाइंड सम
आंसर्स जो आपको फाइंड करने पड़ेंगे। राइट?
हु इज जी बेकर? व्हाट आर देयर वर्किंग
आवर्स एंड रोल इन द कंपनी? हु इज जी बेकर
एंड व्हाट आर द वर्किंग आवर्स एंड रोल इन
द कंपनी? व्हाट इज द पर्पस ऑफ एंड लोकेशन
ऑफ द HQ Finance FS2 हु कैन एक्सेस इट?
ठीक है? व्हाई कुड दिस यूजर नीड एक्सेस टू
द कॉर्पोरेट फाइनेंसियल रिकॉर्ड्स?
ठीक है?
गॉट इट?
अब ये आंसर्स आपको चाहिए। ये आपको आंसर्स
करने आपको मिलने चाहिए। तो इसी के लिए
हमें जानकारी लेनी होगी। आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी की और एसेट इन्वेंटरी की। जैसे
मैंने बोला आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी जिससे आप
यूजर को पहचान पा रहे हैं। ठीक है? जैसे
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी इज अ कैटलॉग ऑफ यूजर
या कोई भी चीज जिसको एक्सेस है किसी चीज
का किसी भी चीज का।
थैंक यू सर। एटलीस्ट आप टीएचएम तो कवर कर
रहे हो। क्या बोल रहे हो भाई?
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी इज अ कैटलॉग ऑफ
कॉर्पोरेट एंप्लाइजज़ यूजर अकाउंट्स एंड
सर्विसेस। मशीन अकाउंट्स। मशीन अकाउंट्स
की भी बात है। ठीक है? एंड देयर डिटेल्स
एंड देयर
डिटेल्स लाइक प्रिविलेजेस कॉन्ट्रैक्ट्स
रोल्स विद इन द कंपनी। यह भी होते हैं।
राइट? तो ये मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी के बारे में हालांकि सब कुछ बता
दिया है। फॉर सिनेरियो ऑफ़ आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी वुड हेल्प यू गेट कॉन्टेक्स्ट
अबाउट जी बेकर एंड दिस यूजर एंड मेक इट
सिंपल। ठीक है? तो अब देखो एग्जांपल ऑफ़
आइडेंटिटीज़। अब ये किस टाइप के आइडेंटिटीज़
हो सकते हैं? किस-किस टाइप के आइडेंटिटीज़
इन्वेंटरी हो सकते हैं? तो अब देखो यहां
पे जैसे ग्रेगरी बेकर
ग्रेगरी बेकर इसका यूजरनेम है जी बेकर।
ईमेल है यह। यह यह अब इसका रोल क्या है?
चीफ फाइनेंसियल ऑफिसर। यह सीएफओ है कंपनी
का। लोकेशन इसका क्या है? यूरोप यूके।
एक्सेस किस चीज का है? वीpn का है। एचक्यू
फाइनेंस ये सारे जो मशीनंस हैं इन सबका जो
है
एक्सेस है इसके पास। उसी तरीके से एक और
है यहां पे रेमंड करके यूजर हैं। जिनका
यूजरनेम है। यह इनकी ईमेल आईडी यह है। यह
क्या है? यूएस फाइनेंसियल एडवाइजर हैं।
यूएस टैक्सेस में रहते हैं। वीpए और
फाइनेंस का एक्सेस इनके पास है। उसी तरीके
से केट करके हैं। के डैनर ये ईमेल आईडी
चीफ टेक्नोलॉजिकल ऑफिसर ये सारे मतलब कि
आइडेंटिटीज़ के ये एग्जांपल है कि मतलब
इनका पूरा नाम क्या है? ये आइडेंटिटी इनका
यूजरनेम क्या है? ईमेल आईडी क्या है? ये
किस रोल पे हैं? कौन से लोकेशन से जनरली
एक्सेस करते हैं? ये और साथ ही में एक्सेस
इनका पास इनके पास किस-किस चीज़ किस-किस
चीज का एक्सेस है? ये सारी चीजें जो है
इसके अंदर आती है आइडेंटिटीज के अंदर में।
अब सोर्स ऑफ आइडेंटिटीज की अगर बात करें
तो सोर्स ऑफ आइडेंटिटीज क्या-क्या हो सकते
हैं? तो एक एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी हो सकता है,
एसएसओ प्रोवाइडर्स हो सकता है, एचआर
सिस्टम्स हो सकते हैं, कस्टम सॉलशंस हो
सकते हैं। अगर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी की बात
करें तो ऑन प्रमाइस एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी या
इंट्रा आईडी इंट्रा आईडी जो है यह
Microsoft का ही aur अह एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
को बोलते हैं। अभी मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं। अगर मैं इंट्रा आईडी सर्च करूं तो ये
आपको यहां पे दिख जाएगा कि इंट्रा आईडी जो
है Microsoft का इंट्रा आईडी ये नया नेम
है। यह पहले इसको हम Azure एडी बोलते थे।
वी वर दिस दिस वाज़ नोन ऐज़ Azure एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी। पहले अब इसका नाम Microsoft
intra आईडी कर दिया गया है। तो इसको आप
लेके कंफ्यूज मत होइएगा। तो दिस इज़ एंड एक
ऑन प्रिमाइस एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी Microsoft
के द्वारा ही प्रोवाइड किया जाता है। तो
इससे भी जो है आइडेंटिटीज़ के ये सोर्स
हैं। वहां से आइडेंटिटीज़ जो है हमें मिलते
हैं। एडी इटसेल्फ इज़ एन आइडेंटिटी
डेटाबेस। हां, तो सही बात है। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी जो है ये ऑटो अपने आप में एक
क्या है? एक आइडेंटिटी का डेटाबेस है।
उसमें आइडेंटिटीज़ सारी चीजें लिस्ट स्टर्ड
होती है। एंड इज़ कॉमनली यूज़्ड बाय एसओसी।
एसओसी के द्वारा एडीज का यूज़ किया जाता
है। एसएसओ प्रोवाइडर्स जैसे कि ऑक्टा
Google वर्कस्पेस ये एसएसओ प्रोवाइडर्स
है। क्लाउड अल्टरनेटिव ऑफ़ ए फॉर एडी। अब
जैसे एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी जो है उसकी का
क्लाउड अल्टरनेटिव होता है ये एन इजी वे
टू मैनेज एंड सर्च द यूज़र्स। तो क्लाउड
अल्टरनेटिव वर्चुअली आप सारा कुछ मैनेज कर
रहे हैं। सारे आइडेंटिटीज को मैनेज कर रहे
हैं। वो चीजें एचआर सिस्टम्स जैसे कि कुछ
एचआर सीआरएम या एचआर सिस्टम्स प्रोवाइड
करने वाले कंपनीज़ हैं। जैसे बंबू एचआर हो
गया, सैप हाईब हो गया। ये सारी चीज़ जैसे
आप बमबू एचआर की बात करें हम
तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे बमबू एचआर द
कंप्लीट एचआर सॉफ्टवेयर फॉर पे फॉर पीपल।
तो यह एक एक कंपनी है जिसे बेसिकली क्या
करती है जैसे हायरिंग एंड ऑनबोर्डिंग का
सपोर्ट प्रोवाइड करना एचआर डाटा एंड
रिपोर्टिंग की सपोर्ट पेल एंड टाइम का
बेनिफिट्स एडमिनिस्टर ये सारे एंप्लई
एक्सपीरियंस का सारी डाटा मतलब एक से
ऑटोमेट करके ऑटोमेशन के थ्रू सब कुछ आपको
प्रोवाइड करने के लिए जो है वह आपको यहां
पे एक तरह से प्रोवाइड करती है। ठीक है?
अ
सर मैं पीछे हूं। ठीक है कोई बात नहीं। सर
बाइनरी एक्सपेक्टेशन रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग
वेब Android वीएपीटी एंड Python Linux सब
अच्छे से प्रैक्टिस करते हैं। लाइक मशीन
सॉल्व बट सर सीनियर बोलते हैं। यह
कॉर्पोरेट में 1% भी ना है। तो मैं क्या
करूं? ऐसा नहीं है यार। ऐसा नहीं है। देखो
दिस इज अ रॉन्ग परसेप्शन। रॉन्ग परसेप्शन।
दिस इज अ वेरी वेरीरी रॉन्ग परसेप्शन। अगर
आप ट्राईकमी के लैब्स को सॉल्व कर रहे
हैं। द बॉक्स के मशीनंस को सॉल्व कर रहे
हैं। अ प्रैक्टिससेस काफी कर रहे हैं,
कांसेप्ट्स को समझ रहे हैं। थ्यरीज को
अंडरस्टैंड कर रहे हैं। तो आपकी यही चीजें
काम आने वाली है। राइट अप्स को पढ़िए। यही
चीजें आपके एक्चुअली काम आने वाली है।
राइट?
तो प्लीज गो थ्रू दिस। राइट?
यह कोई पता नहीं कौन है। डिस्कर्ड पर
किसको बुला रहे हो भाई? डिस्कर्ड वाले
बंदे कौन है यार? यह डिस्कर्ड तुम किसी
दोस्त को बुला रहे हो डिस्कर्ड पे। चलो
बाद में आना डिस्कर्ड पे बुलाना उसको।
चलिए
तो
अब एसेट इन्वेंटरी की बात करें। जैसे
मैंने पहले बोला था आइडेंटिटी। अब एसेट्स
में क्या हो गया? वही कंप्यूटर, लैपटॉप,
हार्डवेयर, ओयर जो भी है तो एसेट्स इन अब
एग्जांपल ऑफ़ एसेट्स की बात करें तो देखो
यहां पे जैसे HQ Fin FS2 ये एक मान लो
होस्ट नेम है। इसका लोकेशन यूके डाटा
सेंटर है। IPपी एड्रेस दी हुई है।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम Windows सर्वर 2022 ओनर
कौन है? सेंट्रल आईटी डिपार्टमेंट इसका
ओनर है मान लो। ठीक है? एंड यहां पे पर्पस
क्या है? फाइल सर्वर फॉर फाइनेंसियल
रिकॉर्ड्स। तो फाइनेंसियल रिकॉर्ड्स के
लिए फाइल सर्वर है ये। उसी तरह HQ एडीडी
ये क्या है? प्राइमरी एडी डोमेन कंट्रोलर
है। एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी का डोमेन कंट्रोलर
है इसका। यह यूके डाटा सेंटर ही है। यह
IPपी एड्रेस है। तो मतलब जो डिवाइसेस है
ना जो डिवाइसेस हैं उसकी पूरी डिटेल
एसेट्स की पूरी डिटेल ये होती है आपकी।
उसी के साथ में यहां पे आपकी यहां पे एक
और मशीन है पीसी है। लंदन ऑफिस में यहां
पे ये क्या है? स्टेशनरी पीसी फॉर
अकाउंट्सेंस के लिए यहां पे है। कॉर्पोरेट
लैपटॉप्स है कुछ यहां पे उसके दी हुई है।
और सोर्सर्सेस ऑफ़ एसेट्स क्या हैं? जो
एसेट्स के सोर्सेस क्या हैं? तो यह भी
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के हैं। एसआईएम, एडीआर,
एमडीएम सॉल्यूशन, कस्टम सॉल्यूशन। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी वही ऑन प्रमाइस या इंट्रा आईडी
एसआईएम और इडीआर तो जैसे कोई एसआईएम,
एडीआर इलास्टिक या क्राउड स्ट्राइक की तरफ
से है तो वो हो गई। एमडीएम सॉल्यूशन एमएस
इंट्र इनट्यून या जैमf एमडीएम ऐसे करके
एमडीएम सॉलशंस होते हैं। ये क्या होते
हैं? डेडिकेटेड क्लास ऑफ़ सॉलशंस क्रिएटेड
टू लिस्ट एंड मैनेज एसेट्स। एसेट्स को
मैनेज करने के लिए होते हैं। तो ये इसके
सोर्सेस होते हैं एसेट्स के। अब यहां पे
कुछ क्वेश्चंस हैं उनको हम डील करते हैं।
यहां पे लुकिंग एट द आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी
व्हाट इज द रोल ऑफ दिस यूजर आर डैश एट द
कंपनी? तो अब आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी के उस
पे देखिए भैया। तो आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी
कौन है? ऊपर में है। तो हमारे आर भैया जो
हैं इनका पोस्ट क्या है? इनका क्या इनका
क्या काम है? यूएस फाइनेंसियल एडवाइजर ये
इनका रोल है। तो यहां पे ये क्या पूछ रहे
हैं कि इनका रोल क्या है? तो यूएस
फाइनेंसियल एडवाइजर और क्या? तो यूएस
फाइनेंशियल एडवाइजर
यह इसका रोल है। क्या है? नहीं है क्या?
ये एडवाइजर की स्पेलिंग गलत लिख दिया
क्या? हां एसईआर होगा।
एसईआर ये एडवाइजर रोल है। करेक्ट है।
बिल्कुल दैट्स इट। सिंपल।
अब चेकिंग द एसेट इन्वेंटरी। एसेट
इन्वेंटरी देखेंगे। व्हाट डस व्हाट डाटा
डस द एचक्यू फin fs2 सर्वर स्टोर? तो
एचक्यू फिन एफएस सर्वर जो है यह क्या डाटा
स्टोर करता है? तो यह फाइल सर्वर फॉर
फाइनेंसियल रिकॉर्ड्स। फाइनेंसियल डाटा
रिकॉर्ड फाइल सर्वर फॉर फाइनेंसियल
रिकॉर्ड्स। तो ये क्या करता है?
फाइनेंसियल रिकॉर्ड्स करता है। तो
फाइनेंशियल
अ रिकॉर्ड्स आई थिंक यही होना चाहिए। यस।
फाइनली डस द फाइल शेयरिंग फ्रॉम सिनेरियो
लुक लेजिटमेट एंड एक्सपेक्टेड? क्या ये जो
फाइल शेयरिंग हुई है सिनेरियो से ये
लेजिटमेट और एक्सपेक्टेड है। फाइल
सिनेरियो फाइल शेयरिंग। कौन सा फाइल
शेयरिंग हुआ था भैया? याद है ना आपको पहली
बार में कि जी बेकर ने फाइल डाउनलोड की थी
HQ Fin FS2 सर्वर से और इसको शेयर किया था
R बंदे से तो आप देखिए जी बेकर कौन है? जी
बेकर हमारा कौन है? चीफ फाइनेंसियल ऑफिसर
है। तो ये एक हाई अ मैनेजमेंट ऑफिसर है।
एंड इसने शेयर किया था R बंदे से जो कि एक
फाइनेंसियल एडवाइजर। यह कंपनी के ही पार्ट
है। कंपनी के ही लोग हैं। अपने लोग हैं
कंपनी के। ठीक है? तो एक ने फाइल डाउनलोड
की एक दूसरे अपने कंपनी के बंदे से शेयर
किया। तो यहां पे क्या ये जो शेयरिंग थी
ये लेजिटमेट थी? डस द फाइल शेयरिंग फ्रॉम
द सिनेरियो लुक लेजिटिमेट एंड
एक्सपेक्टेड? मतलब ठीक था लेजिटमेट? हां
भैया। तो अपनी कंपनी के लोग ही थे बेचारे।
एंड बेसिकली कंपनी के लोग थे और कंपनी से
कंपनी के बंदे को शेयर कर रहे हैं। एज़
सिंपल एज़ दैट। तो बस सही थी यार। हां, सही
थी। यह तो वाई ई ए यह दैट्स इट। हो गया
सही था। राइट? लेजिटमेट थी क्योंकि कंपनी
के लोग थे तो लेजिटिमेट हो गई।
आई होप यू गॉट इट। राइट?
समझ में आ गया? चलिए अब हम आगे की तरफ
बढ़ते हैं। ये तो पार्ट हमारा समझ में आ
चुका है। अब आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं नेटवर्क
डायग्राम्स के ऊपर। देखो अभी मैंने जो
चीजें बताई ना उसमें नेटवर्क डायग्राम
आपको नहीं बताया था। अब इसको मैं थोड़ा सा
समझा देता हूं एग्जैक्टली क्या होता है।
आपको और भी क्लेरिटी मिलेगी। देखो
नेटवर्क डायग्राम क्या होता है?
कंटिन्यूइंग आइडेंटिटी एंड एसेट इन्वेंटरी
टॉपिक्स यू माइट आल्सो नीड टू लुक एट द
अलर्ट फ्रॉम अ नेटवर्क पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू। अब
जो अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं उसको आप नेटवर्क
पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से भी देखेंगे।
मतलब मतलब आप नॉर्मल जो आप पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू
देख रहे हैं नॉर्मली उसके अलावा नेटवर्क
पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू भी होता है। ठीक है?
स्पेशली इन बिगर कंपनीज़। स्पेशली बिगर
कंपनीज़ में। छोटे कंपनीज़ में इसका रोल
नहीं है। बड़े कंपनीज़ में बहुत बड़ा रोल है।
कंसीडर द सिनेरियो वेयर यू आर
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग अ चेन ऑफ़ रिलेटेड अलर्ट्स
बेस्ड ऑन फायर लॉग्स। एंड वांट टू गिव सम
मीनिंग टू द आईपीज़ यू सी। अब मान लो कि आप
जो है अलर्ट्स जो हैं फायर लॉग्स के बेस
पे अलर्ट्स को इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हैं और
यह आप जानना चाहते हैं कि भैया यह आईपीस
जो हैं वो कैसी आईपीस हैं? कहां की आईपीस
है? किस तरह की आईपीस हैं? ये सारी चीजें।
ठीक है? तो
मान लो एक सिनेरियो है 8 बज 8:00 बजे।
8:00 बजे क्या होता है? एनआईपी
10361240174
इज़ रिपीटेडली कनेक्टिंग टू अ कॉर्पोरेट
फायर वॉल वाया पोर्ट नंबर टीसीपी
10443 अभी आपको 8:00 बजे पता चलता है कि
एक आईपी है वो कॉर्पोरेट फायरवल से कनेक्ट
कर रहा है हमेशा इस पोर्ट पे। चलिए अच्छी
बात है। 8:23 पे आपको पता चलता है फायरव
लॉग्स के थ्रू पता क्या चलता है कि आईपी
यह वाली आईपी जो यह आईपी जो कनेक्ट हो रही
थी वाज ट्रांसलेटेड टू एन इंटरनल IP मतलब
ये जो IP है वो एक इंटरनल आईपी पे
ट्रांसलेट हो चुकी है जिसका IP है
10.10.0.53
ठीक है?
यह इंटरनल आईपी देखो मास्टर गेमिंग 4503
दिस इज अ प्रीमियम लैब राइट दिस इज अ
प्रीमियम लैब अब्सोलुटली करेक्ट फॉर इन
फॉर द एसओसी एंड मैं आपको यह चीजें क्यों
बता रहा हूं यह मैं आपको यहां चीजें इसलिए
ही पढ़ा रहा हूं क्योंकि यह प्रीमियम
लैब्स हैं। आप में से हो सकता है कई लोग
इसको नहीं परचेस कर पाए या कई लोगों को
हालांकि देखो अब तो सस्ता हो चुका है। आप
पर मंथ ₹500 देके भी आप ट्राईमी के लैब्स
प्रीमियम लैब्स को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। बट
कई लोगों के पास वो भी नहीं हो पाता है।
मतलब एकद महीना कर लेंगे लेकिन हर महीने
नहीं हो पाता। तो यहां पे ये चीजें मैं
सॉल्व और ये चीजें मैं इतना आसान से इसलिए
ही बता रहा हूं ताकि आपको ये चीजें बिना
प्रीमियम के भी मतलब आप सीख सकते हैं। यू
कैन गो थ्रू द वीडियो। यू कैन लर्न थ्रू
दिस पर्टिकुलर क्लासेस। एंड आपको वो चीजें
मैं बता ही रहा हूं। बस दैट्स इट। आपको
चीजें समझ में आ रही है, पता चल रही है।
राइट?
या
तो 8:23 पे फायर लॉक से पता चलता है कि यह
जो IP है यह एक इंटरनल आईपी में ट्रांसलेट
हो गई है इस आईपी पे। चलो अब 8:25 जस्ट 2
मिनट के बाद द IP दिस दिस दिस जो इंटरनल
आईपी है स्कैनिंग दिस नेटवर्क रेंज बट डज़
नॉट फाइंड ओपन पोर्ट्स। अब आपको पता चल
रहा है कि यह जो IP थी जो थोड़ी देर बाद
इंटरनल IP पे मैप हो गई थी। इंटरनल आईपी
पे ट्रांसलेट हो गई थी। अब वही इंटरनल
आईपी से इस नेटवर्क रेंज को जिसमें कि
मल्टीपल आईपीस हो सकते हैं। स्कैन किया जा
रहा है। बट कोई भी ओपन पोर्ट फाइंड नहीं
किया गया। 8:32 पे आपको पता चल रहा है द
सेम आईपी इज़ नाउ स्कैनिंग दिस नेटवर्क
रेंज। पहले तो इसको रेंज को स्कैन कर रहा
था वह 172 1615.0 अब यह 16 1726.23.0
नेटवर्क रेंज को भी स्कैन कर रहा है। मतलब
एक दूसरे नेटवर्क रेंज को स्कैन कर रहा
है। एंड द अटैक सीम्स टू बी ऑनगोइंग और ये
चीजें रिपीट होती जा रही है, चलती जा रही
है, चलती जा रही है। तो मतलब यहां पे यह
हुआ कि सिंपल सा फंडा है कि शुरू शुरू
होता है इस आईपी से।
यह एक यह एक वैन IP है। एक बाहर की कोई
आईपी है। यह हमारे कॉर्पोरेट फायर वाल से
कनेक्ट करना चाहता है इस पोर्ट पे। अब यह
पोर्ट किसकी है? यह पोर्ट देखो यह जो
पोर्ट है 10443 इस पोर्ट पे क्या चल रहा
है? तो इस पोर्ट पे आप देखोगे तो यह एक
वीpए सर्विस चल रही है इस इमेज के थ्रू।
इस इमेज के थ्रू देखोगे VPN डॉट ट्राई
hmm.
10443 यानी ये वीpए चल रही है इस पोर्ट
पे। आप सोचो कि कोई बंदा फायरवल के फायरवल
कॉर्पोरेट फायरवल से कनेक्ट करेगा एंड इस
वीपीए पोर्ट के थ्रू कर रहा है। कुछ तो
सस्िशियस हो सकता है और उसके बाद उसको
इंटरनल IP मिल जाती है। देन अब वो इंटरनल
IP के थ्रू वो VPN की जो भी IP है ये ये
जो IP है 10.10.53 ये किस-किस सबनेट की
है? ये देखो ये 10.10.06
सबनेट की है। यानी कि ये VPN सबनेट की है।
यानी कि ये VPN सर्विस चल रही है इस IP
पे। तो अब ये वीपीए के थ्रू स्कैन कर रहा
है इन नेटवर्क रेंजेस को। ये दोनों
नेटवर्क रेंज। अब ये दोनों नेटवर्क रेंज
किस-किस के हैं? तो एक नेटवर्क रेंज आपका
डेटाबेस सबनेट है और एक नेटवर्क रेंज ऑफिस
सबनेट है। यानी कि एक जो नेटवर्क रेंज है
उसमें डेटाबसेस सारे पड़े हैं। डेटाबेसिस
की पूरी वो चीज पड़ी है। एंड दूसरी जो
सबनेट है उसमें आपके ऑफिस की पूरी सबनेट
है। ऑफिस में जो भी लाइक राउटर हैं,
स्विचेस हैं या मशीनंस हैं वो सारी चीजें
पड़ी हुई हैं। तो बंदा पूरा डेटाबेस भी
स्कैन कर रहा है। मशीनंस भी सारे राउटर
स्विचेस को भी स्कैन कर रहा है। और जो
जितने दूसरे कंप्यूटरटर्स एंड पॉइंट्स हैं
उनको स्कैन कर रहा है। तो ये बड़ी टेंशन
वाली बात है कि एक बाहर से आ रहा है बंदा
वो बंदा क्या कर रहा है कि फायरवल से
कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। वीpएन के
थ्रू फिर हमारे इंटरनल नेटवर्क्स को स्कैन
कर रहा है। गजब बात है यार ये तो। ये तो
डेंजरस बात है। राइट? तो अब इस चीज को
नेटवर्क डायग्राम से समझने के लिए यहां पे
क्या है कि हम नेटवर्क डायग्राम से समझते
हैं। तो आप देख सकते हैं कि ये थ्रेट
एक्टर है जो बाहर वाला बंदा है
10361240174
जो आईपी जो मैंने बताया अब यहां पे ये
क्या कर रहा है? यह वेबसाइट विजिटर्स है
नॉर्मल। अब यह वीपीए जो हमारा यूजर्स जो
वीpए वाली जो पोर्ट है उसके थ्रू जो है यह
कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। एंड
हमारे फायरवल के थ्रू कनेक्ट करने कनेक्ट
करके हमारे फायरवल के थ्रू कनेक्ट करके यह
क्या कर रहा है? स्कैनिंग कर रहा है।
किन-किन चीजों को स्कैन कर रहा है भैया?
तो
यहां पे डेटाबेस सबनेट्स को, ऑफिस सबनेट्स
को ये सब चीजों को यह स्कैन कर रहा है।
तो, आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे डिपेंडिंग ऑन
द कंपनी साइज़ एंड स्ट्रक्चर यू मे सी अ
मोर कॉम्प्लेक्स डायग्राम। यह तो नॉर्मल
डायग्राम है बट आप मोर कॉम्प्लेक्स
डायग्राम्स भी जो है अह आप देख सकते हैं।
आप आपको देखने को मिल सकता है अगर कोई
बड़ी कंपनी है या कोई बड़ा
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर नेटवर्क का बट देयर यूज़
फॉर एसोसिए एनालिस्ट रिमेंस द सेम बट देयर
यूज़ फॉर एसोसिएशन बट उनका जो यूज़ केस है
एसोसिस एनालिस्ट के लिए वो सेम ही रहेगा
टू हेल्प अंडरस्टैंड सस्िशियस नेटवर्क
एक्टिविटी। नेटवर्क एक्टिविटी को अच्छे से
समझने के लिए नेटवर्क डायग्राम का यूज़
किया जाता है। तो बीइंग एन एसओसी नेटवर्क
डायग्राम को समझना भी आपको आना चाहिए ताकि
आप अटैक्स को समझ पाएं। इन आवर सिनेरियो
यू कैन रेफर टू द नेटवर्क डायग्राम एंड
रिकंस्ट्रक्ट द अटैक फेज एट फॉलोज़। तो हुआ
क्या है? बेसिकली इस पूरे ये जो अटैक फेज
हुआ है, ये जो चार पॉइंट्स में मैंने आपको
अटैक फेज बताया। इसमें एग्जैक्टली क्या
हुआ है? इसको समझते हैं।
हुआ क्या है? थ्रेट एक्टर बिहाइंड दिस
आईपी परफॉर्म्ड वीpए ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
टारगेटिंग वीpn डॉट ट्राई hmm. तो इस बंदे
ने जो थ्रेट एक्टर था इसने क्या किया है?
इसने क्या किया है कि वीpए ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
करने की कोशिश की है और इसने टारगेट किया
है किसको? कौन से डोमेन को? VPN.
ट्रhatमी.
जो हमारा वीpए जिस पे बिलोंग करता है।
आफ्टर द सक्सेसफुल ब्रूटf द वीp एंड वीpए
लॉग इन इसने वीpए को सक्सेसफुली जो है
रूट फ़ोर्स कर दिया है। द थ्रेट एक्टर वाज
असाइन एन IP फ्रॉम वीpए सबनेट। अब जैसे ही
इसने वीpए को रूट फोर्स कर दिया है तो
इसको एक इंटरनल IPपी असाइन हो गई। क्योंकि
ये वीpए के अंदर घुस चुका है। तो वीpए
सबनेट से एक आईपी असाइन हो गई VPN वाली।
कौन सी आईपी असाइन हुई है इसको? ये वाली
10.10.053।
ठीक है? देन द एडवर्सरी ट्राई टू स्कैन द
डेटाबेस सबनेट। एडवर्सरी का मतलब यहां पे
होता है जो थ्रेट एक्टर है या जो हैकर है
उसकी बात यहां पे हो रही है। तो जो उस
अटैक थ्रेट एक्टर ने उस थ्रेट एक्टर ने
क्या किया? अब वो डेटाबेस सबनेट को स्कैन
कर रहा है। डेटाबेस सबनेट कहां पे है
भैया? 172 1726.15
वाली सबनेट। तो ये पहले उसी सबनेट को
स्कैन कर रहा है। तो डेटाबेस सबनेट को
स्कैन कर रहा है। बट वाज़ लाइकली ब्लॉक्ड
बाय द फायरवल रूल्स। बट इसको ब्लॉक कर
दिया गया फॉरवर्ड रूल्स में रूल्स के के
अकॉर्डिंग इस बंदे को जो है ब्लॉक कर दिया
गया। ठीक है?
सीइंग नो सक्सेस ब्लॉक हो गया। सक्सेस
नहीं मिली। द थ्रेट एक्टर स्विचेस टू द
ऑफिस सबनेट। अब ये ऑफिस सबमिनेट को स्कैन
करने लगा अपने नेक्स्ट टारगेट को फाइंड
करने के लिए। अब ये ऑफिस सबनेट पे घुस गया
कि भैया आप ऑफिस सबनेट पे चलो नेक्स्ट को
फाइंड करो। यह पूरा प्रोसेस चल रहा है। अब
यहां पे कुछ क्वेश्चंस हैं। इसके आंसर आप
लोगों को भी करने हैं। ठीक है? देन आई विल
डू। ओके? अकॉर्डिंग टू द नेटवर्क डायग्राम
वि सर्विस इज़ एक्सपोज्ड ऑन द TCP 10443
पोर्ट? तो मुझे बताइए TCP 10443 पोर्ट पे
कौन सी सर्विस एक्सपोज्ड है? इसका आंसर
क्या होगा? बताइए देख के।
बिल्कुल सही सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए।
ऑब्वियसली दिस इज़ सर्वे 443 पे यहां पे
दिख रहा है ना यहां पे वीपीए वीपीए।
सो इट्स द वीपीए सर्विस।
नाउ वि सबनेट वुड द सर्वर बिहाइंड दिस
आईपी बिलोंग टू? ये कौन से सबनेट से
बिलोंग करता है?
वि सबनेट द सर्वर बिहाइंड दिस IP बिलोंग
टू 1726 15.99
15.99 कौन से सबनेट से बिलोंग करेगा?
15.99 172.16.15.99
इन तीनों में से कौन से सबनेट से बिलोंग
करेगा? बता दीजिए।
डेटाबेस वीpए या ऑफिस
172.16.15.99
IP जो होगी वो किस सबनेट से बिलोंग करेगा?
यह बताइए। डेटाबेस सबनेट से, वीpए सबनेट
से या ऑफिस सबनेट से? बताइए फटाफट।
बताओ सबनेट का डेटाबेस वीपीए या ऑफिस
सबनेट
ओके
छुप गए हैं।
नहीं इतना तो दिख रहा है शायद।
लास्ट का है ऑफिस सबनेट लास्ट का यहां
देखो ना यह देखो यह देखो ऑफिस सबनेट इसको
मैं यहां से ज़ूम करता हूं शायद तुम्हें
दिखेगा
ये देखो ऑफिस सबनेट
जिन्होंने बोला डेटाबेस सबनेट उनका आंसर
बिल्कुल सही है
ऑफिस सबनेट नहीं होगा क्योंकि इसका जो
आईपी है देखो 172 16 172.16.15.99
है और डेटाबेस वाला 15.0 सबनेट है। यानी
15.99 इसी के अंदर आएगा। तो दिस इज़
डेटाबेस सबनेट। ठीक है? डेटाबेस सबनेट
होगा यह। तो इसका आंसर जो होगा वो होगा अ
डेटाबेस।
अरे यार सबनेट
फाइनली डस द सिनेरियो लुक लाइक अ ट्रू
पॉजिटिव। क्या यह सिनेरियो ट्रू पॉजिटिव
लग रहा है? यह क्या ट्रू पॉजिटिव है? यह
बताइए मुझे। जो यह अभी हुई है, थ्रेट
एक्टर ने अटैक किया, ब्रूट फ़ोर्स किया,
घुस गया, फिर स्कैन कर रहा है। तो क्या यह
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है?
लेट मी नो।
भारी मिस्टेक हो गया। कोई बात नहीं यार।
मिस्टेक्स होते रहते हैं। ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव
है या फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है?
अरे भैया फॉल्स पॉजिटिव कैसे होगा यार?
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है ना? व्हाई फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
कहां है? कहां दिमाग नहीं चल रहा है क्या
अभी? अरे ट्रू पॉजिटिव है। यह एक्चुअली हो
रहा है। दिस इज़ एक्चुअली हैपनिंग। यह बाहर
का एक्टर है। थ्रेट एक्टर है। एक्चुअली यह
कर रहे हैं। तो यह ट्रू पॉजिटिव ही तो
हुआ। दिस इज़ टीपी ट्रू पॉजिटिव।
करेक्ट? फॉल्स क्यों हो गया यार? सर फॉल्स
क्यों बोल रहे हो? ट्रू पॉजिटिव होगा।
राइट? चलिए गॉट इट। अब आते हैं वेब बुक्स
थ्योरी पे। वेब बुक्स की थ्योरी का मैंने
आपको ऑलरेडी बता दिया था, समझा दिया था।
बट इसको थोड़ा सा रिवाइज़ कर देते हैं।
जैसा मैंने बताया था सॉरी वर्क बुक थ्योरी
पे जैसा मैंने आपको बताया था कि एसओसी
वर्क बुक्स आल्सो कॉल्ड प्लेबुक्स, रन
बुक्स एंड वर्क फ्लो। इसको हम यह भी बोलते
हैं प्लेबुक, वर्क बुक, रन बुक और वर्क
फ्लो इज़ अ स्ट्रक्चर डॉक्यूमेंट दैट
डिफाइन द स्टेप्स रिक्वायर्ड टू
इन्वेस्टिगेट एंड रेमडीएट स्पेसिफिक
थ्रेट्स एफिशिएंटली एंड कंसिस्टेंटली। एक
स्पेसिफिक थ्रेट को एफिशिएंटली और
कंसिस्टेंटली जो है इन्वेस्टिगेट
अह
करने का स्टेप रेमडीएट करने का स्टेप जो
है वो वर्कब के थ्रू मिलती है। जैसे मैंने
बताया था कि विजुअलाइज़ करके मिलता है
चार्ट। विजुअलाइज़ चार्ट मिलता है। सिंस
एल1 एनालिस्ट आर कंसीडर जूनियर स्पेशलिस्ट
एंड आर नॉट एक्सपेक्टेड टू ट्राईग एव्री
पॉसिबल अटैक सिनेरियो परफेक्टली। मतलब सी
एसओसी एल1 जो एनालिस्ट होते हैं वो जूनियर
वाले होते हैं छोटे-मोटे।
ठीक है? छोटे बच्चे तो उनको यह जरूरी नहीं
है कि वो सारे मतलब अटैक्स को ट्राई करें।
ऐसा नहीं है। सीनियर एनालिस्ट्स ऑफेन
प्रिपेयर वर्क बुक्स टू सपोर्ट देयर लेस
एक्सपीरियंस्ड टीममेट्स। तो सीनियर
एनालिस्ट जो होते हैं वो जनरली वर्क बुक्स
को प्रिपेयर करते हैं ताकि जूनियर
एनालिस्ट्स उसको यूज़ कर पाएं। उस पे काम
कर पाएं। ठीक है? एफिशिएंटली एल1
एनालिस्ट्स आर रिकमेंडेड एंड समटाइ्स इवन
रिक्वायर्ड टू ट्रैक द अलर्ट्स प्रिसाइज़ली
अकॉर्डिंग टू वर्क बुक्स टू अवॉयड
मिस्टेक्स एंड स्ट्रीमलाइन द एनालिसिस। तो
जो एल1 एनालिस्ट्स होते हैं हमारे हमारे
जो एनुअल एनालिस्ट भैया हैं ये
इनको रिकमेंड किया जाता है कि आप जो है
ट्राई अलर्ट्स को कीजिए बट वर्कब्स के
अकॉर्डिंग कीजिए वो ज्यादा बेटर रहेगा।
वर्कब्स में जिस तरीके से विजुअलाइज़ करके
आपको सारी चीजें बताई जा रही है उसके
अकॉर्डिंग कीजिए। वो आपको ज्यादा अच्छा
मतलब तरीका से आप अलर्ट कर पाएंगे मतलब
ट्राई कर पाएंगे। तो वर्क बबुक के
एग्जांपल में देखिए जैसे कोई वर्क कोई एक
अटैक एक अलर्ट है अनयूजुअल लॉग इन लोकेशन
वर्क बुक मान लो कोई एक अनयूजुअल लॉग इन
हो रहा है एक अनयूजुअल लॉग इन लोकेशन मतलब
कोई एक ऐसी लोकेशन से लॉग इन हो रही है जो
अनयूजुअल है उसका वर्कबुक कैसा हो सकता है
तो इसमें तीन फेजेस हैं। एक इनरचमेंट
स्टेज है, एक इन्वेस्टिगेशन स्टेज है और
एक एस्केलेशन स्टेज है। तीन स्टेज होते
हैं एल1 के लिए। तो इनरचमेंट स्टेज में
क्या होता है? सबसे पहले ये देखते हैं।
ठीक है? इनरचमेंट स्टेज में क्या होता है?
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग इन द इनरचमेंट स्टेट?
अलर्ट रिसीव होता है। इनरचमेंट स्टेट में
क्या होता है? एक अलर्ट को एक एक अलर्ट
रिसीव हुआ है यहां पे। पहले स्टेप में आप
यहां पे देख पा रहे होंगे। ठीक है? अलॉट
रिसीव्ड।
देन
यूज़ बमबू एचआर टू फाइंड आउट एक्सपेक्टेड
यूज़र्स लोकेशन। अब बमबू एचआर का यूज़ किया
गया जिससे कि यूजर का एक्सपेक्टेड लोकेशन
पता चलेगा। एक थर्ड पार्टी टूल है ये।
लुक अप लॉगिन आईपी इन थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
सर्विज। अब यह लुकअप किया जाएगा लॉग इन
आईपी का थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस सर्विस में कि
भैया यह जो आईपी है एग्जैक्टली कोई
मलिशियस आईपी तो नहीं है। उसका लिस्ट देखा
जाएगा। लुक अप लॉगिन आईपी इन एनोनमाइजेशन
डिटेक्शन सर्विज। जो एनोनमाइजेशन डिटेक्शन
कोई एनोनिमस आईपी एड्रेस तो नहीं है। कोई
मलशियस या एनोनिमस आईपी एड्रेस जो अभी तक
नहीं हमें पता है वह तो नहीं है। उसके लिए
लुकअप किया जाएगा। अगर यहां पर नेक्स्ट
सिनेरियो आता है लॉग इन आईपी कंफर्म्ड टू
बी मशियस। अगर यह लॉग इन आईपी कंफर्म्ड हो
चुका है कि यह मलिशियस है। यस कंफर्म्ड
होता है तो एस्केलेशन स्टेज आ जाएगी। ये
वाली स्टेज सीधा एस्केलेशन स्टेज जो यहां
पे ये अरे हट जा यार।
ये हट क्यों नहीं रहा है?
हां। सीधा एस्केलेशन स्टेज पे चला जाएगा।
अगर ये मलिशियस है अगर ये मलशियस नहीं
होता लेट्स सपोज इट्स फाउंड नॉट टू बी
मॉलसियस तो क्या होगा यूज़ स्प्लंक टू
लिस्ट यूजर एक्शंस फॉलोइंग द लॉग इन तो अब
स्प्लक टूल या कोई भी एसआईएम टूल का यूज़
करके जो यूजर
एक्शंस हैं उसको लिस्ट किया जाएगा ठीक है
जो यूजर क्या कर रहा है बेसिकली लॉग इन
करने की कोशिश कर रहा है उसके सारे एक्शंस
को लिस्ट किया जाएगा एनी सस्िशियस एक्शंस
लाइक मल्टीफेक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन रिसेट ऐसा
कोई अगर सस्िशियस एक्शन हो रहा है। अगर यस
ऐसा कुछ हो रहा है तो अगेन एस्केलेशन
स्टेज पे ये चला जाएगा। यानी अगेन लास्ट
स्टेज जो है यहां पे चला आएगा। अगर नहीं
नो अगर ऐसा नहीं है तो फिर क्या होगा? रन
स्प्लंक लॉगिन लॉगिन टाइमलाइन डैशबोर्ड
फॉर 90 डेज। अब स्प्ल का लॉगिन टाइमलाइन
डैशबोर्ड जो है उसको चलाया जाएगा 90 डेज
के लिए। यानी 90 दिनों के लिए लॉगिन
टाइमलाइन का स्टेज चलेगा जिसमें कि वह
यूजर का पूरा लॉग इन हिस्ट्री जो है वो
कैप्चर होगा 90 दिनों तक तीन महीनों तक कि
भैया ये कब कब लॉग इन कर रहा है कहां का
लॉग इन कर रहा है एग्जैक्टली किस तरीके से
कहां क्या लॉगिन कर रहा है क्या कर रहा है
वो सारी चीजें मॉनिटर होगी क्योंकि ये
सस्पिशियस कैटेगरी में तो आ गया मान लो
ठीक है अगर यहां पे इसको पहले ही पता चल
जा रहा है कि हां ये सस्िशियस एमएफए रिसेट
हो रहा है तो एस्केलेशन में चला जाएगा।
लेकिन फिर भी अगर बाय चांस यह सस्िशियस
बोल रहा है कि नहीं भैया सस्िशियस कैटेगरी
में अभी तो नहीं आ रहा है। अगर नो कैटेगरी
में तो फिर भी लेकिन एक सिक्योरिटी पर्पस
के लिए एक लॉग इन टाइमलाइन चलाया जाएगा
स्प्ल का 90 दिनों के लिए। स्प्लंक जैसी
टूल कोई सी भी टूल हो सकती है। कोई सी भी
एसआईएम टूल की यहां पे बात हो रही है।
यहां स्प्ल का एग्जांपल लिया जा रहा है।
बट यह कोई सा भी टूल हो सकता है। ठीक है?
एसआईएम कोई सा भी टूल।
अब इसके बाद क्या होगा? लॉग इन वाया वीपीए
और फ्रॉम अ टिपिकल लोकेशन। अब यहां पे फिर
से होगा जब लॉग इन हिस्ट्री लॉग इन
टाइमलाइन चल रही होगी तो इसमें देखा जाएगा
कि क्या किसी वीpए के द्वारा लॉग इन भी
किया जा रहा है या कोई अ टिपिकल लोकेशन या
ऐसी कोई लोकेशन जो नॉर्मल यूजुअल लोकेशन
नहीं है। क्या लॉग इन किया जा रहा है? तो
अगर यस है अगर यस वीpए या कोई अननोन
लोकेशन से लॉगिन किया जा रहा है तो
कांटेक्ट द यूजर एंड प्रोसीड डिपेंडिंग ऑन
यूज़र्स रिस्पांस तो यूजर को कांटेक्ट करना
है और उसके रिस्पांस के अकॉर्डिंग आगे
प्रोसीड करना है अगर एस्केलेट करना है तो
एस्केलेशन स्टेज पे चला जाएगा। अगर ऐसा
नहीं है तो लॉग इन टाइम और टिपिकल फॉर द
यूजर। अब देखना है अगर ऐसा नहीं है तो
देखना है कि लॉग इन टाइम जो है वो क्या
कुछ अनयूजुअल है। अगर लॉगिन टाइम अनयूजुअल
यस है तो फिर से यूजर को कांटेक्ट करना है
और एस्केलेशन स्टेज पे जाना है उसके
रिस्पांस के अकॉर्डिंग। अगर लॉग इन टाइम
अनयूजुअल नहीं है नो तो क्लोज द अलर्ट एज
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। अगर इतना करने के बाद में
भी अगर नो ही आ रहा है तो इस अलर्ट को
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव के तौर पे क्लोज कर देना
है। यह बात होती है ट्रू पॉजिटिव और फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव। ट्रू पॉज़िटिव होगा तो एस्केलेट
करना है। फॉल्स पॉज़िटिव्स अगर निकल के आ
रहे हैं तो उसको हटाओ, क्लज़ करो, भगा दो,
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करो, अपना रिपोर्ट लिखो और
सामने वाले को बताओ अपने सीनियर को कि
भैया ये फॉल्स पॉजिटिव था, खत्म। कहानी
इसका खत्म। तो इस तरीके से यह बनती है।
मतलब यह पूरा एक पैटर्न फॉलो होता है। एक
अगर सस्िशियस कोई चीज़ आ रही है तो उसको बस
वहीं पे छोड़ें। उसको आगे भी नोटिस आपको भी
देखा जाता है। आगे फिर फ़र्दर
इन्वेस्टिगेशन होती है। देखा जाता है। कुछ
टाइम तक उसको मॉनिटर किया जाता है। अगर
उसके बाद भी लग रहा है कि नहीं यार ये तो
नहीं है कुछ ऐसा। मल्टीपल सिनेरियोस को
लाया जाता है। मल्टीपल कंडीशंस लाए जाते
हैं। अब जैसे आपने देखा अलर्ट रिसीव हुआ।
अलर्ट रिसीव क्यों हुआ? क्योंकि एसआईएम
डैशबोर्ड एसआईएम में लगा कि हां कुछ तो
बात है। तो अब यहां पे लुकअप आईपी मलेशियस
है कि नहीं। थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस सर्विज में
लिस्ट देखा गया। यह है कि नहीं। देखा गया
एनोनिमस आईपी कोई रैंडम आईपी तो नहीं है
वो देखा गया अगर आईपी कंफर्म्ड है मलेशियस
तब तो वहीं से एस्केलेट कर दो अपने सीनियर
को भाई कंफर्म्ड मलेशियस ही है पहले ही
मिल गया मुझे तो कंफर्म कर दो लेकिन अगर
नहीं है तो फिर अगला स्टेप चालू कर दो कि
स्प्लंक जैसे एसआईएम टूल का यूज़ करो और
यूज़र्स की एक्शंस को पूरा मॉनिटर करो उसके
बाद देखो कि क्या वो मल्टीफैक्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन कर रहा है क्या यूजर एक्शन
मॉनिटर हो रही है तो अगर हां कर रहा है
मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन रिसेट तो वहीं पे
फिर पकड़ा गया उसको एस्केलेट कर दो ये
एकदम ट्रू पॉजिटिव है। अपने सीनियर को
भेजो। अगर फिर वहां पे भी नहीं पकड़ा गया
कि नहीं भाई ये तो नहीं कर रहा। फिर सोचो
कि अरे यार अलॉट आई थी तो उसको आगे की तरफ
प्रोसीड करते हैं। अब आगे की तरफ प्रोसीड
करेंगे तो फिर इस प्लंक का लॉग इन
टाइमलाइन चला दो। डैशबोर्ड 90 दिनों तक 90
दिनों तक इसको मॉनिटर करेंगे भाई। और उन
90 दिनों में अगर यह वीpए से लॉग इन कर
रहा है या कोई अनयूजुअल लोकेशन से लॉग इन
कर रहा है। यह चेक करना है आपको। अगर हां
लॉग इन कर रहा है तो उस बंदे तक पहुंचो
जाओ और उससे पूछो भाई क्या बात है वीपीए
क्यों चला रहे हो क्यों इधर-उधर से लॉग इन
कर रहे हो क्या दिक्कत है अगर वो
सेटिस्फेक्टरी आंसर दे रहा है तो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है बंद करो इसको अगर कुछ डाउट हो
रहा है कि हां मलशियस है तो एस्केलेट कर
दो अपने सीनियर को और यह भी चेक करो साथ
में कि लॉगिन टाइम तो अनयूजुअल नहीं है।
अब रात को 2:30 बजे लॉगिन कर रहा है। अरे
क्या है भाई 2 2:30 बजे रात को क्यों लॉग
इन करेगा जब उसका शिफ्ट ही नहीं है मान लो
शिफ्ट नहीं है। खत्म है। बंदा नहीं है
शिफ्ट पे फिर भी लॉग इन हो रही है तो
गड़बड़ है। अगर ऐसा अगर हां ऐसा है तो
कांटेक्ट करो फिर से वही नहीं है तो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव बंद करो। और लास्ट में आती है
एस्केलेशन स्टेज जहां पे क्या होता है?
राइट अलर्ट रिपोर्ट एंड एस्केलेट द अलर्ट
टू एल टू एनालिस्ट। अब यहां पे आप अलर्ट
की जो है पूरी रिपोर्ट लिखिए और अपने एल2
भैया को एस्केलेट कर दीजिए। ये एक पूरी की
पूरी जो है ये स्टेज होती है। आई होप कि
इस स्टेज से आपको पूरा एसओसी एल1 का काम
करने का तरीका समझ में आ गया होगा कि वो
कैसे अलर्ट रिसीव होने से लेकर एस्केलेट
होने तक किस तरीके से मल्टीपल चीजों पे
काम करते हैं। मल्टीपल कंडीशंस मल्टीपल
सोर्सेस पे मल्टीपल एक्शंस परफॉर्म्स होते
हैं। मल्टीपल क्वेश्चंस होते हैं। वेयर,
व्हाई, हाउ एंड फिर जाके वो वो लास्ट
स्टेज पे पहुंचते हैं। उनको फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
बना के क्लोज करना होता है अलर्ट को या तो
ट्रू पॉजिटिव बोल के एस्केलेट कर देना
होता है। दैट्स इट। आई होप यू गाइस
अंडरस्टुड दिस। सभी लोग बता दीजिए देन वी
विल मूव फॉरवर्ड।
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीबॉडी।
समझ में आया?
एज एक्सपेक्टेड आपकी टीचिंग नेवर फेस
धन्यवाद। अच्छी बात है।
सर माय इंटरेस्ट इज इन पेन टेस्टिंग बट
इट्स ट्रस्ट बेस्ड।
ठीक है? सो आई एम लर्निंग फ्रॉम यू टू
एंटर थ्रू एसओसी 111 फर्स्ट। आई एम आल्सो
प्रिपेयरिंग फॉर ट्राईक मी पीटी वन। इज इट
ओके टू फोकस ऑन बोथ हेडफोनस? यस इज इट
ओके? देखो इट इज टोटली ओके टू
अ फोकस ऑन बोथ थिंग्स बट एट अ पॉइंट ऑफ़
टाइम यू नीड टू ड्रॉप वन थिंग टू मास्टर द
अदर थिंग। तभी जाके आप उसमें एक्सीलेंट
चीजें कर सकते हो। एक्सेल कर सकते हो।
दोनों को साथ में लेकर चलोगे तो आपकी
नॉलेज के लिए बहुत बेटर है। बहुत अच्छी
चीज है। यू शुड बी गोइंग विद द नॉलेज
थिंग। बट मास्टरी अगर करना है तो आप उसी
में करो जिसमें आपका इंटरेस्ट हो। चाहे आप
अभी करो या कुछ टाइम के बाद करो। एंट्री
ले लो आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन में।
जस्ट गेट इनसाइड द डोमेन अंदर चले जाओ और
उसके बाद आप रोल चेंज कर सकते हो अपने
इंटरेस्ट के बेसिस पे, अपने परफॉर्मेंस के
बेसिस पे। डजंट मैटर। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
हां जी। तो अब यहां पे आपको पता चल गया
होगा कि तीन स्टेज हैं इनरचमेंट,
इन्वेस्टिगेशन एंड एस्केलेशन। ठीक है?
इनरचमेंट में यूज़ थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस एंड
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी टू गेट इनफेशन अबाउट
द अफेक्टेड यूजर। यह पता चलता है।
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में यूजिंग द गैड डेटा एंड
एसआईएम लॉग्स मेक योर वर्डिक्ट इफ द लॉगिन
इज़ एक्सपेक्टेड। एस्केलेशन में एस्केलेट द
अलर्ट टू L2 और कम्युनिकेट द लॉग इन वि द
यूज़र इफ नेसेसरी। यह होती है। अब यहां पे
क्वेश्चंस है वि रोल वि एसओसी रोल वुड यूज़
द वर्क बुक्स द मोस्ट? कौन सा एसओसी रोल
जो है वर्कब्स को सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ करता
है? बताइए जल्दी।
सर फाइनली वन मोर सीवी असाइन हो गई मेरे
नाम पे। तीन सीवी हो गई। अरे क्या बात है।
अजू
आई थिंक योर नेम इज
अजय मीना कुछ ऐसे नाम है। कांग्रेचुलेशंस
ब्रदर फॉर दैट।
यस। तो इसका आंसर होगा एसओसी
एल1
एनालिस्ट।
बिल्कुल सही। एसओसी एल1 जो है वो अह
इसको यूज़ करते हैं सबसे ज्यादा। व्हाट इज
द प्रोसेस ऑफ गैदरिंग यूजर होस्ट और IP
कंटेक्स्ट यूजिंग यूजिंग टीआई एंड
lookअप्स। ठीक है? व्हाट इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ़
गैदरिंग यूजर होस्ट एंड IP कंटेस्ट यूजिंग
टीआई एंड LOOKUPS इसका क्या प्रोसेस होता
है? जो किसके बारे में यू होस्ट यूजर
होस्ट और IP के बारे में पता लगा है। तो
इसके बारे में किससे पता चलता है? कौन सा
प्रोसेस होता है? ये मुझे बता दीजिए।
कौन सा प्रोसेस होता है? इनरचमेंट। फर्स्ट
स्टेप फर्स्ट स्टेप यहां पे दिया हुआ है
अफेक्टेड यूजर वगैरह के बारे में तो इसका
स्टेप होगा इनरचमेंट
इनरचमेंट
बिल्कुल सही है। यहां आप लोग क्वेश्चन पढ़
के तब आंसर कीजिएगा प्लीज। लुकिंग एट द
वर्कब एग्जांपल व्हाट प्लेटफार्म इज़ यूज़्ड
एज़ एन आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी सोर्स?
आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी सोर्स के लिए कौन सा
प्लेटफार्म यूज़ हुआ है? अगर इसको हम देखें
तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं आइडेंटिटी
इन्वेंटरी के लिए कौन सा प्लेटफार्म यूज़
हुआ है?
यहां पे अगर आप देखेंगे तो वी आर सीइंग
हियर आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी के लिए यू कैन
सी यूज़ बमबू एचआर यहां क्लियर लिखा हुआ है
तो बमबू एचआर जो है
यह यूज़ हुआ है
फॉर द आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी क्योंकि वो एक
आइडेंटिटी सॉफ्टवेयर है जो आइडेंटिटी के
बारे में रिकॉर्ड रखता है। राइट?
दैट्स इट। आपने आंसर कर दिया। अब आते हैं
यहां पे मेन इसके प्रैक्टिस पे। यह एक मेन
वर्क बुक प्रैक्टिस है। बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग प्रैक्टिस आपके लिए है। इसको
हम प्रैक्टिस करेंगे। देखो
यहां पे है
लेट्स प्रैक्टिस बिल्डिंग द वर्कब्स।
वर्कब्स को बिल्ड करना है हमें। ओपन दैट
एज़ साइट बाय प्रेसिंग द व्यू साइट बटन
अबव। एंड फिल इन द मिसिंग वर्कब स्टेप्स
फ्रॉम द ऑप्शंस। ठीक है? ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप
द ऑप्शंस टू देयर रेस्पेक्टिव पोजीशंस। इफ
द पोजीशंस इज करेक्ट, द ऑप्शन विल स्टिक
देयर। वंस यू आर डन, रिसीव द फ्लैग एंड
कंटिन्यू टू द नेक्स्ट सेक्शन। ठीक है?
तीन तरह के यहां फ्लैग्स हमें लेने हैं।
यहां पे विजिट साइट पे क्लिक करते हैं।
साइट को विजिट करते हैं। ओके? यहां पे
हमारे पास कुछ इस तरीके का डायग्राम है
जिसमें हमें फिट करना है। तो इसको मैं
छोटा कर लेता हूं। यहां पे फिट करना है
हमें। ठीक है?
तीन यहां पर वर्क बुक्स हैं। वर्क बुक 1 2
3 वन को कंप्लीट करने के बाद शायद टू और
थ्री हमारा अनलॉक होगा। तो हम इसको शुरू
करते हैं। देखो यह कैसा वर्क बुक है?
वर्कब फॉर एक्सटर्नल ईमेल विद स्क्रिप्ट
और बाइनरी अटैचमेंट। एक एक्सटर्नल ईमेल आई
है कंपनी कंपनी में किसी को भी आई होगी।
जिसमें क्या अटैच है? स्क्रिप्ट या बाइनरी
अटैच्ड है। कोई स्क्रिप्ट है उसमें अटैच्ड
है। तो उसी के ऊपर यह वर्कबुक है जो हमें
बनानी है। तो ईमेल एनालिसिस का यह वर्कबुक
है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। चलिए हम अब इसको
बनाना शुरू करते हैं। तो यहां पे पहले
स्टेप में क्या होगा? फर्स्ट स्टेप में।
तो देखो फर्स्ट स्टेप में जब भी कोई अलर्ट
आती है तो उसको खुद को असाइन करना होता
है। वी नीड टू असाइन द पर्टिकुलर थिंग। तो
हमें यहां पे सबसे पहले तो आएगा अ
टेक ओनरशिप ऑफ द अलर्ट। मतलब खुद ओनरशिप
आपको लेना है। तो सबसे पहले यही आएगा। कोई
सा भी वर्क बुक कुछ भी हो। टेक ओनरशिप ऑफ
द अलर्ट। यूज़ आइडेंटिटी इन्वेंटरी टू गेट
कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ द ईमेल रिसीपिंट्स। ठीक
है? तो हमें यह पहला ये है। तो हम बिल्कुल
यहां लगाएंगे। ये स्टिक हो गया। मतलब यह
सही है। अगर इसके आप ऊपर आप कोई और लगाते
अगर वह सही नहीं होता, तो स्टिक नहीं
होता। ठीक है? ऐसा नहीं है। मैं इसको उठा
के डालूंगा इस पे वन पे तो यह इस पे नहीं
स्टिक होगा। तो हमारा टेक ओनरशिप वाला
बिल्कुल सही है। दूसरा चीज अब दूसरा लगाते
हैं भैया। दूसरा देखते हैं क्या है। हां
एक चीज और यहां पे आप देखेंगे इसमें
तो आपको यहां पे दिखेगा इज द अटैचमेंट
मलिशियस
यस तो उसका कुछ कंडीशन है दो यहां पे
एस्केलेशन का। नो तो उसका यहां पे क्लोज
है। ठीक है? तो जब ये वाले प्रोसेस हैं तो
उसमें क्या होगा भैया? उसमें क्या होगा?
व्हाट विल हैपन इन देयर? वो हम बाद में
देखेंगे। बट फिलहाल के लिए हम नेक्स्ट
स्टेप पे चलते हैं। उसमें हम तभी करेंगे
ना जब
राइट एंड अलर्ट रिपोर्ट वाली चीजें आएंगी
या सब चीजें आएंगी। तो पहले हमने यहां पे
क्या देखा? टेक ओनरशिप ऑफ द अलर्ट।
ओनरशिप। अलर्ट का ओनरशिप हमें लेना है
भैया। चलिए अच्छी बात है। हमने ओनरशिप ले
लिया। दूसरा स्टेप यहां पे है। अब आ रहा
है इन्वेस्टिगेट द ईमेल यूजिंग ईएमएल
एनालाइजर। जो ईमेल वाली एनालाइज करने वाली
सॉफ्टवेयर होती है उसकी बात यहां पे है।
इट्स एसपीएफ डीएआईएम कंटेंट एंड सेंडर
डोमेन रेपुटेशन। उसके बाद यहां पे आ रहा
है नोटिफाई ऑल एंप्लाइजज़ इन द चैट टू
अवॉयड यूजिंग द कॉर्पोरेट ईमेल गैदर ट्रैग
एविडेंस रिसीप्ट रिसिपिएंट लिस्ट सैंड
बॉक्स रिपोर्ट ईएमएल एनालाइजर रिजल्ट्स
एंड ये सब चीज़ है। ठीक है ना? अब देखो
यहां पे ईएमएल एनालाइजर रिजल्ट्स इसको
यहां पे गैदर ट्रैग एविडेंस। तो इसमें
ईएमएल एनालाइजर रिजल्ट्स भी शामिल है। तो
ईएमएल एनालाइजर जो ए रिजल्ट्स होंगे वह तो
तभी आएंगे ना जब हम ईएमएल एनालाइजर का यूज़
करेंगे। तो यानी ये स्टेप के पहले ये
स्टेप आनी चाहिए। इन्वेस्टिगेट द ईमेल
यूजिंग ईएमएल एनालाइजर। ये पहले आनी
चाहिए। ईएमएल एनालाइजर का पहले यूज़ होगा।
तब उसके बाद ये आएगा। बाकी और देख लेते
हैं। राइट अ शॉर्ट अलर्ट कमेंट।
एक्सप्लेनिंग व्हाई यू आर कॉन्फिडेंट दैट
दिस ईमेल इज़ सेफ एंड एक्सपेक्टेड। अब यह
कहां पे आएगा? देखो, राइट अ शॉर्ट अलर्ट
कमेंट। एक्सप्लेनिंग व्हाई यू आर
कॉन्फिडेंट दैट द ईमेल इज़ सेफ एंड
एक्सपेक्टेड। तो मतलब यह तब आएगा जब आपको
लगता है कि यह मलिशियस नहीं है। तो अगर इज
द अटैचमेंट मलिशियस तो यस जो आ रहा है तो
इसमें ये चीज़ आ सकती है कि राइट करो अलर्ट
को। मतलब
ये बताओ कि भैया आपके लिए कि क्यों ये
बिल्कुल सही मतलब मलेशियस जो है ये
व्हाई यू आर कन्व दैट ईमेल इज़ सेफ एंड
एक्सपेक्टेड? तो इज़ द अटैचमेंट मलशियस? तो
यहां पे नो आएगा। नो नो में आप यह वाली
चीज लिखेंगे तो आप यहां पहले ही नो में ला
सकते हैं आप इसको उठाओ और यहां नो में लाओ
क्योंकि ये इसी के लिए बना हुआ है ऑब्वियस
सी बात है दिख रहा है यहां पे क्योंकि
राइट अ शॉर्ट अलर्ट एक्सप्लेनिंग व्हाई यू
आर कॉन्फिडेंट दैट ईमेल इज़ सेफ तो भैया इट
अटैचमेंट मलेशियस नो मतलब ईमेल सेफ है
आपको लग रहा है तो ये इसमें आएगा ये तो
इसी के लिए बना ही हुआ है तो हमने इसको भी
ला दिया ताकि हम इस चीज को ऑप्शंस को कम
करें तो चलो अब ऑप्शंस हमारा यहां पे भी
काम आ गया अब एक और चीज़ है इज़ द अटैचमेंट
मसियस तो अगर हम यस बोलते हैं मलेशियस के
केस में कभी भी मलेशियस होती है तो
एस्केलेशन वाली फज़ आती है। राइट? तो उसके
लिए हमें क्या लिखना है यहां पे? दो
स्टेप्स यहां पे लिखने हैं। तो देखो यहां
पे क्या है?
कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस।
ठीक है? कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस।
यूज़ सैंड बॉक्स फॉर बाइनरीज़ मैनुअल। ये तो
अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस की बात है। तो इसको छोड़
देते हैं। अभी राइट राइट एन अलर्ट रिपोर्ट
फॉर एल टू एक्सप्लेनिंग द फाइंडिंग्स। तो
यह जो अलर्ट रिपोर्ट लिखने की बारी आएगी,
यह तो सबसे लास्ट में आएगा। तो, यहां लगा
दो। यह भी सही हो गया। ये फिल्टर आउट हो
गया। समझ में आ गया? ये सारे फिल्टर आउट
हो गए। अब यहां पे दो-तीन फील्ड्स बचे
हैं। अब इसके पहले अलर्ट लिखने से पहले
अटैचमेंट अगर मसियस है तो उसको एनालाइज़
करना पड़ेगा। राइट? तो क्या होगा?
इन्वेस्टिगेट द ईमेल यूजिंग ईमेल
एनालाइजर। ठीक है? इन्वेस्टिगेट द लॉग इन
इवेंट्स। ठीक है? कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट
एनालिसिस। यूज़ सैंड बॉक्स फॉर वाइंडिंग।
कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस। ठीक है?
नोटिफाई ऑल एंप्लाइज़ इन द चैट टू अवॉयड
यूजिंग कॉर्पोरेट ईमेल अंटिल द
इन्वेस्टिगेशन इज़ ओवर। यह इसमें पॉसिबल हो
सकती है क्या? नोटिफाई एंप्लाइजज़ अगर मैं
इसमें ये करूं नोटिफाई करने की तो ये नहीं
होगा। क्यों? क्योंकि हमें इससे
इंपॉर्टेंट पहले काम क्या है कि अगर
अटैचमेंट मलेशियस है तो इस पे हमें पहले
काम करना पड़ेगा। वी हैव टू वर्क ऑन दैट
थिंग। उसमें क्या करना पड़ेगा भैया? तो
हमने सबसे पहले यहां पे ओनरशिप ली है। ठीक
है? हां। ओनरशिप ली है। अब यहां पे हम
इसको इन्वेस्टिगेट करेंगे और इन्वेस्टिगेट
करके हम उसकी रिपोर्ट्स बनाएंगे।
रिपोर्ट्स बनाने के लिए हमें अलग-अलग
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन चाहिए। हम इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
लेंगे? उसके लिए क्या करेंगे? हमें पहले
तो यह इन्वेस्टिगेट द ईमेल यूजिंग ईएमएल
एनालाइजर। उसके बाद का ये स्टेप है। तो हम
यहां पे अब क्या करेंगे? इन्वेस्टिगेट लॉग
इन इवेंट्स ऑफ़ द ईमेल रिसीपिंट्स। ये हम
सेकंड वाले में डाल के देखते हैं। नहीं
है। कोई बात नहीं है। नोटिफाई ऑल ईमेल या
कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस। तो
कंटिन्यू टू करेंगे। यह भी नहीं आएगा।
नोटिफाई ऑल एंप्लाइज़ यह भी नहीं आएगा। तो
अब इसमें सबसे पहले ये वाली है
इन्वेस्टिगेट द ईमेल यूजिंग ईएमएल
एनालाइजर। तो हम इन्वेस्टिगेट करना शुरू
करेंगे ईएमएल एनालाइजर से। जैसा मैंने
पहले बताया था कि हम इन्वेस्टिगेशन चालू
करेंगे कि हम ईएमएल एनालाइजर यूज़ कर रहे
हैं। एसपीएफ डीकेआईएम ये सारी चीजें देख
रहे हैं। अब एनालिसिस कर रहे हैं। अब ये
एनालिसिस करेंगे और इसके बाद ऑप्शन एक और
क्या होगा कि अब हमें यहां पे बताना है
लेट्स सपोज़ कि यहां पे अलर्ट लिख रहे हैं।
तो अब हमें इसका सारा डाटा निकालना है। तो
हमें डेटा निकालना है गैदर ट्राईग
एविडेंसेस।
जो ईएमएल मैनेजर के रिजल्ट्स हैं वह सारी
चीजें का सारी चीजों का डाटा निकालना है
तो हमें यहां पर डाल देना है कि वह डाटा
निकाल के फिर हम एक रिपोर्ट लिखेंगे।
राइट? तो हमने यहां पे ये डाल दिया। अब
हमारे पास क्या बच गया? एक हमारे पास बच
गया नोटिफाई ऑल एंप्लाइजज़ इन्वेस्टिगेट
लॉग इन इवेंट्स ऑफ़ ऑल द ईमेल रिसीपिंट्स
कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस।
अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस तब करेंगे ना जब
मलेशियस हमें लगेगा। यहां पे मान लो कि
हां इट्स मान लो ये मलेशियस है। तो यहां
पे अब कट कंटिन्यू टू द अटैचमेंट एनालिसिस
यहां पे करेंगे। जैसे ही एंटर करेंगे
हमारे पास फ्लैग आ जाएगी। अब इसका यहां
फ्लैग को कॉपी कर लेंगे। ऐसा क्यों हुआ?
हमने यहां पे कंटिन्यू एनालिसिस अटैचमेंट
एनालिसिस क्यों किया? क्योंकि अटैचमेंट्स
का एनालिसिस करेंगे। तभी तो हमें
एग्जैक्टली पता चलेगा कि ये मलिशियस है कि
नहीं है। तो एनालिसिस किया और मलिशियस है
तो बाकी के स्टेप्स थे और नहीं थे तो फिर
तो सीधा कि हां भैया ये सेफ है। सब कुछ
है। और यहां पे हमें एक फ्लैग मिल गया। तो
हमने यहां पे फ्लैग डाला और यहां पे हमने
चेक कर लिया। एंड वी गॉट द फ्लैग एंड
सक्सेसफुली ये चीज़ हो गई। राइट? समझ में आ
गई ये? ये चीज़ नॉर्मल है ये। राइट?
नॉर्मल।
ठीक है? ये स्टेप्स थोड़े समझने पड़ेंगे
आपको। थोड़ी दिमाग लगानी पड़ेंगी। थोड़ा आपको
टाइम भी लगेगा। एज अ फर्स्ट टाइम जब आप
इसको करेंगे तो यू वुड टेक सम टाइम। थोड़ा
सा टाइम सोचने समझने में लगेगा। तो यू हैव
टू गिव द टाइम। कोई बात नहीं। टाइम दीजिए।
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। राइट?
गॉट इट
गॉट इट सभी लोग समझ में आ गया?
चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं सेकंड वर्कब पे
जो कि है पावर शेल एनालिसिस। दिस इज़ द
पावर शेल एनालिसिस।
अब आते हैं पावर शेल एनालिसिस में। क्या
है भैया यहां पे? वर्कब फॉर एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फाइल डाउनलोड यूजिंग पावर शेल। पावर शेल
का यूज करके फाइल डाउनलोड जो है फाइल
डाउनलोड हुई है। एक एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल
डाउनलोड हुई है पावर शेल का यूज़ करके। अब
इसको जल्दी-जल्दी करते हैं फटाफट। कैसे
करेंगे भाई? सबसे पहले तो असाइन करेंगे।
असाइन द अलर्ट टू योरसेल्फ। ये तो आपको
अभी पता है। असाइन कर लिया। असाइन करने के
बाद क्या करेंगे? एक एग्जीक्यूटेबल
डाउनलोड हुई। याद रखिएगा। राइट अ ब्रीफ
कमेंट एक्सप्लेनिंग योर बर्डिक्ट। ठीक है
ना? यह तो हटाओ। सेव द रिजल्ट्स ऑफ द विन
प्रोसेस ट्रीज़ एंड टाइमलाइन एसआईएम
सर्चेस। ठीक है? राइट एंड अलर्ट ये भी
नहीं होगा। बिल्ड अ प्रोसेस ट्री टू फाइंड
आउट द पैरेंट प्रोसेस एंड अकाउंट्स यूज़्ड
टू स्टार्ट द पावर शेल। ये एक अच्छी चीज
लग रही है मुझे। ठीक है? कांटेक्ट द यूजर
इन अलर्ट वाया ईमेल एंड कंफर्म द यूजर
अप्रूव्स पावर सेल यूज़र्स। ठीक हटाओ। यूज़
थ्रेट टू Intel टू एनालाइज़ द यूआरएल एंड
परफॉर्म द हां। अब यहां पे यूज़ द थ्रेट
Intel टू एनालाइज़ द यूआरएल। अब एक डाउनलोड
हुई है भैया। ठीक है? तो हम यूआरएल को
एनालाइज़ करेंगे यहां पे सेकंड पोजीशन पे।
क्योंकि यूआरएल ही सबसे पहले मिल रही है।
तो हम सेकंड पोजीशन यही काम करेंगे। उसके
बाद जब यूआरएल को एनालाइज कर लेंगे तो हम
एक प्रोसेस ट्री बिल्ड करेंगे। यूज़ द
प्रोसेस ट्री टू बिल्ड आउट द पैरेंट
प्रोसेस एंड अकाउंट यूज्ड टू स्टार्ट पावर
सेल। कि पावर सेल को स्टार्ट करने में कौन
सा पैरेंट प्रोसेस यूज़ हुआ है? कौन सा
अकाउंट यूज़ हुआ है? ये सारी चीजें हम यूज़
करेंगे। तो तीसरे नंबर पे ये आ गया। अब हम
देखेंगे यहां पे क्या? इज़ द फाइल मसियस
डाउनलोडेड फ्रॉम अनट्रस्टेड सोर्स। क्या
मशियस था? अगर नहीं था मलेशियस? तब तो
आपको यह लिखना है। राइट अ ब्रीफ कमेंट
एक्सप्लेनिंग अ वर्डिक्ट रीच एसओसी
इंजीनियर्स। नहीं यह भी नहीं है। राइट एन
अलर्ट रिपोर्ट फॉर एल टू अटैच योर एविडेंस
एसोस ये भी नहीं है। हम
राइट अ ब्रीफ कमेंट एक्सप्लेनिंग योर
वर्डिक्ट। ठीक है? रीच एसोसिएट इंजीनियर
टू ट्यून द डिटेल्स। हां ये वाली। क्योंकि
आपको लग रहा है कि नहीं ये मलिशियस नहीं
है। तो आप अपनी वर्डिक्ट देते हैं और यहां
पे लिख देते हैं कि भैया मलिशियस नहीं है।
आप अपना वर्डिक्ट दे रहे हैं। बात खत्म।
यह खत्म हो जाती है। लेकिन अगर मलिशियस है
तो क्या होगा? यहां पे सेव द रिजल्ट्स
फ्रॉम प्रोसेस ट्री। जो प्रोसेस ट्री आपने
बनाई थी उसका रिजल्ट्स यहां पे पहले आप
इसको सेव करेंगे और उसके बाद राइट एन
अलर्ट रिपोर्ट फॉर एल टू अटैच योर
एविडेंस। और ये सब चीजें करके यहां पे
अलर्ट दे देंगे। दैट्स इट। कॉपी किया यहां
पे और यहां पे फ्लैग डाल दिया। बहुत सिंपल
था। है ना? अब ये समझ में आ रहा है आपको
प्रोसेस? कैसे हमने किया ये चीज? आर यू
गेटिंग इट? प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीबडी।
एवरीबडी प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस।
ओके
क्वेश्चन क्लियर लग रहा है। चलिए अच्छी
बात है। अब यहां पे आते हैं तीसरे वर्कबुक
पे नेटवर्क एनालिसिस। क्या नेटवर्क
एनालिसिस है? पोर्ट स्कैनिंग फ्रॉम इंटरनल
आईपी। एक इंटरनल आईपी से पोर्ट को स्कैन
किया जा रहा है। यह यह है। तो सबसे पहले
तो भैया आप अपने आप को असाइन कर लीजिए।
असाइन द अलर्ट टू योरसेल्फ।
अब पोर्ट को स्कैन किया जा रहा है। ठीक
है? तो यहां पे
अब आते हैं
सबसे पहले तो इफ द इज द सोर्स आईपी
अनलिस्टेड और डस द स्कैनिंग पैटर्न
रिमाइंड मलेशियस डिस्कवरी अटेम्प्ट? तो
क्या यह सोर्स आईपी अनलिस्टेड या मशियस अह
डिस्कवरी अटेम्प्ट्स हैं? यह तो अगर नो है
तब तो आप अपना वर्डिक दे दीजिए। क्या है?
यहां पर आप
वर्डिक्ट में वही चीजें देंगे जो पहले दी
थी। राइट एन अलर्ट कमेंट एक्सप्लेन योर
वर्डिक्ट एंड रीच आउट टू एसओसी इंजीनियर्स
टू ट्यून द रूल। मतलब रूल को थोड़ा अच्छा
बनाने के लिए नो यहां पे ये कर दिया एंड
आपका काम यहां पे ये हो गया। तो ये तो
यहां पे आ गया। अब यहां पे आपने असाइन
किया खुद को भैया। यू हैव असाइन योरसेल्फ।
तो उसके बाद क्या होगा?
यूज़ इडिया टू वेरीफाई इफ देयर एनी अलर्ट्स
रिलेटेड टू डाटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन ऑब्टेन
अटेम्प्ट्स। इफ सोर्सेस इज अ कॉर्पोरेट
वेरीफाई इफ द स्कैनिंग पैटर्न इज
एक्सपेक्टेड। यह वेरीफाई करना है कि क्या
यह सोर्स जो है वह कॉर्पोरेट से आए हैं?
वेरीफाई या स्कैनिंग एक्सपेक्टेड था।
लिस्ट पोर्ट्स स्कैन बाय द आईपी। फाइंड
आउट व्हिच सर्विस कुड बी रनिंग ऑन द
पोर्ट्स। कलेक्टर एविडेंस अटैक टाइम रेंज
स्कैन पोर्ट्स एंड आईपी कांटेक्ट। ठीक है?
राइट एंड अलर्ट रिपोर्ट एक्सप्लेन योर
वर्डिक टू L2 अह एंड अटैच द एविडेंस फॉर
एल2। ठीक है? स्कैन फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स ऑन द
सोर्स आईपी फाइंड आउट सर्विसेस दैट कैन बी
रनिंग ऑन द पोर्ट्स। तो यहां पे पहले तो
असाइन किया आपने। उसके बाद अब यहां पे
क्या हो सकते हैं कि इफ सोर्सेस इज़ अ
कॉर्पोरेट नहीं। ये चेक करना है कि भैया
ये कॉर्पोरेट ये एक्सपेक्टेड कोई चीज था
ये हम अगर चेक करना चाहें बट हमें क्या
हुआ है कि हमें एक अलर्ट मिली है। राइट?
तो हम अगर इस चीज को लेकर आते हैं पहले ही
अभी तो जैसे हमने एक अलर्ट मिला है क्या
कि
अलर्ट क्या मिला है भैया? कि एक इंटरनल
आईपी से पोर्ट स्कैनिंग हो रही है। तो
हमें असाइन किया गया है। हमें हमने खुद का
असाइन किया है। बट यहां पे द थिंग इज़ हां
बिल्कुल यहां पे द थिंग इज़ यहां पे बहुत
लोगों के दिमाग से ऊपर जा रहा है। आई नो
बट और वो छोड़ के जा चुके हैं। बट इससे कोई
फर्क नहीं पड़ता है। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
आप लोग रिवाइज कीजिएगा हो जाएगा। समझ में
आ जाएगा। पहले यहां पे खुद को असाइन किया
हमने। अब यहां पे अब देखो लिस्ट पोर्ट्स
स्कैन बाय द आईपी। कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स को
स्कैन किया गया है आईपी के द्वारा? तो
इसको हम लिस्ट करेंगे। तो ये सेकंड नंबर
पर डाल देंगे सारे आईपीस को। अब जब यह
स्कैनिंग हो चुकी है तो अब क्या करेंगे?
इफ सोर्स इज कॉर्पोरेट तो जब आप स्कैनिंग
पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करेंगे। फाइंड आउट व्हिच
सर्विसेस कुड बी रनिंग ऑन द पोर्ट्स। ये
सारी चीजें हैं। तो इसके बाद क्या करेंगे
आप? राइट अह स्कैन फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स ऑन द
सोर्स आईपी। फाइंड आउट सर्विसेस दैट कैन
बी रनिंग ऑन द पोर्ट्स। यह है इफ सोर्स इज़
अ कॉर्पोरेट नेसेस ऐसे वेरीफाई इफ द
स्कैनिंग पैटर्न इज़ एक्सपेक्टेड और दूसरा
है यहां पे क्या है कि यूज़ एडीआर टू
वेरीफाई यूज़ एडीआर टू वेरीफाई देयर डेटा
देन अलर्ट्स रिलेटेड टू डेटा एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन अटेम्प्ट्स कि कोई डेटा एक्स
फिल्ट्रेशन भी हुई है कि नहीं ये तो तब हम
पता करेंगे जब हमें इज़ द सोर्स आईपी
अनलिस्टेड और स्कैनिंग पैटर्न रिवाइंड
मलेशियस डिस्कवरी अटेम्प्ट्स तो होगा तब
हम पता करेंगे तो अभी उसकी जरूरत नहीं है
तो अभी यहां पे हम क्या करेंगे?
नहीं नहीं अब देखो वहां पे अभी देखो पहले
हमने लिस्ट पोर्ट्स को लिस्ट किया। अब हम
यहां पे दो चीजें कर सकते हैं। या तो
स्कैन फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स या तो सोर्सेस
कॉर्पोरेट वेरीफाई द स्कैनिंग पैटर्न इज़
एक्सपेक्टेड। स्कैनिंग पैटर्न जो है वो
एक्सपेक्टेड है। सिंपल। तो स्कैन जो किया
है तो इसका इसका स्कैनिंग पैटर्न देखने के
लिए हम ये पता करेंगे कि भैया क्या ये
स्कैनिंग पैटर्न क्योंकि ये इंटरनल आईपी
से आ रही है। तो पहले तो हम लिस्ट करेंगे
पोर्ट्स को जो स्कैन की गई है आईपी के
द्वारा जो आईपी से स्कैन हो रही है इंटरनल
आईपी से सारे पोर्ट्स को लिस्ट करो। अब
देखो कि क्या ये जो स्कैनिंग पैटर्न है
क्या जो ये स्कैनिंग पैटर्न है वो
नॉर्मल है एक्सपेक्टेड है इंटरनली किसी के
द्वारा किए जा रहे हैं ठीक है तो अगर इफ द
सोर्स आईपी अनलिस्टेड और डस द स्कैनिंग
पैटर्न रिमाइंड मलशियस डिस्कवरी अटेम्प्ट
अगर यह मलशियस पैटर्न है यस तो अब क्या
करेंगे यहां पे हमारे पास बचता है
यूज़ इडी टू वेरीफाई देयर इन डेटा इन एनए
अलर्ट्स रिलेटेड टू डाटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
अटेमप्ट्स। तो यह देखेंगे इडीआर से
वेरीफाई करेंगे। अगर ऐसा पॉसिबल है तो
क्या हम इडीएस से वेरीफाई करेंगे? एक ये
ऑप्शन है। तो यहां पे हमने ड्राई करके देख
सकते हैं। दूसरा है कलेक्टर एविडेंस अटैक
टाइम रेंज स्कैन पोर्ट्स एंड आईपी
कॉन्टेक्स्ट। अपना डेटा कलेक्ट करो यहां
पे। मान लो दूसरा ये और दूसरा है रिपोर्ट।
मतलब रिपोर्ट कर दो। रिपोर्ट बना दो। तो
रिपोर्ट क्या है? राइट एंड अलर्ट रिपोर्ट।
तो अलॉट रिपोर्ट यहां पे करके यहां पे
फ्लैग ले लिया। राइट अलर्ट रिपोर्ट एक्ट
फाइल करो और कर दो। एडीआर की यहां पे
जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि डेटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन की यहां पे बात अभी नहीं आ
रही थी। अभी बात यहां पे सिर्फ स्कैनिंग
तक की थी। तो हमने एडीआर की कोई ऐसी कुछ
खासेंस हमारे लिए नहीं थी। दैट्स इट। तो
हमारा यहां पे ये जो चीज़ है तीनों फ्लैग
जो है हमारे पास आ गए हैं। एंड वी डीड इट।
कंक्लूजन में तो कुछ होता नहीं है। तो ये
चेक कर दो। बस दैट्स इट। यह हमारा कंप्लीट
हो गया। खत्म।
सिंपल। राइट?
ऑट इट
हां, यह नॉर्मल था जो कि हमने एसओसी
वर्कब्स एंड लुकअप्स का पूरा कंप्लीट किया
यहां पे। काफी इंटरेस्टिंग था। एसओसी
मैट्रिक्स एंड ऑब्जेक्टिव्स में अब आ जाते
हैं। ठीक है? ये छोटा सा है। ज्यादा बड़ा
नहीं है यहां पे। ठीक है? तीन मैट्रिक्स
के बारे में छोटा सा चीज है। जो मैं आपको
बताना चाहता हूं। अगेन इस पे आ जाते हैं।
कई लोग यहां से कई लोग बेचारे थक गए हैं।
यहां से चले गए थे। कोई बात नहीं यहां पे।
अब आते हैं
एसओसी मैट्रिक्स के बारे में। ठीक है? सो
क्या कहते हैं? क्या कहती है पब्लिक? शुड
आई कंटिन्यू या शुड आई स्टॉप? क्योंकि कई
लोग तो यहां से निकल चुके हैं। बेचारे ऊपर
से चले गए उन सबके। क्या बताएं अब?
बताइए।
एवरीवन लेट मी नो इफ शुड आई कंटिन्यू
एसओसी मैट्रिक्स
गिव अवे में पार्टिसिपेट आप नहीं कर सकते
हैं। गिव अवे एंड हो चुका है। गिव अवे हैज
बीन एंडेड।
सो मैक्सिमम लोगों का कंटिन्यू ऑप्शन आ
रहा है।
ओके? मैक्सिमम पीपल आर सेइंग टू कंटिन्यू।
सो वी विल बी कंटिन्यूइंग।
कंटिन्यू करते हैं। यहां पे हम बात करते
हैं एसओसी मैट्रिक्स की। ठीक है? अब इसका
इसका नॉर्मल सा कांसेप्ट है समझ लीजिए।
एंड दैट्स इट। इन अ एसओसी मैट्रिक्स आर द
हार्ट बीट ऑफ द ऑपरेशन। दे टेल यू इफ योर
टीम इज वेल ऑयल्ड मशीन। और इफ यू आर
ड्राइंग ड्राइंग इन नॉइज़ मतलब मैट्रिक्स
का मतलब है कि आपका जो एसओसी टीम है उसकी
कैपेबिलिटी यह टेस्ट करता है। आपकी एसओसी
टीम कितनी कैपेबल है कितनी इंटरेस्टिंग
टीम है और आपके एसओसी टीम का पूरा बजट
कितना होना चाहिए यह भी इससे तय होता है।
यह भी इससे अह फिक्स किया जाता है। अब जो
मैनेजमेंट है, कंपनी की मैनेजमेंट है, वह
एसओसी टीम की कितनी बजट रखेगी, कितनी बजट
देगी, कितना पैसा लगाएगी उस पे और टीम किस
तरह की है, यह मेजर करने के लिए एसओसी
मैट्रिक्स होते हैं।
ठीक है?
जोन नेम इफ यू आर हैविंग इश्यूज विद द
डिफ्रॉनिक्स ऐप आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट यू टू
प्लीज मैसेज अस ऑन द WhatsApp नंबर जो कि
हमारे आप वेबसाइट पे dfin.com पे जाएंगे।
उस पे सबसे ऊपर में ही हेडर में आपको
हमारा WhatsApp नंबर दिख जाएगा। आप उस पे
हमें WhatsApp पे मैसेज कर दीजिए। अपने
फोन नंबर ऑब्वियसली बात है उसी से करेंगे
आप तो आपका वो जो लॉग इन इशू रिॉल्व कर
दिया जाएगा। ठीक है? इट विल बी सॉल्व।
व्हेन व्हाइल ऑब्जेक्टिव्स एक चीज और होती
है। एक और होती है ऑब्जेक्टिव्स। तो
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स डिफाइन व्हाट यू वांट टू
अचीव। एग्जांपल रिड्यूस द रिस्क ऑफ डेटा
ब्रचेस। मैं तो मतलब जैसे डेटाबेस का मुझे
एक मैट्रिक्स का यू मैट्रिक्स का मतलब
होता है कैपेबिलिटीज़ का पता लगाना
एसोसिएटिव का। और ऑब्जेक्टिव्स मतलब हम जो
चीज़ अचीव करना चाहते हैं। जैसे डेटा
ब्रीचेस के रिस्क को रिड्यूस करना एक
कंपनी के अंदर में। मैट्रिक्स आर द
क्वांटिफायबल डेटा पॉइंट्स यूज़्ड टू मेज़र
द सक्सेस। सक्सेस को मेजर करने के लिए
मैट्रिक्स का यूज़ में मैट्रिक्स जो है
उसको यूज़ में लिया जाता है। ठीक है? वी
जनरली कैटेगराइज़ एसओसी मैट्रिक्स इनू थ्री
बकेट्स। एसोसी मैट्रिक्स को तीन बकेट्स
में कैटेगराइज़ जनरली किया जाता है। एक
ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स, एफिशिएंसी मैट्रिक्स
और स्ट्रेटेजिक मैट्रिक्स। तीन मैट्रिक्स
होते हैं। ठीक है? ऑपरेशनल, एफिशिएंसी एंड
स्ट्रेटेजिक। सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं कोर ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स से। जब बिग टू
बोलो या बिग थ्री बोल लो। मैं इसको बिग टू
नहीं बोलूंगा। मैं इसको बिग थ्री बोलूंगा।
ठीक है? अब इसको मैं टू को यहां लाइव थ्री
कर देता हूं।
अब क्यों थ्री बोलूंगा? ये भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा। बहुत लोग टू बोलते हैं। मैं यहां
थ्री बोलूंगा। द कोर ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स
में बिग थ्री। क्या है ये बिग थ्री?
ठीक है? व्हाट आर दिस बिग थ्री? इफ यू
ओनली ट्रैक टू थिंग्स ट्रैक दीज़। इफ यू इफ
यू ओनली ट्रैक टू थिंग्स ट्रैक दीज़ दे
मेज़र हाउ फ़स्ट योर टीम रिएक्ट्स। तो यहां
पर फिर से मैं थ्री करूंगा। इफ यू ओनली
ट्रैक थ्री थिंग्स
ट्रैक दी थिंग्स। ठीक है?
ओके? पहला है कोर ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स में
एमटीटीए, दूसरा है एमटीटीआर। और तीसरा जो
है आपका वो है एमटीटी डी। तीन चीजें होती
हैं। तो
एक आपका मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट होता है।
दूसरा आपका मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज होता है।
तीसरा आपका मीन टाइम टू रिस्पोंड या
रिमीडिएट होता है। तो फर्स्ट पे हम रखते
हैं मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट। ठीक है? दूसरे
टाइम दूसरे पे हम रखते हैं मीन टाइम टू
एकनॉलेज एंड देन हम मीन टाइम टू रिमीडिएट
रखते हैं। यानी एम
टी टी डी देन एम टी
टी ए एंड देन एट द एंड एम टी
टी आर ये एक नंबर पे ये दो नंबर पे और ये
तीन नंबर
ये तीन चीज़ होती है। तो पहले नंबर पे हम
एमटीडी एमटीडी एमटीटीडी को समझते हैं। मीन
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट। एमटीटीडी इज़ द मेजर ऑफ़
हाउ लॉन्ग अ थ्रेट एकज़िस्ट इन योर
एनवायरमेंट बिफोर योर सिक्योरिटी टूल्स।
एसआईएम, ईडीआर या आईडीएस एक्चुअली
ट्रिगरर्स एन अलर्ट।
मतलब एक अलर्ट
फर्स्ट टाइम जब ट्रिगर होती है और आपको
पता चलता है वही होता है मीन टाइम टू
डिटेक्ट। कितने टाइम्स वो आपके एनवायरमेंट
में था? गोल क्या होता है? द लोअर द
एमटीडी द बेटर। जितनी लोअर यानी कि जितनी
जल्दी कोई अलर्ट आपको मिल जाती है, जितनी
जल्दी कोई सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट दे देता है,
वह ज्यादा अच्छी बात है। अब मान लो कि कोई
एक थ्रेट है, वो आपके नेटवर्क में चारप
घंटे से पड़ा हुआ है और आपको अलर्ट ही
नहीं आ रहा है। तो, दिस इज़ अ वेरी बैड
मैट्रिक्स। दिस इज़ अ वेरी बैड एमटीटीडी।
राइट? व्हाई इट्स ट्रिकी? यू ऑफेन डोंट नो
व्हेन द एक्चुअल इंसिडेंट स्टार्टेड अंटिल
द इन्वेस्टिगेशन इज़ ओवर। जब तक आपको
इन्वेस्टिगेशन ओवर ना हो जाए। आपको पता
नहीं चलेगा कब स्टार्ट हुई थी ये सारी
चीजें। फॉर एग्जांपल इफ अ हैकर एंटर्ड द
नेटवर्क और मंडे एक हैकर है आपके नेटवर्क
में मंडे को घुस गया। बट द एसआईएम डिड नॉट
अलर्ट अंटिल थर्सडे। थर्सडे तक आपका
एसआईएम अलर्ट ही नहीं दे रहा है। द
एमटीटीडी फॉर दैट इंसिडेंट इज़ थ्री डज़।
क्योंकि मंडे को ही आपके नेटवर्क में घुस
गया। तो मंडे, ट्यूसडे, वेडनेसडे। ठीक है?
मंडे को घुसा तो मंडे, ट्यूसडे, वेडनेसडे।
3 दिन से आप केवल नेटवर्क में हैं। आपको
थर्सडे को अलर्ट आ रहा है। तो तीन दिन
आपका थ्री डज़ हो जाएगा एमटीटीडी।
समझ में आ गया? बस दैट्स इट।
हाउ टू इंप्रूव एमटीटीडी? आप अपना नेम बता
दीजिए किस या नंबर का लास्ट फाइव डिजिट या
फोर डिजिट बता दीजिए। जॉन नेम किस नंबर से
आपने मैसेज किया है। माय टीम विल गेट बैक
टू यू एंड रॉल्व योर क्वेरी। ठीक है?
लास्ट फोर डिजिट बता दीजिए। एमटीडीीडी को
कैसे हम
बेटर कर सकते हैं। बेटर लॉग कवरेज यू कांट
डिटेक्ट व्हाट यू कांट सी। तो बेटर लॉग
कवरेज होगी। अच्छी खासी लॉग कवरेज होगी।
तो जो चीजें दिखेंगी तो उसको डिटेक्शन में
भी आएंगी। एडवांस्ड एनालिटिक्स मूविंग
फ्रॉम सिंपल इफ देन रूल्स टू एमएल मशीन
लर्निंग दैट स्पॉट एनलीज़ लाइक अ यूजर
लॉगिंग फ्रॉम अ न्यू कंट्री। तो यहां पे
वही बात है। मशीन लर्निंग का यूज़ करना,
आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस का यूज़ करना। इससे
भी आप एमटीडी को लोअर कर सकते हैं। थ्रेट
Intel
यूजिंग lookअप्स फॉर टू ऑटोमेटिकली फ्लैग
नोन बैड आईपीस द मोमेंट डिड टच योर
नेटवर्क। lookups का यूज़ करना। जैसे मैंने
पहले बताया lookअप्स क्या होते हैं? सब
चीजें पता होती है उनको। तो lookups का
यूज़ करके बैड आईपीस की लिस्ट से आईपीस को
निकाल के पहले ही अलर्ट कर देना कि भैया
नेटवर्क में कुछ मिलिश आईपीस घुस चुके
हैं। इससे आप एमटीटीडी को लोअर कर सकते
हो। लेस कम कर सकते हो। ये होता है मीन
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट। उसके बाद आता है मीन
टाइम टू एकनॉलेज। द एवरेज टाइम इट टेक्स
फ्रॉम व्हेन एन अलर्ट फायर्स
टू व्हेन एन एनालिस्ट असाइन इट टू
देमसेल्व्स एंड स्टार्ट्स लुकिंग एट इट।
मतलब कि
अलर्ट आने में जो समय लगा एमटीटी डी हो
गया। अब जब अलर्ट आया और अलर्ट आने के बाद
एल जो एसओसी एल1 है उसने खुद को असाइन
किया। ठीक है? क्या किसी को भी असाइन किया
किसी एल1 को और उस पर इन्वेस्टिगेशन चालू
किया। ठीक है? तो अलर्ट से लेके
और उस इन्वेस्टिगेशन वाली फज़ के बीच की जो
टाइम होती है उसको हम एमटीटीए बोलते हैं।
मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज। जहां पे उसको
एकनॉलेज किया जा रहा है कि हां भैया ये
अलर्ट आया। मैं इस इन्वेस्टिगेशन स्टार्ट
कर रहा हूं। व्हाई इट्स मैटर? हाई एमटीटीए
मींस यू हैव टू मेनी अलर्ट्स। अलर्ट फैटी
उसको बोलते हैं और नॉट इनफ स्टाफ। अब बहुत
ज्यादा हाई एमटीटीए दिख रहा है। मतलब बहुत
सारे मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेजमेंट बहुत ज्यादा
है। तो इसका मतलब है या तो आपको बहुत
ज्यादा अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं। तो आपको वो
एकनॉलेज करने में आपको अलर्ट को एकनॉलेज
करके उसको इन्वेस्टिगेट करना यह टाइम लग
रहा है। या तो बहुत ज्यादा स्टाफ नहीं है।
जितनी होनी चाहिए। जितने अलर्ट्स आ रहे
हैं उसके अकॉर्डिंग आपके पास एसओसी एल1
एनालिस्ट की कमी है। जिसकी वजह से आपको और
ज्यादा एसओसी एल1 हायरिंग करनी पड़ेगी। यह
होता है और उसके बाद होता है एमटीटी आर
मीन टाइम टू रिसोंड। यह लास्ट सबसे एंड
लास्ट वाला चीज है। द एवरेज टाइम इट टेक्स
टू क्लोज एन इंसिडेंट न्यूट्रलाइज द
थ्रेट। यह एक टाइम लग रहा है या उसको
क्लोज करने में उसको टाइम लग रहा है। वह
टाइम होता है। वाइट मैटर्स। दिस इज़ द
मोस्ट क्रिटिकल मैट्रिक्स फॉर द बिज़नेस। द
लगर फॉर अ हैकर। द लगर ए हैकर इज़ इन द
सिस्टम जिसको बोलते हैं डीवेल टाइम। द मोर
डैमेज दे डू जितने टाइम तक हैकर आपके
सिस्टम में नेटवर्क में रहेगा उतना ज्यादा
डैमेज वो करेगा तो जितने टाइम तक कितने
टाइम तक एक हैकर आपके नेटवर्क में बैठा
हुआ है उसको हम डी वेल टाइम बोलते हैं डी
वेल टाइम इसको भी हम जानेंगे थोड़ी देर
बाद अब ये तो आपने देखा एसओसी मैट्रिक्स
में कोर ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स में एमटीटी डी
एमटीटीए और एमटीटीआर अब इसको मैं ट्राईकमी
के थ्रू थोड़ा समझाऊंगा आपको मजा आएगा
काफी इंट्रोडक्शन में चल के चेक कर लेते
हैं इसमें कुछ भी नहीं है
कोर मैट्रिक्स में आते हैं। कोर मैट्रिक्स
में यहां पे अब
कोर मैट्रिक्स में यहां पे दो तीन चीजें
अलर्ट काउंस, फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेस, अलर्ट
एस्कलेशन रेट, थ्रेड डिटेक्शन रेट ये सारी
चीजें हैं। दैट्स वी विल बी गोइंग थ्रू।
और यहां पे हम
अब आते हैं
एक और एक और चीज पढ़ लेते हैं। फिर हम
ट्राईटमी पे आएंगे तो ज्यादा कनेक्ट कर
पाएंगे। ज्यादा अच्छे से हम उसको समझ
पाएंगे। अब ये तो आपने देखा कोर ऑपरेशनल
मैट्रिक्स को देखा। अब हम आते हैं यहां पे
एफिशिएंसी एंड क्वालिटी मैट्रिक्स। इसको
भी थोड़ा समझ लेते हैं। देन हम वी विल बी
कमिंग टू द ट्राईक में।
ठीक है? एफिशिएंसी एंड क्वालिटी
मैट्रिक्स। इस पे आते हैं। क्या है? दिस
मैट्रिक्स हेल्प यू अंडरस्टैंड इफ योर
टूल्स एंड प्रोसेससेस आर एक्चुअली
वर्किंग। आपके टूल्स और प्रोसेससेस
एक्चुअली काम कर रहे हैं। यह मैट्रिक्स
उसी के बारे में बताते हैं। तो इसमें अब
आते हैं तीन तरह के। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट,
ट्रू पॉजिटिव रेट, अलर्ट वॉल्यूम वर्सेस
इंसिडेंट वॉल्यूम। तो, फॉल्स पॉजिटिव का
मतलब आपको यह सब चीजें पता है। द परसेंटेज
ऑफ़ अलर्ट दैट टर्न आउट टू बी नॉइज़। मतलब
यह एक नॉइज़ था। फालतू चीजें थी, यह
अलर्ट्स जो थी, वैसी ही थी, बेकार थी। ठीक
है? गोल कीप इट लो। इफ 90% ऑफ़ अलर्ट्स आर
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स, योर एनालिस्ट विल स्टॉप
पेइंग अटेंशन।
मतलब कि अगर आपके
90% अलर्ट्स फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स हैं, तो आपका
जो एनालिस्ट है वो आपको अटेंशन देना ही
बंद कर देगा। आपका जो सीनियर है वो
सोचेगा, अरे यार, यह तो फालतू के सिर्फ
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स दे रहा है यह। तो, यह
थोड़ी सी दिक्कत है। ठीक है? ट्रू पॉजिटिव
रेट। द परसेंटेज ऑफ़ अलर्ट दैट वेयर
एक्चुअली सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंट्स। दिस
वैलिडेट्स दैट योर डिटेक्शन रूल्स आर
ट्यून करेक्टली। यह आपको बताता है कि
एक्चुअल जो इंसिडेंट्स हो रहे हैं जो
एक्चुअल सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंट्स ही हैं।
आपको आपने सही से वो चीजें रिपोर्ट करी
है। तो यह आपकी एक
मैट्रिक्स आपकी जो है ना वो बताता है कि
यस यू आर अ परफेक्ट कैंडिडेट। यू आर डूइंग
योर जॉब गुड। आपका एक अच्छा वहां पर ट्रू
पॉजिटिव रेट बना हुआ है। तो यू आर डूइंग
योर वर्क इन अ गुड वे। यह आप एकदम बढ़िया
से काम कर रहे हैं। अलर्ट वॉल्यूम वर्सेस
इंसिडेंट वॉल्यूम शोज़ द रेशियो ऑफ़ रॉ
पिंग्स टू एक्चुअल प्रॉब्लम्स। इफ यू हैव
10,000 अलर्ट्स बट ओनली टू इंसिडेंट्स,
योर एसआईएम नीड्स बेटर फ़्टरिंग। मतलब यह
बताता है रेशियो बताता है किससे? रॉ
पिंग्स से एक्चुअल प्रॉब्लम्स से। मतलब जो
रॉ पिंग्स जो एक्चुअल आपको अलर्ट्स आ रहे
हैं जो पिंगिंग आ रही है और एक्चुअल
प्रॉब्लम क्या है उसका दोनों का रेश्यो है
मतलब अगर आपके पास 10,000 अलर्ट्स आ रहे
हैं और उसमें से दो ही सिर्फ ट्रू पॉजिटिव
अलर्ट है तो इसका मतलब है आपके एसआईएम में
जो फिल्टरिंग लगी है जो एक रूल्स बने हैं
जैसे हर तरह का फायर वाल या एसआईएम रूल पे
बात रूल पे काम करता है एक और सारे रूल्स
सेटअप होते हैं कि यह कंडीशन होगी तो ऐसा
होगा यह चीज होगी तो वैसा हुआ तो यानी
एसआईएम आपका फाइन ट्यूड नहीं है। एसआईएम
का रूल जो है वो सही से फाइन ट्यूड नहीं
है। तो एसओसी इंजीनियर्स के पास जाना
पड़ेगा। एसओसी इंजीनियर्स जो हैं यानी कि
एसओसी जो इंजीनियर्स हैं आपके सीनियर जो
हैं वो उसको फाइन ट्यून करेंगे और उसको
सही करेंगे कि भैया सही कर दो। ये चीजें
होती हैं एफिशिएंसी एंड क्वालिटी
मैट्रिक्स में। उसके बाद है स्ट्रेटेजिक
एंड रिस्क मैट्रिक्स। इस पे भी हम आएंगे
बट इसके पहले चलो इसको भी हम समझ ही लेते
हैं। देन हम ट्राईमी पे आ जाएंगे
डायरेक्ट। तो ये हमने देखा पहले देखा हमने
क्या ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स देन हमने देखा
एफिशिएंसी एंड क्वालिटी मैट्रिक्स जिसमें
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव ट्रू पॉजिटिव ये सब है और
उसके बाद है स्ट्रेटेजिक एंड रिस्क
मैट्रिक्स ये लास्ट ये एक फंडा है दीज़ आर
द मैट्रिक्स यू शो टू द सी सूट सी सूट का
मतलब है जो
हेड ऑफ द मैनेजमेंट
पोजीशंस हैं मैनेजमेंट जो हेड पोजीशंस है
उनको आप दिखाते हो सी सूट का मतलब है सी
वाले वाले जितने भी पोजीशंस हैं सी में
हमेशा टॉप वाले आते हैं। जैसे सीईओ हो
गया, सीआईएसओ हो गया, सीटीओ हो गया, सीएफओ
हो गया। राइट? सीएमओ तो मार्केटिंग का हो
गया। राइट? तो यह सी वाले होते हैं। टू
जस्टिफाई एसओसी बजट। इनको आप इसलिए यह
बताते हो मैट्रिक्स दिखाते हो कि एसओसी का
बजट इन्हीं का हाथ में कि भैया कितना
रुपया खर्च करेंगे यह पूरे एसओसी वाली चीज
पे। हाउ हाउ मच मनी दे आर गोइंग टू
स्पेंड। यह इसी मैट्रिक्स के आधार पर
होगी। तो उसमें आता है सबसे पहले डीएल
टाइम। द टाइम बिटवीन द इनिशियल इनफेक्शन
एंड व्हेन द एसओसी फाइनली डिटेक्ट्स इट।
मतलब कि एक हैकर भैया कितने टाइम तक आपके
नेटवर्क में है? यह वही डीएल टाइम है।
डीएल टाइम इक्वल टू डिटेक्शन टाइम माइनस
इनफेक्शन टाइम। मतलब कि
डिटेक्ट कब हुआ था? और इनफेक्ट टाइम कब
हुआ था? यानी कि जैसे कि अगर आज सुबह
ठीक है? आज सुबह 8:00 बजे कोई सिस्टम या
कोई नेटवर्क को इनफेक्ट किया गया था टाइगर
के द्वारा। ठीक है? 8:00 बजे और उसको
डिटेक्ट किया गया दो 12:00 बजे मान लो
12:00 बजे। सुबह 8:00 बजे हुआ। दिन में
12:00 बजे डिटेक्ट किया गया। तो इसका
ड्यूल टाइम क्या होगा? 12 - 8 ठीक है? तो
चार यानी 4 आवर्स का डीएल टाइम ये हो गया।
इसका मतलब यही होता है। ये ड्यूल टाइम है।
उसके बाद आता है कवरेज मैपिंग। मैत्रे
अटैक की बात यहां पर कर रहे हैं। अ
परसेंटेज शोइंग हाउ मच ऑफ द अटैकर प्लेबुक
अ परसेंटेज शोइंग हाउ मच ऑफ द अटैकर
प्लेबुक यू कैन एक्चुअली सी एग्जांपल वी
हैव 80% कवरेज ऑफ रैंसवेयर टेक्निक्स। तो
यह बताता है बेसिकली कि एक परसेंटेज शो
करता है कि हाउ मच ऑफ द अटैकर प्लेबुक यू
कैन एक्चुअली सी अटैकर प्लेबुक मतलब कि
एग्जैक्टली अटैकर का कितना आप कितना अटैकर
को आप कितना देख पा रहे हैं? कितना समझ पा
रहे हैं। एक अटैकर सामने अलग-अलग तरह के
अटैक्स कर रहा है। आप उसको कितने परसेंट
तक समझ पा रहे हैं। कितने परसेंट तक आप
उसको डिटेक्ट कर पा रहे हैं। तो ये 80%
जैसे कि एग्जांपल में हमारे पास 80% कवरेज
है रैंसमवेयर टेक्निक्स का। मैंने जो भी
रैंसम टेक्निक्स दुनिया में यूज़ हो रहे
हैं, रैंसवेयर अटैक्स यूज़ हो रहे हैं अलग
तरीके से चाहे कुछ भी किसी भी तरीके का
80% अटैक्स को हम समझ पाएंगे। ये जितना
ज्यादा हो उतना अच्छा है।
और लास्ट में आती है एसएलए सर्विस लेवल
एग्रीमेंट कंप्लायंस। सर्विस लेवल
एग्रीमेंट। ये क्या होता है? द परसेंटेज
ऑफ़ क्रिटिकल इंसिडेंट्स हैंडल्ड विद इन द
प्रॉमिस टाइम फ्रेम। एग्जांपल 95% ऑफ़
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स एकनॉलेज्ड विद इन 15
मिनट्स। मतलब जितने भी क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स
हैं वो एक प्रॉमिस्ड
टाइम फ्रेम में उसको हैंडल कर लिया गया।
यह एसएलए
को डिस्क्राइब करता है यानी सर्विस लेवल
एग्रीमेंट को कि भैया हां अगर आप मतलब
किसी पर्टिकुलर अलर्ट को आप जैसे 95% ऑफ
क्रिटिकल एरर्स को आपने 15 मिनट में
एकनॉलेज किया है तो इट्स अ गुड एसएलए रेट।
इसको हम एक अच्छा रेट बता सकते हैं एसएलए
का सर्विस लेवल एग्रीमेंट का। सो यह होता
है एसएलए। तो यह स्ट्रेटेजिक एंड रिस्क
मैट्रिक्स में आपके आते हैं। आई होप कि
आपको ये चीजें क्लियर ये थ्योरी वाले
पार्ट क्लियर हो गए। अब हम चलेंगे
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन एंड हैंड्स ऑन के ऊपर में
लैब के ऊपर में। तो मुझे एक बार जितने भी
लोग यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं प्लीज एक बार
बता दीजिए। हम आगे की तरफ ये तो वो है तो
इसको हम ये जो मतलब उसका हुआ है मैट्रिक्स
के बारे में और भी चीजें हैं वो हम बात कर
लेंगे बाद में। बट फिलहाल के लिए ये मुझे
बताइए कि ये जो चीजें आपको समझ में आई
ऑपरेशनल मैट्रिक्स, एफिशिएंसी एंड
क्वालिटी मैट्रिक्स, स्ट्रेटेजिक एंड
रिस्क मैट्रिक्स ये चीजें आपको क्लियर हुई
या नहीं हुई है। सो प्लीज लेट मी नो।
हम चलते हैं ट्राई पे।
आज बहुत लोग चले गए हैं लीव करके कुछ
लोगों के ऊपर से जा रही होगी आई आई आई कैन
आई कैन फील दैट बट लीव करना इज़ नॉट अ
सॉलशन फर्स्ट ऑफ़ ऑल सबसे पहले लीव करना
सॉल्यूशन नहीं होता है यह बात हमेशा याद
रखिएगा आप लोग
लीव वही वही करते हैं जो हार मान जाते
हैं। जो छोड़ के चले जाए वो हार मान जाते
हैं। वही छोड़ के जाते हैं। इट्स नॉट एन
सशन। यू शुड बी ऑलवेज अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस।
ठीक है? आप अभी देखो फिर रिकॉर्डिंग देखो
दो बार हो जाएगी। बट छोड़ दोगे फिर कैसे
होगा? चलो अब आते हैं कोरड मैट्रिक्स पे।
ट्रैक मी पे कोड मैट्रिक्स पे। अब यहां पे
देखो यहां पे
यहां पे कुछ मैट्रिक्स हैं। अलर्ट
काउंट्स, फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट, अलर्ट
एस्केलेशन रेट, थ्रेट डिटेक्शन रेट। ये
कुछ मैट्रिक्स होते हैं। ठीक है?
एसओसी का रोल होता है प्रोटेक्ट करना,
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी, इंटीग्रिटी और
अवेलेबिलिटी। सीआईए को प्रोटेक्ट करना। यह
वन ऑफ़ द मेजर रोल होता है एसओसी का। ठीक
है? द एल1 एनालिस्ट रोल इन दिस प्रोसेस इज़
टू रिलायबली रिपोर्ट ट्रू पॉजिटिव्स टू द
हायर लेवल टू L2. L2 को
एक रिलायबल रिपोर्ट प्रोवाइड करना, ट्रू
पॉजिटिव्स को एस्केलेट करना। ये मेन रोल
है एसोसिएल वंस का। इसमें अलग-अलग
मैट्रिक्स यूज़ होते हैं। ठीक है? अब इसमें
अलग-अलग मैट्रिक्स में जैसे एक मैट्रिक है
अलर्ट्स काउंट का। देयर इज़ अ मैट्रिक नोन
एज अलर्ट्स काउंट। एक है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट। अलर्ट्स काउंट को एसी बोलते हैं।
एफपीआर बोलते हैं। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट को
अलर्ट एक्सक्ललेशन रेट को एईआर बोलते हैं।
शॉर्ट फॉर्म है। थ्रेट्स डिटेक्शन रेट को
टीडीआर बोलते हैं। एसी अलर्ट काउंट्स का
मतलब है टोटल काउंट्स ऑफ़ अलर्ट रिसीव।
टोटल अलर्ट जो रिसीव हुए हैं। ओवरऑल लोड
ऑफ़ एसोसिए एनालिस्ट। यह मेजर करता है
एसओसी एनालिस्ट के ऊपर कितना लोड है।
कितने अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं? कि लोड को मैंने
यह ओवरऑल दिखाता है। एफपीआर फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट क्या दिखाता है?
लेवल ऑफ नॉइज़ इन द अलर्ट्स। नॉइज़ कितने
अलर्ट्स में? नॉइज़ मतलब फालतू के कितने
फाल्स पॉजिटिव्स या कितने कितने हैं? मतलब
बेकार के चीजें बेकार के अलर्ट्स जो काम
के नहीं है वो कितने हैं वो बताता है।
एस्कलेशन अलर्ट अलर्ट एस्केलेशन रेट एईआर
यह बताता है एक्सपीरियंस ऑफ़ एल1 एनालिस्ट।
क्या एक्सपीरियंस है L1 एनालिस्ट का? मतलब
अगर एस्केलेशन रेट अच्छा है वो एक ट्रू
पॉजिटिव्स को अच्छे से एस्केलेट कर रहा
है। मतलब एक एक्सपीरियंस्ड एल1 एनालिस्ट
है। ये L2 एनालिस्ट बन सकता है। इसकी
प्रमोशन हो सकती है। ये बताता है। थ्रेट
डिटेक्शन रेट रिलायबिलिटी ऑफ़ द एसोसिएट
एसोसिएटी मतलब थ्रेट को डिटेक्ट करने का
क्या रेट है कि एक्चुअल में कितने थ्रेट्स
को कितने अलर्ट्स में से मैक्सिमम कितने
थ्रेट्स को डिटेक्ट किया जा रहा है? ये
रिलायबिलिटी बताता है। एसोसिएट टीम कितनी
रिलायबल है ये बताता है। ठीक है? ये सारी
चीजें होती है। तो अब ये सारी चीजें हम
देखेंगे। इसके इसके अभी वी विल बी
अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस। जस्ट गिव मी टू
मिनट्स।
ओके ओके अभी आवाज जा रही है सॉरी सॉरी
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी लेट मी नो नाउ द ऑडियो
इज गोइंग ओके
माइक्रोफोन ऑफ था आई थिंक इस वजह से ऑडियो
नहीं जा रही होगी अभी माइक्रोफोन ऑन कर
दिया मैंने सो नाउ द ऑडियो इज क्लियर
ठीक है। ठीक है। फाइन।
ओके। ग्रेट पढ़ या
चलिए। तो अलर्ट काउंट की बात कर रहे हैं।
तो फाइव टू 10 अलर्ट्स पर डे पर एल1
एनालिस्ट इज अ गुड मैट्रिक्स। अगर मतलब
देखो वैसे तो ये कंपनी साइज के ऊपर डिपेंड
करती है। कंपनी अगर बहुत बड़ी है तो
अलर्ट्स थोड़े ज्यादा होंगे। ज्यादा बड़ा
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है तो अलर्ट ज्यादा होगा।
बट अगर यूजुअली एक मीडियम साइज कंपनी की
हम बात करें तो 5 से 30 अलर्ट पर डे पर
एल1 गुड मैट्रिक है। अच्छा मैट्रिक है।
ठीक है?
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट्स
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट्स ट्राईक के प्रीमियम
अकाउंट के वाउचर के लिए क्या करें? ट्राईक
पे जाओ खरीद लो। ₹500 पर मंथ पे मिल रहे
हैं। अगर तुम ₹500 पर मंथ भी इन्वेस्ट
करने को रेडी नहीं है आप लोग तो फिर मैं
इसमें क्या बोलूं बताओ? ₹500 जस्ट 500 में
प्रीमियम सारी चीज आपको मिल जा रही है।
पूरे महीने बैठ के प्रैक्टिस करो भाई।
इससे ज्यादा अच्छा अपॉर्चुनिटी क्या हो
सकता है? गो एंड गेट गेट इट। राइट? फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव रेट में देखो। इफ 75 आउट ऑफ 80
अलर्ट्स वेयर कंफर्म टू बी फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स लाइक सिस्टम नॉइज़ और टिपिकल
आईटी एक्टिविटी। दैट्स अ बैड सिग्नल फॉर
योर टीम। यह अच्छा नहीं है कि 80 अलर्ट्स
में से 75 जो है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव हो। दिस इज़
नॉट गुड। ठीक है? पॉजिटिव रेट ऑफ़ 0% इज़
अनअचीवेबल। अब देखो 0% का फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट अचीव करना भी पॉसिबल नहीं है। बट 80%
और हायर इज़ अ सीरियस प्रॉब्लम। 80% फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव हो या उससे ऊपर का अगर फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव रेट है तो यह गड़बड़ चीज है। दिस इज़
वेरी गड़बड़ चीज। यह नहीं होना चाहिए।
एस्केले अलर्ट एस्केलेशन रेट। देखो इट इज़
यूजुअली एम टू बी बिलो 50% और इवन बेटर
बिलो 20%। अलर्ट एस्केलेशन रेट जो है यह
50% से कम या 20% से अगर कम है तो यह
ज्यादा बेटर है। अब क्या है? L2
एनालिस्ट्स रिलाई ऑन L1 एनालिस्ट टू
फिल्टर आउट द नॉइज़ एंड एस्केलेट्स ओनली द
एक्शननेबल थ्रेटनिंग अलर्ट्स। तो L2
एनालिस्ट इस बात पर ही वह भरोसे पर टिके
रहते हैं कि L1 जो है वह फालतू के फॉल्स
नेगेटिव्स को हटाएगा और सिर्फ जो ट्रू
पॉजिटिव और जेन्युइन अलर्ट्स है जिनको
लगता है कि यस यह एक मशियस अटैक है या यह
एक एक्चुअल इंसिडेंट एक सिक्योरिटी
इंसिडेंट है उसी को रिपोर्ट करेगा उसी को
एस्केलेट करेगा
तो ये जो चीज है
कम होनी चाहिए अलर्ट एस्केलेशन रेट मतलब
कम से कम मतलब ऐसा नहीं कि सब के सब अलर्ट
वो एस्केलेशन एस्केलेट कर दो अलर्ट्स को
सब के सबको एस्केलेट करते रहो अब एल वन है
तो एल2 को करते रहो फिर आपकी जॉब खतरे में
आ जाएगी तो इसका रेशियो कम होना चाहिए 50%
और उससे कम या 20% से भी कम हो तो बेटर
रहेगा थ्रेट डिटेक्शन रेट क्या है देखो द
थ्रेट डिटेक्शन रेट शुड ऑलवेज बी 100%
डिटेक्ट तो हमेशा होना चाहिए सिंस एव्री
मिस थ्रेट कैन बी अ डिवास्टेटिंग
क्सक्वेंसेस सच एज रसमवेयर इंफेक्शन एंड
डेटा एक्सट्रेशन तो थ्रेट डिटेक्शन रेट
100% होना चाहिए क्योंकि अगर वह थ्रेट
डिटेक्ट ही नहीं हुआ कोई फिर तो नेटवर्क
में घुस के तबाही करेगा ना तबाही मचाएगा
राइट ये थोड़ी सी आपको ध्यान देनी है सो
इज जीरो अलॉट फॉर वन मंथ अ गुड साइन फॉर
योर एसओसी टीम इसका आंसर दीजिए इज जीरो
अलॉट फॉर वन मंथ इज अ गुड टाइम गुड साइन
फॉर योर एसोसिएट टीम मतलब एक महीने में
कोई भी अलर्ट नहीं आई क्या यह गुड साइन है
या नहीं लेट मी नो
इज इट गुड गुड साइन और नो
महीने में एक भी अलर्ट नहीं आई। पूरे
महीने भर कोई अलर्ट नहीं आई।
आंसर
नो बिल्कुल सही बात है। इट्स आंसर इज़ ने
नो ऐसा नहीं है। ये अगर एक महीने तक आपके
अलर्ट ही नहीं आ रही है। मतलब आपके एसआईएम
टूल में कोई ना कोई गड़बड़ी है। कोई ना
कोई प्रॉब्लम है। इसके डिटेक्शन रूल में
किसी तरह का प्रॉब्लम है या डिटेक्शन रूल
जो है जिससे कि एसआईएम आपके डिटेक्ट करता
है अलर्ट्स को। उसमें फाइन ट्यूनिंग की
जरूरत है। उसको ट्यून करने की जरूरत है।
उसको अच्छा करने की जरूरत है। उसमें और
मस्त उसे मस्त बनाने की जरूरत है। व्हाट
इज द फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट? इफ ओनली 10 आउट
ऑफ 50 अलर्ट्स अपीयर टू बी रियल थ्रेट्स?
बताइए व्हाट इज द फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट? इफ
ओनली 10 आउट ऑफ 50 अलर्ट्स अपीयर टू बी
रियल थ्रेट्स। अगर 10 में से 50 में से 10
जो है वह रियल थ्रेट है तो इसका रेट क्या
रहेगा? तो सिंपल सा इसको डिवाइड करना है
और क्या करना है?
तो क्या होगा? इसका रेट क्या होगा? बताइए
मुझे।
क्या करना होगा? 10 आउट ऑफ 50
20 इट्स 20 तो हम यहां पे 20 परसेंट लिख
देते हैं। ऐसे गलत है आ रहा है। इट्स इट्स
रॉन्ग कमिंग इट्स रॉन्ग कमिंग बताओ। इट्स
रॉन्ग वाई
ये आ रहा है। आंसर इज़ इनकरेक्ट।
2% टू तो होगा ही नहीं भाई। टू तो नहीं
होगा। व्हाट इज द फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट? अरे
भैया फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट बतानी है। समझो
थोड़ा दिमाग लगाओ यार। इफ ओनली 10 आउट ऑफ
50 अलर्ट्स अपीयरर्स टू बी रियल थ्रेट्स।
50 में से 10 रियल थ्रेट हैं। 40 जो है ना
40 वो हैं फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स। 50 में से 40
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स हैं। तो यहां पर
डिवाइड करोगे 80% आएगा ना। 4000 को 50 से
डिवाइड करोगे ना 4000 को 50 से तो 80%
निकल के आएगा भाई। कहां से 40% हुआ? अरे
सिंपल सा फंडा है यार। क्या तुम मतलब
मैथ्स में कमजोर हो तुम लोगों लगता है
मुझे।
अरे यार ये क्या है?
मैथ्स में इतना कमजोर कैसे हो भाई? कैसे
काम चलेगा?
देखो
आउट ऑफ 50
10 आर रियल। तो फेक कितने हैं? 40 है तो
40 आर फॉल्स
तो भैया अगर
अगर
50 में
40 फॉल्स है
रेट आपको रेट आपको रेट निकालना है ना 50
में 40 फॉल्स है तो अगर वन
की बात करें तो क्या होगा यह? 40
बाय 50 यही तो होगा। सॉरी 40 50 यही तो
होगा। और रेट की जब हम बात करते हैं तो
100 की हम बात करते हैं तो क्या होगा? 40
/ 50 एंड इसके बाद इंटू 100 कर देंगे तो
क्या हो जाएगा? ऊपर का क्या हो जाएगा?
4000 क्योंकि 40 * 100 4000 हो जाएगी और
यह डिवाइडेड बाय 50 हो जाएगी। तो रेट निकल
के 80 आ जाएगी। सिंपल।
अरे भाई अभी भी नहीं समझे। हां बिल्कुल
रिक्वेद पॉल बिल्कुल सही। 40/ 50 * 100 80
होगा। 10 / 10 * 100/ 50 नहीं होगा। गलत
है ये आपका ये होगा। ये मैंने ये जो समझा
आपको समझ में आ गया? यहां पर क्वेश्चन
देखो क्या पूछ रहा है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट
पूछ रहा है और 10 जो है वह रियल थ्रेट
हैं। तो फॉल्स पॉजिटिव 40 हो गए हैं। उसका
रेट पूछ रहा है। तो 50 में 40 जो है फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है। यानी 80% फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट
हो गया। दैट्स इट। तो यहां पे आंसर वुड बी
80%।
करेक्ट। राइट? दैट्स इट। खत्म। मजा आ गया?
हां। ट्रू पॉजिटिव पहले बहुत लोगों ने
बोला है। 10 का जो 20% बोल रहे थे ना वो
ट्रू पॉजिटिव रेट था। जो 20% था वो ट्रू
पॉजिटिव रेट था।
ठीक है? अब आते हैं ट्रैग मैट्रिक्स पे।
नाउ वी आर कमिंग टू ट्रैग मैट्रिक्स। अब
देखो ट्रैग मैट्रिक्स में वही चीज़ें हैं
जो मैंने आपको बताया एमटीटी मीन टाइम टु
डिटेक्ट एमटीटीए मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज
एमटीटीआर मीन टाइम टू रिस्पॉन्ड या रेडिएट
ये मैंने आपको बताया ठीक है अब देखो यहां
पे ये किस तरीके से काम करता है वी विल सी
दैट राइट अब
इस इस पर्टिकुलर डायग्राम के थ्रू भी हम
समझेंगे देखो ये एसएलए के बारे में मैंने
होता है सर्विस लेबर एग्रीमेंट। इसके बारे
में मैंने आपको बता बता दिया ऑलरेडी क्या
होता है। अब इस डायग्राम में देखो सम
मलेशियस इवेंट्स अकर। कोई मलेशियस इवेंट
अकर होता है। एसओसी रिसीव्स एसआईएम और
इडीआर अलर्ट। उसके बाद एसओसी को
क्या मिलता है? एसआईएम इडीआर अलर्ट मिलता
है। ठीक है? ओके। एल1 एनालिस्ट स्टार्ट्स
द अलर्ट। ट्रैक। एनुअल एनालिस्ट जो है
ट्रैक अलर्ट स्टार्ट करता है। एस्केलेशन
एंड अदर वर्क फ्लो। एस्केलेशंस होती हैं।
वर्क फ्लो दूसरा वर्क फ्लो जो होता है
इंटरनल वह सारी चीजें होती हैं और लास्ट
में यह मिटिगेट कर दिया जाता है। लास्ट
में इसको सही कर दिया जाता है। मतलब
काउंटर मेजर इसको इसको रॉल्व कर दिया जाता
है। तो अब जब मलेशियस इवेंट ऑकर हुई थी।
वहां से लेकर एसओसी अलर्ट तक का मान लो 5
मिनट का समय लगा। एसओसी अलर्ट होने में।
एक इवेंट ओकर हुई। बट एसओसी अलर्ट जो है
एडीआर या एसआईएम के तरफ से आया 5 मिनट के
बाद तो वह जो 5 मिनट था वह है एमटीटीडी
क्योंकि मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट तब ये
डिटेक्ट हुआ 5 मिनट के बाद डिटेक्ट हुआ तो
5 मिनट हो गया एमटीटीडी
गुड अब अलर्ट रिसीव हो चुका है। अब इस
अलर्ट पे एनालिस्ट जो है ना इन्वेस्टिगेट
काम करना शुरू कर चुका है। इसको ट्राई
किया इसने कि भैया ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव है
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव। उसमें मान लो 5 मिनट लगा।
इसको हम बोलते हैं एमटीटीए। वह 5 मिनट
कहलाएगा मीन टाइम टू अटैक। मतलब अटैक करने
में जो टाइम लगा मीन टाइम टू सॉरी अटैक
नहीं है सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी मीन टाइम
टू एकनॉलेज मतलब उस चीज को एकनॉलेज करने
में कि भैया हां ये एक अब इसको ट्रैक करना
है। ये ट्रू पॉजिटिव फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है।
हां भैया ये कोई अलर्ट है। 5 मिनट लगा तो
वो हो गया मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज।
अब जब ये ट्रैक हो चुकी है तो अब इसके बाद
एस्केलेशंस या अदर प्रोसेससेस जो भी हैं
अगर यह ट्रू पॉजिटिव है तो एस्केलेट होगा।
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है तो उस पर रिपोर्ट बन के
बंद होगा। खत्म होगा। यह इंटरनल
प्रोसेससेस मान लो 20 मिनट चल रहे हैं। 20
मिनट तक ये अब सारे प्रोसेस मान लो चले।
तो अब एमटीटीआर कितना होगा? ये जो एमटीटीए
का टाइम था और जो इंटरनल प्रोसेससेस के
टाइम हुए वो दोनों मिला के एमटीटीआर का
टाइम होता है। यानी मीन टाइम टू रिस्पोंड
या मीन टाइम टू रिॉल्व या मीन टाइम टू
रेमीडिएट। यह होता है एमटीटीआर। यानी कि
एमटीटीए
प्लस इंटरनल प्रोसेस टाइमिंग इज नोन एज
एमटीटीआर। उसको हम बोलते हैं मीन टाइम टू
रिसोंड। ये दोनों मिलके या ये डायग्राम
याद रखिएगा। तो पहला एमटीीडी 5 मिनट दूसरा
एमटीटीए 5 मिनट जो समय लगा और एमटीटीआर
एमटीटीए प्लस इंटरनल प्रोसेस टाइम। दिस इज़
कॉल्ड एमटीटीआर। यह क्लियर हो गया सबका?
यह डायग्राम क्लियर हुआ? ये तीनों समझ में
आ गई? कितना टाइम कैसे मैनेज हो रहा है
यहां पे?
एवरीवन प्लीज टेल मी।
प्लीज टेल मी गाइस लेट मी नो गाइस एवरीवन
प्लीज
क्योंकि इसका भी यूज़ होने वाला है इसलिए
ओके। सो अब हम इसी को यूज़ करके आंसर्स
करेंगे। क्वेश्चन आंसर करेंगे। अब देखो
रेफरेंस टेबल के तौर पर यहां पर देखो
एसओसी टीम में अवेलेबिलिटी 24 * 7 होता
है। यह एसएलए होता है। सर्विस लेवल
एग्रीमेंट 24 * 7 अवेलेबिलिटी होती है।
वर्किंग शेड्यूल होता है एसओसी का जनरली
शिफ्ट में होता है। 8/5 शिफ्ट हो गया। 8
मॉर्निंग फ्रॉम 8 am टू 5 pm और 24 * 7
मोड होता है 24 घंटे वाली। मीन टाइम टू
डिटेक्ट 5 मिनट है। मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज
10 मिनट हो गया। मीन टाइम टू रिसोंड मान
लो 60 मिनट हो गया। कुछ भी व्हाटएवर। ठीक
है? अब यहां पे इमेजिन सिनेरियो वेयर द
एसओसी टीम रिसीव्स अ क्रिटिकल अलर्ट ऑन
संडे। क्रिटिकल अलर्ट मिलता है संडे को।
इफ द टीम वर्क्स 8/5 यानी सुबह 8 से 5 ऑन
वि डे ऑफ द वीक विल दे एकनॉलेज द अलर्ट।
अब देखो सैटरडे को अलर्ट रिसीव हुआ है।
सैटरडे को अलर्ट रिसीव हुआ है। ठीक है?
8/5 यह काम कर रहे हैं। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात
है संडे इज द
लाइक नॉन वर्किंग डे या सैटरडे भी नॉन
वर्किंग डे होता है। जनरली मंडे टू
फ्राइडे काम होता है। तो मंडे को करेंगे
ये सिंपल सा बात है। तो यहां मंडे मंडे को
होगा जो भी होगा। सिंपल। ठीक है? अब यहां
पे आ जाते हैं। इमेजिन अ सिनेरियो वेयर एन
एंप्लई वाज़ लर्ड इंटू रनिंग डाटा स्टील
मैलवेयर। एंप्लई को चकमा दे दिया गया।
एंप्लई को फंसाया गया डाटा स्टील मैलवेयर
चलाने के लिए। अब इसको समझिए। ठीक है?
द एसओसी
माइंड गॉन हैंग। कोई बात नहीं थोड़ी सी
बची है। बस अब ये लास्ट ही है। लास्ट ही
है। तो बस देख लो।
द एसओसी टीम रिसीव्स द कनेक्शन टू रेड
लाइन स्टिलर सी टू अलर्ट आफ्टर 12 मिनट्स।
12 मिनट्स के बाद एसओसी टीम को क्या होता
है? कनेक्शन टू डेडलाइन स्टिलर का जो है
मैसेज आता है। वन ऑफ द एल1 एनालिस्ट ऑन
शिफ्ट मूव्ड टू द मूव्ड द अलर्ट टू इन
प्रोग्रेस 10 मिनट्स लेटर। 10 मिनट के बाद
इसको प्रोग्रेस में डाला जाता है। आफ्टर 6
मिनट्स द अलर्ट वाज़ एस्केलेटेड टू एल2 हु
स्पेंड 35 मिनट्स क्लीनिंग द मैलवेयर। 35
मिनट 6 मिनट के बाद अलर्ट को एल2 को
एस्केलेट किया जाता है और 35 मिनट में
इसको क्लियर किया जाता है। इसको रेमडीएट
किया जाता है। तो अब बताइए आंसर प्रोवाइड
द एमटीटी एमटीटीए एंड एमटीटीआर वाया कॉमा
एज योर आंसर। तो अब मुझे बताइए आप लोग
इसमें एमटीटी मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट कितना
होगा? लेट मी नो।
एवरीवन प्लीज टेल मी। मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट
यहां पे कितना होगा? व्हाट विल बी द मीन
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट?
सिनेरियो को पढ़िए एंड बताइए।
एसओसी को अलर्ट मिला 12 मिनट के बाद।
एक एसओसी L1 ने उसको प्रोग्रेस में डाल
दिया। मतलब एकनॉलेज कर लिया कि हां भैया
ठीक है। उसमें लगे 10 मिनट।
और उसके 6 मिनट के बाद उसने L2 को
एस्केलेट किया जिसको 35 मिनट लगे इसको
रेमीडिएट करने में सही करने में तो एमटीटी
डी मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट पहला क्या होगा?
अरे पहला एमटीटी डी बताओ यार क्या बोल रहे
हो?
एमटीटी डी ये 12 होगा। बिलकुल चलो 12 अब
बताओ एमटीटी ए मीन टाइम टू एक्नॉलेज कितना
होगा? एमटीटीए
एमटीटीए कितना होगा बताइए सभी लोग एमटीटीए
बताइए ओनली मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज क्या होगा
10 ठीक है बिल्कुल सही 10 और एमटीटीआर मीन
टाइम टू रिस्पोंड क्या होगा यह मुझे बताइए
एमटीटीआर क्या होगा फिर देखते हैं फिर
क्या है
बताइए
एमटीटीआर इज़ 51 चलिए अच्छी बात है। 51
इसको चेक करते हैं। एंड इट्स करेक्ट।
कई लोगों को लग रहा होगा एमटीटीआर 51 कैसे
आया? मैं आपको पहले ही बता चुका था इसीलिए
कि MTTR = MTTA
प्लस जो भी उसको रिॉल्व करने में या
इंटरनल प्रोसेस में टाइम लग रहा है। यहां
पे आप देख सकते हो कि एमटीटीए प्लस इंटरनल
प्रोसेससेस या रिॉल्व करने में जो भी टाइम
लग रहा है। इंटरनल प्रोसेससेस में रिॉल्व
करना भी आया, मिटिगेट करना भी आया। इंटरनल
एस्केलेशन वर्क फ्लो सब आ जाता है। तो
एमटीटीए ऑलरेडी हमारे पास 10 है। उसके बाद
इसको 6 मिनट के बाद ये एस्केलेट कर रहा
है। वो भी इंटरनल प्रोसेस है। तो 6 मिनट
ये ऐड हो गया। 10 और छ 16 हो गए। और इसको
35 मिनट इसको रिॉल्व करने लग रहा है। तो
16 और 35 मिलके 51 हो जाते हैं। इसलिए
एमटीटीआर इज़ 51, एमटीटीए इज़ 10 और एमटीटी
12। दैट्स इट। आई होप कि यू अंडरस्टुड
समझ में आ गया
एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड सिंपल था राइट कोई इसमें टफ कोई
रॉकेट साइंस तो नहीं थी 10 मिनट और लगेंगे
आपके उसके बाद सेशन ओवर कर लेंगे
इंप्रूविंग मैट्रिक्स अब मैट्रिक्स को
इंप्रूव करने का क्या है ये सिंपल सा फंडा
है नाउ यू नो दैट अ लॉट ऑफ़ डिफरेंट
मैट्रिक्स अब इंप्रूव आपको करना है
मैट्रिक्स को अच्छा करना है अपने
परफॉर्मेंस को अच्छा करना है राइट ये करना
है तो क्या होना चाहिए? फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट
ओवर 80% 80% से ऊपर है तो इसका मतलब है
योर टीम रिसीव्स टू मच ऑफ नॉइज़ अलर्ट्स।
आपकी टीम को बहुत ज्यादा नॉइज़ मिल रहा है।
बहुत ज्यादा फॉल्स नेगेट फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट मिल रहा है। एक्सक्लूड ट्रस्टेड
एक्टिविटीज़ लाइक सिस्टम अपडेट्स फ्रॉम योर
ईडीआर और एसआईएम डिटेक्शन रूल। जो एसआईएम
की डिटेक्शन रूल है आईडीआर की उसमें से जो
सिस्टम अपडेट्स एक्टिविटीज़ हैं उसको उसको
मतलब मॉनिटरिंग से हटा दो। क्योंकि वो तो
सिस्टम अपडेट्स हैं तो उनको क्यों फालतू
के अलर्ट उनके लेना? कंसीडर ऑटोमेटिंग
अलर्ट ट्रैक फॉर मोस्ट कॉमन अलर्ट्स
यूजिंग सोर और कस्टम स्क्रिप्ट। अब सोर या
कस्टम स्क्रिप्ट। सोर जो होता है वो होता
है सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन ऑटोमेशन एंड
रिस्पांस। इट इज़ अ सॉल्यूशन दैट हेल्प्स
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन टू स्ट्रीमलाइन और ऑटोमेट
देयर सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशंस, इंसिडेंट
इंक्लूडिंग इंसिडेंट मैनेजमेंट, थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस एंड वनेबिलिटी रिस्पांस। तो
जितना भी होता है ना इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस,
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस, वनेबिलिटी रिस्पांस इन
सबको ऑटोमेट करने के लिए सोर प्लेटफॉर्म्स
को यूज़ में लिया जाता है। सो प्लेटफार्म
जो होते हैं आपके सिक्योरिटी, ऑर्केस्ट और
ऑर्केस्ट्रेशन, ऑटोमेशन एंड रिस्पांस।
कहीं मैंने एक बार सोनार भी शायद बोल दिया
था कहीं पे ऐसे करके। सोनार इज़ अ डिफरेंट
थिंग बट यहां पे सोर का यहां पे सोर की
बात हो रही है। राइट? तो ऑटोमेट करने की
कोशिश कीजिए। एल ट्राई को ऑटोमेट हो जाए।
मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट ओवर 30 मिनट। अ मीन
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट 30 मिनट से ज्यादा है।
लाइक यह भी थोड़ा दिक्कत है। योर टीम
डिटेक्ट अ थ्रेट विद अ हाई डिले। अभी 30
मिनट के बाद कोई थ्रेट डिटेक्ट होगा भाई
क्या से क्या हो जाएगा। राइट? कांटेक्ट
एसओसी इंजीनियर्स टू मेक द डिटेक्शन रूल्स
रन फास्ट वि और विद इन अ और वि अ हायर
रेट। तो एसओसी इंजीनियर्स को कांटेक्ट
कीजिए। उनको बताइए कि भैया जो यह रूल्स
होल्स है ना डिटेक्शन रूल्स थोड़ा
ट्यूनिंग करो। कुछ मस्त बनाओ कि
जल्दी-जल्दी डिटेक्ट हो यार। ऐसे कैसे
चलेगा? चेक इफ एसआईएम लॉक्स आर कलेक्टेड
इन रियल टाइम विद इन अ 10 मिनट डिले
विदाउट अ 10 मिनट डिले। और यह भी देखो कि
भाई एसआईएम के जो लॉक्स हैं वो रियल टाइम
में कलेक्ट भी हो रहे हैं। एसआईएम आपका
सही से काम कर रहा है नहीं तो फिर भी
गड़बड़ है। मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज ओवर 30
मिनट। अब एकनॉलेज भी किया जा रहा है। जैसे
अगर आपको रिपोर्ट मिल गया, अलर्ट मिल गया।
अब 30 मिनट के बाद आप एकनॉलेज कर रहे हो।
यानी कि एल1 एनालिस्ट स्टार्ट्स अलर्ट
ट्रैक विथ अ हाई डिले। एल1 एनालिस्ट जो है
ना वह मजेदार नहीं है। ही इज़ नॉट ही इज़
नॉट एबल ही इज़ नॉट बीन एबल टू एक्चुअली
ट्राई या गड़बड़ी है। इंश्योर द एनालिस्ट आर
नोटिफाइड इन रियल टाइम व्हेन अ न्यू अलर्ट
पीएस एनालिस्ट को नोटिफाई हुआ है। इसको
असोर कीजिए। ट्राई टू इवनली डिस्ट्रीब्यूट
अलर्ट्स इन क्यू बिटवीन द एनालिस्ट ऑन
शिफ्ट। या तो उस एनालिस्ट के पास बहुत
सारे अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं। बेचारे को अलर्ट
फैटी हो गया है। गुस्सा आ रहा है उसको।
क्या नहीं करूंगा मैं। नहीं नहीं हो
पाएगा। तो अलर्ट्स को डिस्ट्रीब्यूट कर
दीजिए मल्टीपल एंप्लाइज मल्टीपल एनुअल
एनालिस्ट्स को ताकि सब लोग अलग-अलग हैंडल
कर लें या S1 या ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि एल1
एनालिस्ट कैपेबल ही नहीं है उस टाइप का
उतना कि वो परफेक्टली कर पाए। ये भी चीज
है। राइट?
ये भी आपको ध्यान में रखना है।
ठीक है? मीन टाइम टू रिसोंड ओवर फोर
आवर्स। 4 घंटे से ज्यादा लग रहा है रिसोंड
या इमीडिएट करने में। तो एसओसी टीम कांट
स्टॉप द ब्रीच इन टाइम। तो ऐसा तो होगा तब
तो फिर यार ब्रीच ही नहीं 4 घंटे लग गए
अगर किसी अलर्ट को ट्र किसी अटैक को रोकने
में यह तो बहुत बड़ी बात है एज एल1 मेक
एवरीथिंग पॉस एज एल1 मेक एवरीथिंग पॉसिबल
टू क्विकली एस्केलेट द थ्रेट्स टू एल टू
ये आपके अंदर होना चाहिए कि तुरंत
एस्केलेट करें अगर कोई थ्रेट एक्चुअल एक
थ्रेट है पॉजिटिव थ्रेट है तो एनश्योर योर
टीम हैज़ डॉक्यूमेंटेड व्हाट टू डू
ड्यूरिंग द डिफरेंट अटैक सिनेरियोस और
सारी चीजें डॉक्यूमेंटेड हो कि क्या-क्या
करना है अटैक सिनेरियो में और व्हाट इज़ द
हाई हाईएस्ट एक्सेप्टेबल फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट फॉर एसओसी टीम। हाईएस्ट फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट एसओसी टीम के लिए क्या है? सो ऊपर
यहां लिखा हुआ है कि फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट
ओवर 80% यानी 80% से ऊपर अगर हो तो थोड़ी
गड़बड़ है। तो मैक्सिमम 80% तक जा रहा है
तो फिर भी थोड़ा चलेगा। वो भी ज्यादा है
बट चलेगा। शुड ऑल एसओसी रोल्स वर्क टुगेदर
टू कीप मैट्रिक्स इंप्रूविंग? जितने भी
एसओसी रोल्स हैं सबको साथ में काम करना
चाहिए। मैट्रिक्स को इंप्रूव करने के लिए
शुड बताइए।
सॉरी सर आई एम अनेबल टू अटेंड द लाइव ड्यू
टू सम रीज़ंस बट
ऑल इज वाचिंग रिकॉर्डिंग। दैट्स ग्रेट।
कोई बात नहीं हंटर।
सो यस। तो इसका वाई ये ये सबको साथ में
काम करना चाहिए। बिल्कुल। यस। चलिए अब आते
हैं प्रैक्टिस सिनेरियो जो कि लास्ट
सिनेरियो है आपका उसके बाद सेशन एंड हो
जाएगा। लास्ट सिनेरियो में प्रैक्टिस में
आ जाते हैं। व्हाइल मैट्रिक्स ट्रैकिंग इज
यूजुअली एसओसी मैनेजर्स जॉब। देखो
मैट्रिक्स को ट्रैक करना है। एसओसी
मैनेजर्स का यह जॉब है। अ टेक्निकल पर्सन
इज़ ऑलवेज रिक्वायर्ड टू प्रोप टू प्रोपोज
एनवायर इंप्रूवमेंट्स और हाईलाइट्स द इशू।
एज़ एन एसओसी एल1 यू आर द फर्स्ट टू नोटिस
एक्सेसिव अलर्ट नंबर्स और अ हाई फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव रेट। सो मेक श्योर यू नो हाउ टू
कम्युनिकेट द इशू एंड व्हाट टू डू टू
फिक्स इट। वैसे तो मैनेजर का यह काम है
एसओसी मैनेजर्स जो होते हैं मैट्रिक्स
ट्रैकिंग करना। बट एसओसी एल1 के तौर पे
आपको इसका आईडिया होना चाहिए कि कैसे ये
चीजें काम करती है, कैसे हैंडल करती है।
तो तीन तीन यहां पे फ्लैग्स हैं। तीनों
फ्लैग्स हमें व्यू साइट पे चलकर प्रैक्टिस
करनी है। क्या यहां पे? फॉर दिस लैब,
इमेजिन योरसेल्फ एज अ एसओसी मैनेजर। आपको
खुद को अब एसओसी मैनेजर इसके लिए समझना
है। एनालिस्ट एल1 नहीं है आप थोड़े सीनियर
हो गए हैं, मैनेजर हो गए हैं। रिसीविंग
डिफरेंट कंप्लेंट्स रिलेटेड टू एसओसी टीम।
एसओसी टीम से अलग-अलग कंप्लेंट्स आ रही
है। ओपन द अटैच साइट्स बाय क्लिकिंग व्यू
साइट बटन एंड ट्राई टू इंप्रूव एसओसी
मैट्रिक्स अक्रॉस थ्री सिनेरियोस। एसओसी
मैट्रिक्स को इंप्रूव करना है। बाय
करेक्टली असाइनिंग इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क
फ्रॉम द लिस्ट। इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क जो है
उस लिस्ट से निकालना है। करेक्ट टास्क
असाइन करना है। दैट्स इट। वंस कंप्लीटेड
क्लेम द फ्लैग। ठीक है? चलिए अच्छी बात
है। हम यहां पर आ गए। पहला है अनहै
कस्टमर। कस्टमर ही खुश नहीं है भाई। यह
रिक्वेस्ट फ्रॉम एमडीआर टॉप मैनेजमेंट।
मतलब कि एमडीआर की टॉप मैनेजमेंट है कोई।
ठीक है? अह उससे रिक्वेस्ट आई है अनहैपी
कस्टमर्स के लिए। क्या आई है? डियर एसओसी
मैनेजर आवर बिगेस्ट कस्टमर ओपन डोर आईएसी।
हमारा एक बिगेस्ट कस्टमर ओपन डोर आई एनसी
वाज़ डिसएटिस्फाइड विथ हाउ वी हैंडल
ब्रीचेस। हम कैसे ब्रीचेस को हैंडल करते
हैं? उससे सेटिस्फाइड नहीं है। व्हेन देयर
सीएफओस ईमेल एंड इंट्रा आईडी अकाउंट वेर
ब्रीज्ड। उनके सीएफओ का चीफ फाइनेंसियल
ऑफिसर का इंट्रा आईडी यानी कि Microsoft
Azure आईडी और
ईमेल जो है वह ब्रीच हो गया। इट टूक अस
ऑलमोस्ट 6 आवर्स टू किक आउट द हैकर फ्रॉम
द मेल बॉक्स। हमें 6 घंटे लग गए भाई हैकर
को मेल बॉक्स से भगाने में। 6 घंटे लग गए।
एंड थ्रेट एक्टर्स हैड इनफ टाइम टू डंप ऑल
ईमेल्स एंड लीक देम ऑन डार्क नेट। और
थ्रेट एक्टर्स ने जो क्या किया? सारे
ईमेल्स को डंप कर दिया और डार्क नेट पे
डाल दिया। लुकिंग एट द रिपोर्ट लुक्स लाइक
वी हैड अ क्रिटिकल अलर्ट एंड स्पेंट फाइव
आवर्स ट्राइंग टू प्रॉपर्ली रिसेट द
विक्टिम्स इंट्रा आईडी पासवर्ड एन एफए।
लुक्स लाइक वी हैड अ क्रिटिकल अलर्ट।
क्रिटिकल अर्थी एंड स्पेंड फाइव आवर्स
ट्राइंग टू प्रॉपर्ली रिसेट द विक्टिम्स
इंट्रा आईडी पासवर्ड एंड मल्टीफैक्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन। हाउ कुड इट हैपन एंड व्हाट
वुड योर एक्शन?
5 घंटे लगे रिसेट वोसेट करने में। 6 घंटे
इसको लगे हैं भैया।
रिकवरी करने में, हैकर को हटाने में। ठीक
है? अब देखो
प्रॉब्लमेटिक मैट्रिक क्या है? यहां पे
सबसे पहले प्रॉब्लमेटिक मैट्रिक क्या है?
इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क क्या होगा और असाइन
टास्क टू किसको असाइन करना है यह चीज़ तो
प्रॉब्लमेटिक मैट्रिक क्या है? टाइम टू
रिसोंड वाज़ टू हाई
टू मच टाइम स्पेंट टू कंटेन द अटैक। टाइम
टू रिसोंड वाज़ टू हाइट। ठीक है? एक है
यहां पे टाइम टू एकनॉलेज वाज़ टू हाई।
एनालिस्ट स्टार्टेड द ट्रैक टू लेट। दो
चीज़ हैं। तो देखो यहां पे क्या हो रहा है?
यहां पर हो रहा है कि
इट टूक अस ऑलमोस्ट 6 आवर्स टू किक आउट द
हैकर फ्रॉम द मिल बॉक्स। और यहां पर एक आ
रहा है स्पेंड फाइव आवर्स ट्राइंग टू
प्रॉपर्ली रिसेट द विक्टिमा आई। यानी कि
टाइम टू रिसोंड
यहां पे टाइम टू रिसोंड जो लास्ट वाला एक
है रिमीडिएट करने का वो काफी हाई है। ठीक
है? तो हम इसको एक यहां पे डालते हैं।
देखते हैं क्या होता है। डाल दिया हमने।
टाइम टू रिस्पोंड बहुत हाई था।
इंप्रूवमेंट क्या कर सकते हैं भैया?
इंप्रूवमेंट है
क्रिएट अ वर्क बुक एक्सप्लेनिंग
क्रेडेंशियल रोटेशन स्टेप्स एंड प्रेजेंट
इट टू द टीम। असाइन द डेवलपमेंट टास्क टू
द एसोसिएट इंजीनियर रिस्पांसिबल फॉर द
नोटिफिकेशन।
ठीक है? ट्यून अ नोटिफिकेशन सिस्टम टू
इमीडिएटली कॉल एल1 आफ्टर न्यू ईच न्यू
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट।
ट्यून अ नोटिफिकेशन सिस्टम टू इमीडिएटली
कॉल एल एल1 आफ्टर ईच न्यू क्रिटिकल अलर्ट।
यह एक इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क हो सकता है। एक
इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क हो सकता है। असाइन द
डेवलपमेंट टास्क टू द एसोसिएट इंजीनियर
रेस्पोंसिबल फॉर द नोटिफिकेशन। ये तो अभी
है ही नहीं। ये तो असाइन टास्क वाला जो
कॉलम है उसमें आएगा। असाइन वाले में असाइन
वाले आएंगे। तो देखो असाइन वाले दो हैं तो
इनको छोड़ दो। टाइम टू एकनॉलेज वाज़ टू।
इसको भी छोड़ दो। तो अब बच गए ये दो। कौन
से आएंगे? क्रिएट अ वर्क बुक एक्सप्लेनिंग
क्रेडेंशियल रोटेट स्टेप्स एंड प्रेजेंट
इट टू द टीम। क्रेडेंशियल रोटेशन
उसको स्टेप्स को इंट्रोड्यूस करना या तो
ट्यून अ नोटिफिकेशन सिस्टम टू इमीडिएटली
कॉल एल1 आफ्टर ईच न्यू क्रिटिकल अलर्ट। यह
भी हो सकता है कि हम ट्यून कर दें
नोटिफिकेशन सिस्टम को कि हर अलर्ट के बाद
तुरंत जो है वह कॉल जाए एल1 एनालिस्ट को
क्योंकि यहां पर रिसोंड करने में टाइम लगा
है तो क्रिएट अ वर्क बुक एक्सप्लेनिंग
क्रेडेंशियल रोटेशंस और यह तो हम यह वाली
चीज ज्यादा अच्छा समझ पा रहे हैं कि एल1
को कॉल जाए हर कुछ-कुछ देर पे और असाइन
टास्क टू असाइन द डेवलपमेंट टास्क टू
एसोसिएट इंजीनियर रेस्पोंसिबल फॉर द
नोटिफिकेशन और यह हम नोटिफिकेशन के लिए।
तो अब यहां पे जब हमने डाला तो यहां पे अब
आ रहा है चूज़ इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क गलत है।
व्हाट ब्रिंग्स द नियर रिजल्ट एंड चूज़ इन
असाइन इज़ नॉट द राइट। क्योंकि हमने यहां
पे इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क भी गलत चूज़ किया था
और असाइन टास्क भी गलत। अब इसके इसके
अकॉर्डिंग हमने गलत किया। हमने अपने
अकॉर्डिंग जो चूज़ किया वो हमारे अकॉर्डिंग
सही था। हमने एक अपना सिनेरियो चूज़ किया
उसको डाला। एसओसी के लिए हर आंसर गलत भी
नहीं होता। हर आंसर सही भी नहीं होता। तो
आपने अपने अकॉर्डिंग सही किया। बट इसके
अकॉर्डिंग ट्राईक के अकॉर्डिंग हमें क्या
करना है? उसके लिए हम अब डिफरेंट सिनेरियो
चूज़ करेंगे कि प्रॉब्लमेटिक मैट्रिक तो
वही है कि टाइम टू रिसोंड वास टू हाई जो
बिल्कुल सही बात है। एमटीटीआर अब
इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क में यहां पे जैसा कि
हमने पहले क्या किया कि एक करो
यहां पे एल1 को कॉल करने का। तो हम अब
वर्कब को बनाते हैं। क्रिएट अ वर्कब और
क्रेडेंशियल रोटेशन स्टेप्स को इसमें
इंट्रोड्यूस करते हैं कि क्रेडेंशियल्स को
हमेशा रोटेट किया जाए हर कुछ-कुछ टाइम पे।
ऐसा किया जाए। और इसको असाइन किसको
करेंगे? तो असाइन द डेवलपमेंट असाइन द
रिसर्च एंड वर्क बुक क्रिएशन टास्क टू L2
द हैंडल द इंसिडेंट तो यहां पे क्या असाइन
द यहां पे क्रिएट अ वर्क बुक एक्सप्लेन द
तो असाइन द L2 तो L2 को यहां पे करेंगे
दैट्स इट खत्म तो हम दूसरे सिनेरियो में
बिल्कुल सही थे क्योंकि हम पहले सिनेरियो
में भी सही थे हमने एक अलग मोटिवेट एक अलग
मोटिव से किया काम हमने एक अलग तरीके से
काम किया हमने एक नोटिफिकेशन सिस्टम बनाने
के लिए बोला तो उसके लिए हम सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर को ही एसोसिएट इंजीनियर को ही
बोलेंगे तो हमने वो भी सही किया था बट
यहां कहां पे? क्योंकि ट्राईकमी में
इन्होंने फ्लैग इसी चीज पे डाल के रखा हुआ
है। कई बार क्या होता है ट्राईक जैसे
प्लेटफॉर्म्स में आप एक चीज ध्यान में
रखिएगा कि आपको उनके अकॉर्डिंग ही कई बार
सॉल्व करना पड़ता है। अगर उनके अकॉर्डिंग
आप सॉल्व नहीं करेंगे तो आपको फ्लैग नहीं
मिलेगा क्योंकि फ्लैग उसी पे सेट है। तो
हमने जो किया था वो भी सही था। याद रखिएगा
दैट वाज़ आल्सो अ करेक्ट अप्रोच। उसको गलत
बोल ही नहीं सकते।
बट टू गेट द फ्लैग वी नीड टू फॉलो देयर
स्टेप्स। तो हमने यहां पे फ्लैग ले लिया।
हमने यहां पे डाला एंड इट्स डन।
होगी। राइट? अब यहां पे दूसरा स्टेप करते
हैं। डिलेड अलर्ट। यह आया हुआ है। चैट
मैसेज फ्रॉम द हेड ऑफ द आईटी। हेड ऑफ़ द
आईटी से चैट मैसेज आया हुआ है। क्या आया
हुआ है? डिलेड अलर्ट के बारे में। हे
थैंक्स फॉर द एसओसी डेमो फॉर आवर टॉप
मैनेजमेंट।
ठीक है? दे लव्ड योर रैंसमवेयर समुलेशन।
ठीक है? रैंसमवेयर स्यूुलेशन को उन्होंने
बहुत पसंद किया। एंड वेर शॉक्ड एट हाउ योर
टीम मैनेज टू स्टॉप द अटैक इन 40 मिनट्स।
एंड मजा आ गया उनको कि 40 मिनट में अटैक
रोक दिया तुमने। हाउएवर फॉर द फर्स्ट 20
मिनट्स एवरीवन वाज़ जस्ट लुकिंग एट द
स्क्रीन वेटिंग फॉर सम अलर्ट्स टू अपीयर।
20 मिनट्स तक अलर्ट के लिए इंतजार करते
रहे। यानी अलर्ट देर हुआ है। यानी मीन
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट
देर हुई है। इट वुड बी नाइस टू समऊ
रिड्यूस दिस ह्यूज डिले। व्हाट डू यू
थिंक? तो मीन टाइम टू डिटेक्ट। तो यहां पे
प्रॉब्लमेटिक यही होना चाहिए कि
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट ऑफ 20 मिनट लेड टू अ डिले
अलर्ट ट्रैक। टाइम टू अ यह प्रॉब्लमेटिक
यही होना चाहिए। ठीक है? यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं। ये ये हमारा प्रॉब्लम होना
चाहिए।
टाइम टू डिटेक्ट 20 मिनट्स। ये एक बड़ा
प्रॉब्लमेटिक है। अब इसका इंप्रूवमेंट
कैसे कर सकते हैं भैया? तो यह असाइन वाला
तो छोड़ दो। असाइन असाइन वाला होगा। ठीक
है? ट्यून द एसआईएम। यहां पे अब आ रहा है
अलर्ट काउंट वास टू बिग लीडिंग टू द डिले
इन एल1 रिस्पांस। ये तो हटा दो। आस्क एल1
एनालिस्ट टू पीरियडिकली रिव्यू रॉ लॉग्स
इंस्टीड ऑफ़ रिलाइंग ऑन अलर्ट्स। ठीक है?
ट्यून द एसआईएम एंड द डिटेक्शन रूल्स टू
रन मोर ऑफेन एव्री 5 मिनट्स। ठीक है?
डिटेक्शन रूल्स टू अब देखो, यह भी हो सकता
है और यह भी हो। दोनों ही इसका आंसर हो
सकते हैं। इसका आंसर दोनों बट उसका इन
दोनों के आंसर पे डिपेंड करता है फ्लैग।
फ्लैग आपको काहे किससे मिलने वाली है वो
हम देखेंगे। तो यहां पे एक ऑप्शन आ रहा है
ट्यून द एसआईएम एंड डिटेक्शन रूल्स टू रन
मोर ऑफ एन एव्री 5 मिनट्स। ये आपका आ रहा
है। तो चलो हम इंप्रूवमेंट इसको डाल देते
हैं। अब असाइन किसको करेंगे? क्योंकि ये
डिटेक्शन रूल को बा रूल की बात आ रही है।
तो एसोसिएट इंजीनियर्स की यहां पे आ रही
है। तो असाइन द डिटेक्शन रूल शेड्यूल
रिव्यू टू डेडिकेटेड एसोसिएट इंजीनियर।
असाइन द टास्क टू इंप्लीमेंट द रॉ लीगल
प्रोसेस सीनियर। तो यह डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर
यह कर दिया फ़ैग मिल गया। अब इन्होंने इस
तरीके से सेट किया था। बट हम अगर दूसरे
तरीके से भी करते वह भी सही था। दैट
अप्रोच वाज़ आल्सो राइट कि हम एक अलग
अप्रोच यूज़ कर रहे हैं टू रिज़ॉल्व दैट
क्वरी टू रिज़ॉल्व दैट प्रॉब्लम। राइट? तो
हमें भाई खैर इनके अकॉर्डिंग ही मिल गया।
तो हमने यहां से हमें फ्लैग ढूंढना है
भाई। फ्लैग लेना है तो हमने कर दिया। एंड
यहां पे फ्लैग लेके पेस्ट करके चेक कर
दिया।
बस सिंपल। दैट्स इट। डन।
अब यहां पर आता है लास्ट है ईमेल फ्रॉम
एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट्स। एसओसी एल1 के तरफ
से ईमेल आई है। टायर्ड एनालिस्ट
टायर्ड है बेचारे टायर्ड थके हुए हैं।
डियर एसोसिएट मैनेजर ऑन बिहाफ ऑफ़ ऑल
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट सारे एसोसिएटि एनालिस्ट
के कमेट के बिहाफ में हम दोनों हम सब ने
एक टीम बनाई है। हम सब रिवोल्ट करने वाले
हैं। आई वांट टू रेज़ एन इशू दैट मे
रिक्वायर योर हेल्प ऑन एन एवरेज ड्यूरिंग
एन 8 आवर शिफ्ट। आवर एल1 एनालिस्ट क्लोज
760 अलर्ट्स 760 अलर्ट्स अलर्ट फैटी की
बात है बहुत ज्यादा अलर्ट्स है 95% व्हिच
आर सिस्टम नॉइज़ 95% या ध्यान रखना यह
मैट्रिक्स 95% तो सिस्टम नॉइज़ है और आईटी
टीम और ऑटोमेशन स्क्रिप्ट्स ठीक है आईटी
टीम और ऑटोमेशन स्क्रिप्ट से 90% 95% जो
है वो सिस्टम नॉइज़ है। इट इज़ इंपॉसिबल टु
परफॉर्म अ विजिलेंट ट्रैग विथ सच अ बिग
लोड एंड एनालिस्ट्स आर स्टार्टिंग टु गेट
एग्जॉस्टेड। मोर ओवर एज़ द कंपनी ग्रोज़ वी
रिसीव मोर एंड मोर अलर्ट्स। कैन यू हेल्प
अस विथ इट? प्लीज। अब देखो प्रॉब्लम क्या
है यहां पे कि भैया अलर्ट फैटिक हो रही
है। बहुत ज्यादा नॉइज़ है। यह प्रॉब्लम है।
तो देखो अब असाइन असाइन छोड़ दो। अब यहां
पे है
शेड्यूल अ कॉल। यह थॉट असाइन द टास्क। ठीक
है? मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज इज द मेन इशू
हियर। मीन टाइम द मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज
क्या मेन इशू है? नहीं। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट्स इज द कोर ऑफ़ द प्रॉब्लम। ये है
क्योंकि फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट्स बहुत ज्यादा
हो रहे हैं। तो मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज की तो
बात ही नहीं आती है। पहली ये पहली बात
क्योंकि पहले तो यहां पे प्रॉब्लम यही है
ना कि फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स बहुत ज्यादा आ रहा
है। या लॉट ऑफ़ फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स इज़ द कोर
ऑफ़ द प्रॉब्लम। तो ठीक है। मेन टाइम टू
एकनॉलेज। ये तो एकनॉलेज की बात आती है।
डिटेक्ट के बाद एकनॉलेज होती है ना। तो
अभी एक्नॉलेज में हमारा कहां है? अभी तो
डिटेक्ट वाली बात है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट
ही इतनी वो है। तो हम पहले इसको लेके चलते
हैं। ठीक है? देखते हैं। लेट्स सी इफ इट
इज़ वर्किंग। इंप्रूवमेंट क्या है?
शेड्यूल अ कॉल विद द टीम टू इंप्लीमेंट द
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेमडेशन प्रोसेस। आस्क द
असाइन द टास्क टू द एल1 एनालिस्ट टू
कंट्रोल एंड इंप्लीमेंट द प्रोपोज्ड
चेंजेस। असाइन वाला यह तो हटाओ। चेंज द
ट्रैग रूल टू ट्रैग ओनली क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स
एंड इग्नोर द लो सीवियरिटी वंस। तो यह भी
हो सकता है कि क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स को ओनली
ट्राई करे लो सीवियरिटी को हटा दे। यह भी
एक फंडा हो सकता है। अब जब क्रिटिकल अलर्ट
को ट्राई करना है और लो सीवियरिटी को
हटाना है तो इसके लिए क्या होगा? असाइन द
टास्क टू एसोसिएट इंजीनियर्स टू एक्सक्लूड
द सिस्टम एंड आईटी नॉइस फ्रॉम द रूल्स।
ठीक है? और असाइन द टास्क टू एल1 एनएस टू
कंट्रोल एंड इंप्लीमेंट द प्रोपोट चेंजेस।
तो ये हो सकता है। राइट? अब ये जो चीज़
हमने करी तो इसमें आ रहा है इंप्रूवमेंट
टास्क वन ब्रिंग यू द नीडेड रिजल्ट। अभी
इन्होंने बोला कि इंप्रूवमेंट टास्क हमारा
रिजल्ट नहीं लाएगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है
दोनों ही गलत हो जाते हैं। इंप्रूवमेंट
उन्होंने डाला है चेंज द ट्रैक रूल्स टू
ट्रैक ओनली क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स। हमने यही
चीज डाली है इंप्रूवमेंट में कि ट्रैक
क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स को ट्राई करे। बट इनके
अकॉर्डिंग ये सही नहीं है। क्योंकि ये
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेट्स को वो नहीं करेंगे।
चलो हम इसको हटा भी देते हैं। हम अपना
इसका नॉर्मल जो वो चीज है कि हम फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव रिस्क बहुत हाई है। मान लो इसके
अकॉर्डिंग कर रहे हैं। तो इंप्रूवमेंट
टास्क में हम यहां पे इसको हम अलग करते
हैं। असाइन टास्क टू हम कि हम मीन टाइम टू
नहीं शेड्यूल और कॉल विद द टीम टू
इंप्लीमेंट द फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेमडीएशन
प्रोसेस। इसका मतलब यह है कि रेमडेशन
प्रोसेस हम टीम को करके वो करें और एल1
एनालिस्ट जो हैं उनको हम डाल दें कि भैया
द असाइन इज़ नॉट द राइट। ठीक है?
इसको एक बार फिर से एक बार देखते हैं।
लेट्स सी प्रॉब्लम प्रॉब्लम क्या है? मीन
टाइम टू एकनॉलेज नहीं है। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव
रेट है। चलो हमने कर दिया। अब यहां पे
करते हैं। असाइन द टास्क टू एसोसिएशन
नहीं। चेंज द ट्रैक रूल टू ट्रैग ओनली
नहीं। शेड्यूल अ कॉल। हां। चलो ये
इंप्रूवमेंट है। शेड्यूल अ कॉल विद द टीम
टू इंप्लीमेंट द फॉल्स पॉजिटिव रेमडीशन
प्रोसेस। अब फॉल्स पॉजिटिव के रेमिडेशन
प्रोसेस पे काम करने के लिए कॉल करने के
लिए कि भैया फॉल्स पॉजिटिव जो हो रहे हैं
उसके रेमिडेशन पे काम करो। अब इसमें क्या
हो रहा है?
अब इसमें क्या हो रहा है? व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग हियर? असाइन द टास्क टू एल1
एनालिस्ट टू कंट्रोल एंड इंप्लीमेंट द
प्रोपोज चेंजेस। ठीक है? दूसरा है असाइन द
टास्क टू एसोसिएशन इंजीनियर टू इंक्लूड द
सिस्टम एंड आईटी नॉइज़ चेंज द ट्रैग रूल टू
ट्रैग ओनली क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स एंड इग्नोर द
लो सीवियरिटी अलर्ट्स एंड ये चीज़ ये चीज़
सारी आ रही है। तो अब इसमें हमारा असाइन
टास्क करना है। तो असाइन इन दोनों में से
कोई एक होगा। तो हम एसओसी इंजीनियर को
असाइन करके एक बार देख लेते हैं। व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग? तो इन्होंने उस पे दे दिया है कि
एसओसी इंजीनियर को असाइन कर देते हैं। और
यह करते हैं बोलते हैं कि आईटी और सिस्टम
नॉइज़ को हटाओ और बाकी कॉल शेड्यूल कर लो
वि द टीम टू इंप्लीमेंट फेक जो फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव रिमडेशन प्रोसेस है उसको हम असाइन
करने के लिए करते हैं। राइट? तो बस ये चीज़
करके यहां पे हमें वो मिल जाता है। राइट?
तो हम इसको कॉपी करके यहां पे पेस्ट कर
देते हैं। यहां पे चेक कर लेते हैं। दैट्स
इट। यहां पे हमारा ये प्रोसेस भी कंप्लीट
हो गया। और यहां पे कंक्लूजन वाले में डाल
के यह भी हमारा कंप्लीट हो चुका है। वी
कंप्लीटेड दिस आल्सो दैट्स इट। तो हमने
यहां पर सिंपली यहां पर क्या कर लिया
भैया?
हमने यहां पे इस वाले अ
पैटर्न को भी हमने इसको मैट्रिक्स एंड
ऑब्जेक्टिव्स को भी हमने यहां पे समझ
लिया। हमने इसको फाइनल कर लिया है। एंड वी
क्लियर्ड इट। राइट? सो, हमने इस चीज को भी
पूरा कवर कर लिया। राइट?
दैट्स इट। तो, आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ
चुका होगा। यह क्या है भाई? यू हैव
अनलॉक्ड स्ट क्या है यह?
ओके पता नहीं ठीक है व्हाटएवर
दैट्स इट गाइस सो वी डीड इट एंड दैट्स इट
खत्म तो यहां पे हमने ये चीज जो कवर कर
लिया है वी डीड इट एंड दैट्स इट मजा आ गया
फिर ऐसे करके राइट सो दिस वाज़ ऑल फॉर टुडे
सेशन। आई होप यू एंजॉयड द सेशन गाइस। काफी
लंबा सेशन आज का हो गया है। आई नो बट इट
वाज़ वर्दी। आई होप इट वाज़ वर्दी फॉर यू।
आपके लिए काफी वर्दी लगा होगा। आपको काफी
मजा आया होगा। सीखने को मिला होगा आज की
क्लास में। काफी चीजें काफी चीजें हमने
सीखी है। काफी चीजें हमने देखी हैं। मजा
आपको जरूर आया होगा। ऐसे ही आप कंटिन्यू
रहिए। आपको मजा आता रहेगा। टॉप फैंस की एक
बार लिस्ट देख लेते हैं। ये टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट है हमारे पास जो जनरली रेगुलर रहते
हैं प्रेजेंट। उनमें से काफी लोग हैं। कुछ
लोग लीव भी कर चुके हैं। बट कोई बात नहीं।
कांग्रेचुलेशंस एवरीबॉडी फॉर बीइंग इन अ
टॉप फैंस लिस्ट। क्योंकि आप लोग बहुत ही
रेगुलर बेसिस पर यहां पर अभी आप प्रेजेंट
हैं। इट वास गुड एंड कई लोग तो काफी शुरू
से ले लास्ट तक अभी तक टिके हुए हैं। कुछ
लोग निकल चुके हैं। वो लोग रिकॉर्डिंग
देखेंगे उनको समझ में आएगा। ठीक है? चलो
आई होप कि आपको काफी कुछ सीखने को मिला है
इस सेशन से। बस आप एक काम कर दीजिएगा इस
सेशन को शेयर कर दीजिएगा अपने दोस्तों के
बीच में। आज 7:00 बजे से 10:00 बजे तक 3
घंटे की सेशन हो गई है। अपने दोस्तों के
बीच शेयर कर दीजिएगा इसको और जब
रिकॉर्डिंग देखिएगा हाइप का बटन होगा।
हाइप कर दिया कीजिएगा वीडियोस को। YouTube
उसको शेयर उसको ज्यादा रिकमेंड करती है।
YouTube उसको प्रमोट भी करती है खुद से ही
और लोगों तक पहुंचता है। और जितनी वीडियोस
आप शेयर करते हैं वो मैक्सिमम ऑडियंस तक
पहुंचती है। ऐसे लोगों तक जिनको इस सीरीज
की कई ज्यादा जरूरत है। एंड जो महंगे
कॉस्टली कोर्सेज अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते उनको
यह एसओसी एल1 की फ्री जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग
मिल जाती है आपकी शेयर करने की वजह से। तो
आप भी कहीं ना कहीं एक अच्छा एक एक एक
अच्छी स्टेप ले रहे हैं। एक अच्छा
चीज कर रहे हैं कि आप वीडियोस को शेयर कर
रहे हैं। लोगों तक वो चीज पहुंचा रहे हैं
जो उन तक नहीं पहुंच पा रही है जनरली। सो
गाइस थैंक यू वेरी मच। अब आज के लिए मैं
आपसे विदा लेता हूं। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में। एंड गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि टू
एवरीबॉडी। टेक केयर एंड जल्दी मिलेंगे
नेक्स्ट सेशन में। थैंक यू वेरी मच।